The State Board will reconvene for the second day of our meeting.
I would like to report out that the in closed session, the board discussed or took action on the following case, Kapim versus Torlakson et al.
And before we begin the public hearing and before we begin the whole proceeding with the department presentation, I'd like to get the two action items left that we must take up.
These are in item 17.
One is the under SBE priorities and one would be the approval of our minutes and the other would be the approval of our ACSS new members for the Advisory Commission on Charter School.
And CPEG.
So, yeah.
Thank you, President Kirst.
I'd be happy to make a motion to approve the minutes if you'd like to get that out of the way.
Yes, I would.
Second.
Is there any discussion by the board?
No?
No public comment on that?
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay.
So the next item is you have an addendum item 17.
And these are recommendations from the screening committee for appointments and reappointments to our various advisory committees.
Before I begin, I just want to say that again, as I mentioned yesterday with respect to the student recruitment, very strong applicant pool, lots of interest in serving.
So very much appreciative of that.
And it's gratifying that there's the level of civic engagement that we have.
So I'm going to...member's son is gone.
She had to recuse for ACCS.
I'm just going to read these quickly because not everybody who's streaming will have this document.
We recruited for three committees.
With respect to the ACCS, I want to express my appreciation to board member Williams and our staff, Carolyn Pfister and Cindy Chan, who actually came back from retirement to help us with this.
And these are our recommendations for appointment and reappointment.
To represent the parent on the ACCS, we're recommending Jared Austin.
He's the executive director of Kairos Public School in the Vacaville area.
We're also recommending reappointment of the following individuals.
Ari Engelberg, who will serve in an at-large position.
He's the executive director of Bright Star Schools.
Mark Ryan, who's the superintendent of North Valley Military Institute in the Los Angeles area, will represent charter school administrators.
And Wes Seaver, who's the superintendent of Kingsburg Elementary Charter School District, will represent district superintendents.
So that's the ACCS.
And I'm going to just ask for a motion on all of these at the end.
Oh, sorry.
Okay, I take that back.
I move that we approve the appointment and reappointment of the members to the ACCS.
Second.
All those in favor, respond.
Okay, thank you.
While Ting is coming back in, I'm going to tell you about the California Practitioner Advisory Group.
We're recommending appointment of three individuals for three-year terms, starting with Nancy Portillo.
Nancy is the Assistant Superintendent in the Archdiocese of Los Angeles.
She's representing private school children.
Tarina Small, who's a teacher at Sciatech in the San Diego area.
She's representing teachers from charter schools.
And Jesse Levin, who's a principal researcher for AIR, and he's representing educational researchers.
We're also recommending the reappointment of Joanne Ishkin.
Joanne is the interim director at UCLA's teacher education program.
She's also representing educational researchers.
So that's CPAP.
Can we have a motion on that?
I'm going.
We're also recommending the reappointment of Edmon Ansalo, who's the county superintendent, Eldorado County, who's representing superintendents.
Karen Monroe, the superintendent, Alameda County, who's representing authorizers of charter schools.
And Araceli Simeon, who's a parent organization network project director for Asian Americans Advancing Justice.
She's representing parents.
of students currently enrolled in K-12 schools.
So that's CPAG.
We can do CPAG and IQC together.
The next group is for recommendations for appointment to the Instructional Quality Commission.
for a four-year term.
And thanks to my colleagues on the screening committee, Feliza Ortiz-Lincoln and Eileen Strauss, as well as Stephanie and her staff.
First recommendation is Shay Fairchild.
Shay is a curriculum specialist in Norwalk La Mirada.
She will be representing the expertise area of elementary education.
Jose Lara, who's a social studies teacher in LA Unified, he's going to help us on ethnic studies.
Christine Chapman is a principal of Delano Union School District.
She will help with mathematics.
And we're recommending also Yolanda Munoz, who's a teacher in Pasadena Unified.
She'll help us on special education.
And we are also going to recommend an appointment now for beginning January 1, 2019 of Deborah Costa Hernandez.
She's the executive director of the
subject matter project at the University of California and she's going to be representing elementary education and I move appointments and reappointments to those two committees.
Any discussion by the board?
If not, raise your hand.
Okay, that completes that action part of that item.
We still
I have the board member comments about developments in their various activities.
So now I'm ready for us to take up item 18.
History, Social Studies Adoption of K-8 Instructional Materials.
Instructional Quality Commission Recommendations.
This is an action item and has a public hearing.
So we're going to start with the CDE presenter, Stephanie Gregson.
Then we're going to have the guest presenters from the IQC.
We think it's important that SBE members hold their questions both technical and substantive until after the public comment in its entirety.
And so why don't we begin with Stephanie.
Good morning, everyone.
Good morning, Board President Kirsch, Superintendent Torlakson, and honorable members of the board.
My name is Stephanie Gregson.
I have the pleasure of serving as the Executive Director of the Instructional Quality Commission, and I'd like to thank you for spending the day with us today.
Before I begin introductions and the formal presentation, I'd like to acknowledge and appreciate the many participants in this process, including my staff at the Department of Education, the 99 instructional materials reviewers and content review experts, the commissioners, and the many people and groups who participated throughout this process.
As we know, history social science is an inquiry-based discipline that relies on reason, debate, and evidence to support positions with the goal of a greater civic understanding.
This, in part, explains the passionate participation and debate about instructional materials for California's classrooms.
With this understanding, let me share with you the extensive review process that the Instructional Quality Commission, instructional material reviewers, and content reviewer experts engaged in to ensure high quality instructional materials for our students.
To help me present this process and recommendations of the Instructional Quality Commission, I have with me Bill Honig, Chair of the History Social Science Subject Matter Committee of the Instructional Quality Commission, and Lizette Diaz, Chair of the Instructional Quality Commission.
Commissioner Honig will briefly review the instructional shifts from the History Social Science Framework that are represented in the instructional materials recommended by the IQC.
Chair Diaz will then present the recommendations of the Instructional Quality Commission.
But first, I get to walk you through the process that has brought us in front of you today.
The adoption process is a lengthy one with many steps that are defined in statute and in the California Code of Regulations.
Here is an overview of the major milestones that have brought us to this meeting today.
In some ways, this process began in July of 2016 when the State Board of Education adopted the new history social science framework.
The new curriculum framework has been the basis for this adoption, both because of the new content and instructional shifts throughout the document and the fact that the evaluation criteria used for this adoption is part of the framework.
At the same meeting, the board approved the schedule of significant events and the reviewer application for the adoption.
After the framework was adopted, the CDE conducted initial briefings of publishers in participating in the adoption.
These briefings took place in July and September of 2016 and focused on the content of the new curriculum framework and how the instructional shifts would translate into instructional materials.
In January of this year, the state board appointed instructional material reviewers and content review experts that were recommended by the Instructional Quality Commission.
The board also approved two non-commissioners to serve as review panel facilitators.
On January 18, 2017, the California Department of Education hosted the publisher's invitation to submit meeting where the statutory and regulatory requirements for participation in the adoption process were explained.
This meeting was open to the public and invited public comment.
Title V regulations require a majority of instructional material reviewers be classroom teachers in the area of history social science.
I think that's a great benefit to our process.
The board appointed 73 classroom teachers out of a total of 99 reviewers for 10 panels.
Per the Title V regulations, each panel had a board-appointed content review expert with a doctoral degree in the area of history social science.
The panels also included board-appointed curriculum leaders and community members.
All reviewers received a week-long training at the lovely Doubletree in Sacramento from April 24th through 28th.
Their chocolate chip cookies were the best.
The board-appointed reviewers were trained to evaluate the submitted programs for alignment with the standards, framework, and evaluation criteria adopted by the board.
Reviewers had the privilege of being sworn in by Board Member Rucker.
On the final day of the training, reviewers attended presentations by the publishers of the programs that they were assigned to review.
The reviewer training was an open meeting, and public comment was called for each day of the training.
During the summer following the training, each reviewer conducted an independent and extensive review of the instructional materials assigned to his or her panel.
This independent review was conducted over a two-month period of time, with each reviewer spending hundreds of hours reviewing the text for alignment to the standards, framework, and evaluation criteria.
As a former reviewer, I can appreciate the time and the table space they took to conduct their review.
Reviewer deliberations were held again at the Sacramento Doubletree on July 24 through 28.
During the deliberations, the reviewers met in panels to discuss and evaluate the 12 programs submitted for the 2017 History Social Science Adoption.
The panels were forwarded any public comment related to their program to review prior to deliberations.
During deliberations, panels took public comment twice each day.
After much discussion and reaching consensus on their recommendations, the panel members developed a report of findings for each program.
These reports were forwarded to the commission and were also posted on the CDE website.
We thank board member Rucker and Sandoval for their presence during deliberations.
They witnessed the panel's process and discussions as they conducted their deliberations.
The commission hosted a public meeting on August 17th to receive public comment on the report of findings.
As you know, the CDE and the commission have received extensive public comment throughout the adoption process.
Between the various meetings, hearings, and submissions via email and regular email, we have received over 10,000 pages as of November 6th.
of public testimony.
All of this comment has been archived on the cdebox.com account and has been made available to board members for their review.
On September 27th through 28th, 2017, the members of the Instructional Quality Commission considered the recommendations from the Instructional Material Reviewers and Content Review Expert Report of Findings.
their public comments, and reports from individual commissioners to determine whether each program satisfied or did not satisfy the State of Board Adopted Evaluation Criteria for this adoption.
Prior to action, the IQC conducted two public hearings, one during the History-Social Science Subject Matter Committee on September 27th, and one during the full IQC meeting on September 28th.
The commissioners heard testimony from 199 members of the public at these two meetings.
Commissioner Hoening will now briefly describe the instructional shifts from the history social science framework that are presented in the instructional materials recommended by the IQC.
Good morning.
President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, Executive Director Steph Walters, members of the board.
I'm just going to briefly go over what the framework and standards and especially the framework said about these changes which are now reflected in the textbooks that are before you for adoption.
There are four instructional shifts that lay out the expectations for how history social science is taught in California and expressed within the new instructional materials.
The content in the books was significantly expanded to reflect new scholarship and developments that have taken place.
This translates into instructional materials expanding the diversity reflected in the historical narrative.
and is consistent with some of the legislation that was passed in the legislature directing our work.
The second major point is that the frameworks and structural model is based upon the concept of student inquiry.
Board member Rucker made this point early in the process about we want a more active classroom.
We want to pose questions.
We want to have students talk to each other and discuss issues, not just a lecture format.
And that's in the framework and reflected in the materials that will be before you.
So it's not just something, this is not something entirely new for most history social science teachers, but the instructional materials will now support the inquiry concept with suggestions for student-based learning and guiding questions that students can answer.
The third element is we know that literacy development is a shared enterprise and the framework emphasizes the importance of collaboration to develop student literacy skills.
The framework contained more than 30 detailed lesson examples that provide correlations to not only the California History Social Science Content Standards and Analysis Skills, but also the California Common Core ELA Standards and the California ELD Standards.
The instructional materials demonstrate and emphasize literacy development by incorporating the concept of classroom examples within the instructional materials.
And finally,
One of the things we're proud of is the framework emphasizes citizenship and civics.
And these materials do too.
That's the fourth element here.
Given our current discussion of where we are in the country, that's a very important thing to do with our youngsters.
And it's strongly emphasized in the framework, both in the framework and in the appendices.
And it means the instructional materials now not only support students learning about how government works,
but encourages teachers to provide opportunities to students to practice the skills and habits of engaged and active citizens.
The new History, Social Science, and Structural Materials being recommended today include these four shifts throughout the grade levels and provide opportunities for students to engage in conducting their own analysis of history and connect the narrative of history to today's events.
Students will have the opportunity to become historians themselves.
I'd now like to introduce Lizette Diaz, who's chair of the Instructional Quality Commission, to make the recommendations about which materials are supported.
Thank you, Commissioner Hoening.
Good morning.
I have the pleasure of presenting information on the recommendations of the Instructional Quality Commission.
As chair of the Instructional Quality Commission, I would be remiss if I did not mention the appreciation of the commission
for the participation of the members of the public in providing their input on the instructional materials.
The commission took this role to heart and conducted their review with the utmost diligence.
The recommendations of the commission are in the IQC advisory report, which was provided as an attachment to this item.
The Commission is recommending 10 of the 12 programs submitted for this adoption.
The IQC advisory includes our reasons for recommending or not recommending each program with citations in each of the five categories of the State Board adopted criteria.
It lists recommended edits, corrections, including social content citations, publisher-submitted errata for each program.
It is our recommendation that these proposed edits be considered as a condition for adoption if the state board elects to adopt these materials.
The recommended edits came from a combination of the reports of the panels of the reviewers that the board appointed to evaluate the materials, comments,
from the public that requested that edits be made to the materials and errata submitted by the publishers.
The commissioners carefully considered all of these sources of input when discussing and deciding which edits to add to our recommendation.
As I noted, the commission decided to recommend 10 of the 12 programs to the State Board of Education.
The commission is not recommending two programs submitted by Houghton Mifflin Hardcourt Publishing Company.
The reasons for this negative recommendation are included in our report.
But in short, the commission felt that these programs did not meet the several criteria statements in Category 1, and in general, had issues that would require edits in excess.
of the minimal in number threshold that is defined in the Title V regulations.
It is our view that the fixes that would be needed to correct these issues would be rewrites and are disallowable as part of our process.
If you adopt our recommendation, then you will be adopting only four programs for kindergarten through grade five.
Therefore, in order to meet the requirement in Ed Code section 60200E, the state board must find that fewer than five programs meet the criteria for adoption and conduct a review of the degree to which the criteria and procedures for evaluation were consistent with the board adopted curriculum framework.
Liaisons from the board were present at all meetings of the IQC related to this adoption and at the training and deliberations of reviews and can attest to the extent to which this process was aligned to the state board adopted framework.
We know that you have to conduct a public hearing before you take action on this adoption and that there are many people waiting to speak.
But on behalf of the commission, I would like to thank the board for its support throughout this adoption process.
We hope that the materials you adopt today will provide, most importantly, support for districts across the state in implementing the instructional shifts and the new content in the history social science framework.
And now I'd like to refer back to Dr. Grayson.
Thank you, Chair Diaz.
There have been many questions of what will happen after the State Board takes action today, so I'd like to provide some insight on that.
Once the State Board takes action today, there's a 60-day timeline for publishers to submit all edits and corrections to be verified by CDE.
I'd like to note that the materials seen linked at the California Department of Education website do not reflect any of the edits or corrections recommended by the IQC.
They are in the original format that the reviewers use to conduct their review.
The final versions of instructional materials will not be available until the State Board adopted edits and corrections have been made.
I'd like to also highlight that besides the wonderful diversity of California, another beautiful element of California is the local control our local school districts have to make choices that are in the best interest of their students and community.
These choices also apply to adopting instructional materials.
The California process is designed to offer districts choices of instructional materials to match the needs of their students.
Not all instructional materials are alike, and that is a benefit for our districts.
Each district will have multiple options as they conduct their own review of instructional materials that are either on the state board adopted list or not on the state board adopted list.
The state level review is just a first level review to share with districts, these are the materials that meet the criteria of the standards framework and criteria, the content of the standards framework and criteria.
Districts then engage in their own review of instructional materials to analyze which programs best fit their student, program, and pedagogical needs.
As a former principal and district administrator, this choice is invaluable for teachers and students.
I have personally experienced the benefit of teachers being able to go through an analysis process of many programs to choose the one that best fits their students' needs.
On this slide, we have provided the CDE recommendation based on the Instructional Quality Commission's recommendation.
As Chair Diaz stated, we appreciate your support throughout this process and would be happy to answer any questions that you might have about the adoption process or the Commission recommendation after our public comment.
Thank you.
So before we start the public hearing, I want to salute
The outgoing member of the IQC, Bill Honig, who has served his two terms on this Instructional Quality Commission.
He was the head of it and then has played a key role after that.
Indefatigable in his work and in all the detail.
Certainly a huge undertaking that he has led.
And we're most appreciative of your time, your effort.
the extensive experience you have in this.
I remember working on this with you in 1976.
So that goes back quite a ways.
So we really salute your effort and integrity and help on this.
So thank you.
And so now I'm going to declare the public hearing open.
I want to announce that
We expect all participants of this public hearing to abide by their time limits.
And the time limits are two minutes per publisher.
We're going to start with the publishers.
And then we're going to allow one minute per person for all the other members of the public.
We hope that the public hearing
Appearance will abide by their time limits and be respectful of all commenters and refrain from clapping, cheering or making other loud expressions.
We want to make sure that the board and the audience are able to hear from all the commenters.
So with that, I declare the public hearing open and we'll now call for the publishers to come.
I guess we have a list.
Go ahead.
Yes, there are two.
Roderick Spellman and Natasha Martin.
My name is Roderick Spellman.
I am the chief of the humanities department for Houghton Mifflin Harcourt.
And first of all, I want to thank you for.
The mic's on?
Yes.
I think yours is on.
Wait a second.
They're on, aren't they?
Yeah, she's going to.
Oh, got it.
Is that better?
Yes, go ahead.
Speak loudly.
Good morning.
My name is Roderick Spellman.
I am the head of the Humanities Department at Houghton Mifflin Harcourt.
I want to thank you for the opportunity to speak today.
I appreciate it.
I know it's a busy agenda.
I first want to address some of the concerns that were raised by both the IQC and the community at large regarding our HMH social studies submissions.
We take those concerns very, very seriously.
We have worked diligently through these past months to address those concerns and to be sure that our materials reflect the kinds of changes that were directed by both the panels and special groups in the public.
I think one of the biggest issues that was raised by the IQC was the issue around our grades 6, 7, and 8 errata corrections and the volume.
We take responsibility for that.
I think what we submitted there really focused on changes to our index, changes to our TOC, the kinds of page reference changes that really do not affect student content.
I want to assure this board that in no way do those changes represent a rewrite of the content.
We really focused exclusively on trying to clean up the files and really do those minor corrections and that's what that errata represents.
I'd like to start with grade 6 and ask this board to approve that title for these reasons.
It was approved by both the panel and the subject matter committee.
It had less than 1% change to the content.
There were no social content citations for grade 6.
For grade 7, similar situation.
We had no social content citations, less than 1% change, and both the panel and the subject matter committee approved grade 7.
Grade 8, I would like to ask that you approve grade 8 because it also had less than 2% change to the actual content.
It had only two social content citations.
It was approved by the panel, the folks who actually looked through that content over those extensive hundreds of hours that Stephanie mentioned.
and also by the Subject Matter Committee.
So when you put that together, I really would ask you to consider the good faith that we work with, with our family coalition, the Hindu American Foundation, to ensure that these materials met the quality you expected.
I thank you for your consideration and I would ask that you approve grades 6, 7, and 8 Houghton Mifflin Harcourt.
Any questions?
Okay, thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Natasha Martin, and I'm Outreach Director at Teachers Curriculum Institute.
Teachers Curriculum Institute, or TCI, is a California-based company that was founded in 1989 with a mission to reach all learners through an active, hands-on approach to social studies.
Our belief is that the best instructional materials combine high quality content and strong pedagogy.
Because of this approach, TCI fully supports the vision of the history social science framework, and we have appreciated the opportunity to participate in the history social science adoption.
We would like to make it clear to the Board that TCI will work with the Board and CDE staff to make any edits and corrections that are recommended by the State Board for the two programs that we have submitted, the Social Studies Alive California series for K-5 and the History Alive California series for K-6-8.
Finally, we'd like to direct the board to public comment that was submitted by TCI on November 2nd.
In this letter, we are suggesting two minor edits to resolve issues that resulted from edits that were approved in the final IQC approved motion.
One suggested edit resolves a minor grammatical error created by one of the approved edits.
The other edit seeks to resolve a small contradiction between two of the approved edits.
I'll resubmit this letter to you today, and I thank you for your time and consideration.
Okay, thank you.
I think that concludes the publisher's comments.
So now we're ready for public comments of one minute each.
So we would like to ask numbers 1 through 24 to enter the boardroom in a single file line and be prepared to speak.
Yeah, come right up and start speaking.
Can we have some more people?
Yeah.
Go ahead, sir.
Good morning.
My name is Dr. Parag Vaishampine, and I work as a scientist at NASA's Jet Propulsion Laboratory.
I thank and fully support IQC's decision to reject
HMH K-6 and HMH 6-8 program.
I strongly support the recommendations of Academic Coalition by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other top academicians.
McGraw-Hill also has a lot of prejudice and racist contents, so does National Geography's World History of California textbook.
There are many glaring problems in this textbook, including insensitive depiction of sacred Hindu text, which betrays the oriental stereotypes.
The violations in the California law are also the criteria for instruction materials as mandated by CDE.
Hence, it is imperative that these problems be addressed, failing which the textbook not be adopted for teaching in California public school.
Thank you for your time.
Good morning, chair and board members.
I'm C.C.
Yin, the founder and chair of APA, American Public Service Association Education Foundation.
I'm here to do two parts.
One is that the Fiona Amati, chairman of the Board of Equalization, asked me to read her letter.
I'm only going to read a part of that because they're long.
First, Dr. Kirst, APA
The group is very diverse and with rich heritage and history.
And when I was the speaker pro tem for assembly, I authored AB 199 to encourage the instruction of social science.
to grades 7 to 12 to include the diverse aspect of API history and the culture in our textbook.
And the picture now shown within the proposed textbook does not adequately depict the rich culture of diversity in the Indo-American community and Hinduism.
You have one minute, so you're finished.
Thank you.
All speakers have one minute time limit.
We will also be collecting numbers from each of the speakers as they leave the podium.
We would like to wait until everybody receives their copy.
Oh, please get started.
They'll be right behind you.
OK.
We appreciate that.
Respected members of State Board of Education, I am Dakshita Talekar.
I am from Hindu Education Foundation.
I also belong to a so-called lower caste community.
On Monday, an alarmist letter was submitted to you by a group named South Asian Histories for All, SAFA.
The letter claims that the HSS framework is not being followed.
SAFA has asked you to delay the process based on these contentions.
Here, we present an analysis of their demands in the letter.
The analysis is with you.
Firstly, in 32 of 43 revisions proposed by SAFA, the publisher's original text already complies with the framework.
Even the wording is identical to the framework.
But SAFA appears to be seeking deletions or alterations to this.
They are hence forcing the publisher drafts into non-compliance of framework and adoption guidelines, especially category 1.2 and 1.12.
Thank you.
Hello, everyone.
I'd like to continue what Lakshita, she said.
Please see the table we have submitted in our comments column.
We have provided page numbers and line numbers of the relevant framework sections.
Secondly, many of SAFA's suggestions are blatantly anti-Hindu and adversely reflect on Hinduism.
leading to violations of Category 1.10 of the HSS Adoption Criteria and California's Education Code sections.
Thirdly, SAFA has made contentions about erasure of history in their letter.
But it is ironic that most of their edits, in fact, call for deletions of content.
Safa blatantly even suggests the removal of a section on Hinduism in one of the drafts.
Lastly, nowhere in their letter do we see any suggestion to add the cultural-religious contributions of so-called lower castes such as mine.
Rather it is because of the effort of HEF that the histories of Hindu sages and saints from so-called lower caste were added in the framework.
Thank you for your time.
We thank you for your hard work in developing the curriculum framework and enforcing the social content standards.
As standards and evaluation criteria and California law demand, each child should feel pride in his or her heritage and develop a sense of self-worth related to the equality of opportunity.
They also forbid negative stereotyping.
The bigoted and highly biased Hinduphobic edits of SAFA are directly contradictory to the law.
We have made point by point analysis of SAFA's letter.
It clearly shows that the asks and alarmism of SAFA are based on very flimsy grounds.
We ask you to reject their edits.
We also commend you for not getting alarmed by the letter and staying on the course of the SBE agenda.
Again, we sincerely thank you for keeping the publishers stick to the framework.
Thank you.
respected members of the State Board of Education.
I am Archana, teacher in Campbell Union High School District.
Representing the teacher community, I have submitted letters signed by many teachers across California.
We teachers strive to instill in each child a sense of pride in his or her heritage, develop a feeling of self-worth to equality of opportunity, eradicate the roots of prejudice,
We also want students to become aware of accepting of religious diversity while being allowed to remain secure in any religious beliefs they may already have.
IQC has made openly and collaboratively worked hard to attain these by rejecting biased textbooks by HMH.
along with many other teachers across the state.
I thank them.
Please uphold the IQC's recommendations and reject biased and prejudicial textbooks.
Reject both books by HMH.
Also, I please ask you to adopt McGraw-Hill and National Geography textbooks only if all the edits proposed by them are accepted.
Thank you.
Dear members of SBE, I am Deepti and I'm here on behalf of Hindu Education Foundation.
On Monday, a last-minute letter was submitted to you by HMH regarding their 628 program that was rejected by IQC.
HMH made several claims on criteria based on their subjective analysis and not on the criteria as defined by the California's Code of Regulations.
You've been prevented with the analysis.
The appendix lists the tables.
Here are the broad points.
One, HMH in their letter acknowledges the higher than normal volume of corrections, but classify the majority of errors incorrectly as errata.
Analyzing their changes,
and utilizing the definitions of California Code of Regulations, Title 5, Education, 5 CCR, Section 9510H and 9510R.
The analysis finds the claims are inaccurate and misleading.
Thank you.
Hello, I'm Shivani.
I'm continuing after the previous speaker.
We've provided grade-wise data with severity of change that clarifies much higher volume of major changes.
In our analysis, we found that 26% or 946 of the changes that they submitted are very significant changes.
If we consider edits of medium severity also, that's 76% of their edits are considerably significant, causing changes in the narrative.
Even with such major rewrites, it fails to solve the underlying issues of adverse reflection, as defined in Category 1.10 of HSS Adoption Guidelines.
Even the changes that were submitted were incomplete or the edits talk of replacements, but don't tell full details of what the replacements are going to be.
No publisher content can be allowed based on a promise of change when the content itself is not known.
The handful of corrections for the Hinduism in Ancient India section failed to even address the violations of Category 1.
HMH's drafts are blatantly racist, stereotypical, and show Hinduism as an inferior to other religions.
Thank you.
Respected members of SB, I am Archana Shinde, a parent of two children from Cupertino Union School District.
I'm shocked to see the incorrect and imaginary contents regarding Hindus in the textbooks.
So here I am today to speak against the demonization of Hindus and Indians.
I completely support ICAS's decision to reject two worst programs of HMH.
McGraw-Hill textbooks has a lot of prejudiced and racist content.
National Geographic has completely ignored 20 major items from Hindu history, thereby completely erasing our history.
I request SBE to say no to hatred against Hindus in all forms.
National Geographic has submitted a document to the CDE with corrections.
National Geographic books should be adopted only if all the changes are reflected in their textbook.
I also support recommendations by Professor Geoffrey Long and 38 other accommodations and expect those to be taken into consideration during collection or rewriting.
Thank you.
respected members of the State Board of Education.
First of all, thank you for the opportunity to speak here.
My name is Venu Acharya.
I'm from Folsom, California.
I stand in front of you to speak against the demonization of Hindu religion and ancient Indian culture.
I stand here as a Hindu American and also
as Indian-American to give voice to the three million people of our community who could not be here.
We have one demand.
Please stop demonization of Hindus.
Please stop hatred.
And the best place to start this is the textbooks.
We are here in solidarity with the LGBTQ coalition and with the support of numerous public officials, including California Lieutenant Governor Gavin Newsom.
thousands of Indian Americans, Hindus, Jains, Buddhists, interfaith groups, and all the like-minded people of California who today want hate to be rejected.
We all have just one thing to ask from the State Board of Education.
Stop hatred against the Hindus and Indians.
Thank you for the opportunity.
Respected state hearing committee members, my name is Guru Dutt and my daughter studies in eighth grade.
When we studied history chapter, it's hard for me to convince my daughter about the contents in a textbook which are misinterpreted.
We are seeing textbooks portraying 6,000 years of Hindu culture as being the religion of monkeys and elephants.
We wholeheartedly appreciate IQC's decision of rejecting HMH and NatGeo because the textbook needs a lot of sanitization.
Few things that caught my mind.
We see Indian laborers working alongside monkeys and hereby equating Indians to monkeys.
This is clear violation of California state law ECS 51501.
Hinduism is one of the most tolerant religion in the world.
Upanishads and Vedas in the books are misinterpreted.
But in the same books, the Upanishads and Vedas have a phrase called Vasudhaiva Kutumbakam, which means the world is one, which also can be read as we are all one.
Justice can be delayed, but not be denied.
I would request the honorable committee members to
Thank you.
Dear members of the State Board of Education, I'm Satish Nagaraj, parent of one child studying in seventh grade in Granite Oaks Middle School, Rocklin, California.
I'm shocked about the content used about India and Hinduism.
I'm a true believer that all have their own right to practice any religion, but should not undermine other religion and their beliefs.
Some of the publishers are in that direction.
I strongly condemn their intentions of using bad pictures and contents about India and Hindu way of living.
Thank you.
We would like to make certain that all people numbers 1 through 24 have had an opportunity to line up.
And at this time, if you are numbers 25 through 48, please start lining up outside.
Thank you.
Panelists, I am Jyoti Yelgalwadi, a publisher based in Tracy, and I've been participating in these hearings from the beginning.
Thanks for all your hard work.
The framework was completed in June 2016.
The publishers had 10 months until April 2017 to review and prepare the data, which would be part of the book.
From April 2017 to September, publishers had time to finalize the book.
That's a lot of time.
14 months to complete a draft and present to review.
HMH handed over 4,000 corrections just a week before so that no one could really review it.
These corrections proved to be wrong, insulting, and disgusting.
Its image seems to rest on all its laurels, thinking that due to its fame, whatever it does will be accepted.
I am an independent publisher and can guarantee that I would do a better job in a third of the time.
Thank you.
Respected members of the SBE.
Good morning.
My name is Abirinima Hajan and I'm a fifth grader in the Sunnyvale School District.
This is my second time here in CDE with another missed school day.
I'm really sad that I have to go home and do my extra schoolwork and homework.
Anyways I'm here to stand up for my Indian-American friends.
I don't like to see my friends being bullied and it is not a happy experience.
According to the bullying report
Every 1 out of 3 Indian-American student is being bullied because he or she is a Hindu or Indian.
If textbooks are teaching us this then these textbooks are wrong and should be taken away immediately to create education a positive experience for everybody.
I'm really happy and thankful to IQC for rejecting HMH 2 programs.
It was the right decision.
I would like to request all the SBE members to also reject Harcourt and other bad books.
Thank you.
Namaste.
My name is Amar Nadig.
I'm a parent of two daughters in third and seventh grade.
One of my older daughter just read the textbook last year and was quite embarrassed when she came home and asked me about Hinduism.
She also asked me questions about why we are being, my community or my people are being represented in a certain way.
And why a classroom divides, the teachers in the classroom are instructed to divide the classroom into four parts to represent casteism.
There has to be a way to come around these topics and come up with an understanding that there is something more to Hinduism, like power for women, ahimsa, and other concepts.
These, by themselves, are big chapters that we can all take from the books of Hinduism.
I request you to accept the recommendations that my friends are making here and reject the ones that we don't support.
Thank you.
Hello, I'm Shubhangi from Los Angeles, California.
I stand here as a concerned mother of a young boy, as every one out of three Hindu American children have reported of being bullied based on religious beliefs and practices.
I stand here as a Hindu, an Indian, as an Asian with support of other Asians and Pacific Highlanders.
I stand here to support Professor Jeffrey Long and other academics who are seeking historical accuracy.
I stand here with the support of 11 assembly members, three congressmen, three senators, and numerous Hindu, Jain, and interfaith groups.
And most of all, I stand here as one of the hundreds of Hindus who are speaking today and thousands of others who have sent you letters and signed petitions across from California.
All of us are just saying one thing.
Stop hatred against Hindus.
Stop demonization of Hindus.
Thank you.
Respected members of State Board of Education, Namaste.
I'm Basanta Vennela from Los Angeles.
I have two sons, sixth grader and third grader, who go to LASD schools.
As a mom, I'm concerned that the derogatory portrayal of Hinduism in textbooks adversely affects my children in classroom.
I believe IQC and SBE did significant due diligence in building 2016 framework.
I'm surprised that National Geographic completely ignored the framework and did not include many aspects of core teachings of Hinduism like yoga that promote peace and harmony and oneness of all living beings.
There is an attempt to portray Hinduism as primitive and dirty in the textbooks.
Hence, I'm here to support IQC's decision to reject HMH drafts.
Request you to please reject those drafts that do not meet California law and instructional standards.
Support the recommendations by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other scholars, and those be included.
Thank you.
Good morning, respected members of the State Board of Education.
I'm Dilip Nayak.
I'm father of two kids, 11 and 6, living in the Sacramento area.
I'm shocked to see that on page 177 of the 6th grade textbook of HMH 6-8 program, calling Veda,
Vedas, the sacred scriptures, a collection of spells and charms.
Spells and charms, really?
No other sacred book has been mentioned in such a denigrating terms.
This is inaccurate, biased, and discriminatory.
Hinduism is one of the most tolerant religions in the world.
I stand here to support Jeffrey Long and other 38 other scholars who are seeking historical accuracy.
I request that the recommendations of academic group be made accepted to address all the problems in the books.
Thank you for your time.
Namaste.
Respected members of the board, I'm Kiran.
I'm a concerned parent.
I'm here to oppose and condemn the inappropriate content that demeans Hindu, the culture I follow, and the country, India, which I want.
I appreciate and stand behind the decision of IQC to reject the programs of HMH.
These programs are the worst, and even after so many revisions, they have not collectively addressed all our problems.
I'm here to ensure that all the recommendations from Jeffrey Long and his academics are taken into consideration, and HMH's denigration of Hindus and Indian culture is rejected.
So thank you.
Namaste, dear members of State Board of Education.
I'm Amit Agarwal, parent of two daughters studying in Folsom.
Being the father of a fifth grader, I am concerned about the bullying of my daughter who will be going to middle school next year.
I don't want her to be suppressed by her peers.
or be afraid of her Hindu identity.
If other students have inaccurate information about the Hindu society, it will create a bad impression on Indian community.
I stand here to oppose hatred against all Hindu and Indian children.
Please take immediate steps to stop the bullying of children that is happening because of stereotypes in the textbooks.
You can do that by adopting Professor Long's recommendations to address the problems of bias and prejudice in the textbook.
I urge the board to reject all material that has hatered against Hindus and every other community.
Thank you.
Good morning, respected board members.
I am Regis Chobisa from El Dorado Hills, father of 10-year-old.
I appreciate and fully support decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMH, which I consider inappropriate and misleading interpretation, creating hatred amongst schools and society.
I stand here not only to fight hatred against Hindu-Americans, but also to support LGBTQ community as well as African-American communities who are getting hatred in the school as well as in the community.
Hinduism is the only major religion that recognizes divinity in all people, all individuals, respect for every living being, including plants and animals.
Education is light and ignorance is darkness.
With this statement, I demand the right education by acceptance of all recommendations of academic coalition by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other top academics.
All of us are saying just one thing, stop hatred against Hindus, stop demonization of Hindus.
Thank you.
Respected members of SBE, I am audible.
My name is Sudarshan Ramayanam, came from Roseville.
The HMS K6 and 628 have pictures that show Hindus with trash and as dirty.
A bullying report about Hindu American children calls a seventh grade child as being called as dirty as Hindu by their classmates.
Hindu children face this all the time in the classrooms.
Is it not clear from where these ideas of Hindus being dirty came from?
I commend AQC for rejecting the two Hinduphobic books that had the images that conflate dirt with Hinduism and India.
But I think more needs to be done.
I stand here in solitary with all Hindu American children who have been bullied and who have to face hatred in classrooms.
Thanks for giving me opportunity.
Thank you.
Hey, good morning.
This is Sarvesh, and I'm from Irvine.
And I'm a parent of a fourth grader and kindergartner.
And I'm concerned about the California education system that has failed to make my kids proud of their culture and their origins.
So due to the bullying and other
unsocial stuff they went through because of the misinterpretation and misrepresentation of the religion.
Hinduism and all the textbooks like HMH and the Netgeo
are representing Hinduism in a wrong way.
I support IQC's decision to reject HMH for Kindergarten to 6th program and I request Board to reject NetGeo because of the content that has been put in against Hinduism.
Thanks a lot.
Respected members of State Board of Education, teaching history comes with its own unique challenges in the classroom.
Hence, textbooks not only have to be historically accurate, but also culturally competent.
Material that failed to treat all cultures with fairness or negatively reflect upon the religious and cultural heritage of children can not only lead to psychological problems within students, but also encourage bullying of children, especially from minority communities.
It poses severe challenges in creating a safe and nurturing learning environment.
We request you to adopt new curriculum that will give our children access to accurate history.
And also, I thank IQC for their work and request you to please reject HMH.
And thank you for your time.
Good morning to all of you.
My name is Deepak Sharma.
I am from Southern California, Irvine.
I, together with about 100 families, came here today to represent our concerns to all of you.
If this hearing was being held on a Saturday, you might see 10 times more people because that's the level of concern at the grassroots level about these books.
My own daughter is a teacher.
She teaches high school English.
Our only request is that there should be fairness depicted in the California textbooks towards our religion.
We want our children and their friends to go in and learn about the positive aspects of it versus learning things and getting bullied about it.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I'm a mother of two adult daughters.
They're 26 and 25.
They're done with their college.
They're employed.
But the experience that they had in their high school years still haunts me.
And as a parent, it bothers me so much that I have taken days off and come here repeatedly in front of the committee in the public hearing.
So the reason I'm here is it's important for me so that this new generation should be aware about the Hinduism in India and the positive light that they learn, the same for other religions and countries.
When the Quality Committee rejected the hate-filled books, it was a great celebratory moment.
And I hope that we continue to follow the framework which is not supported by the other books.
We do not need our children to grow up in a divisive society.
The young minds need to nurture towards unity so that the educational material should be of high accurate quality.
Textbook is not a place for hatred.
It is not a place for politics as well.
Thank you.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Nik Saad, parent of two near future middle schoolers in Union School District of San Jose.
I am not a Hindu.
Having grown up in the beautiful multicultural setting of India, I do understand its culture and religious tapestry deeply.
I completely support the IQC's rejection of the HMH textbooks as being both irretrievably biased, offensive, and inaccurate in both facts and narrative.
I have seen the proposed textbook sections on Hinduism in specificity and my majority association, India in general, can clearly say that it is in no way reflective of the reality that I grew up in or the India that my daughters see when they visit their grandparents.
I don't want to stand by while my daughters are taught completely slanted so-called facts in their school class in front of their peers.
As an Indian-origin parent in the Bay Area, I would ask you to adopt the recommendations of the IQC, compel the textbooks that build the minds of our children to be accurate and non-discriminatory in their narrative.
Thank you for your time.
Good morning.
My name is Inder Kaur.
I'm a U.S.
citizen, and I was born in Kashmir, India.
I'm a Kashmiri pundit.
The word pundit came into English lexicon based on my community, and we spearheaded the education in India from time immemorial.
There is nothing here I want to say that has not been said, but I want to say a couple of things from heart.
There was a scholar from India.
He said the vanities of this world are transient.
Those alone live, who live for others.
The rest are more dead than alive.
It's modern times.
This is the time to shun hatred.
shun bigotry, shun fanaticism, and shun any opportunity to make another religion feel inferior.
And this scholar said, help and not fight, assimilation and not destruction, harmony and peace and not dissension.
Thank you very much.
Respected members of the State Board of Education, I am Pratik Shah, a parent from Sunnyvale.
I am extremely shocked by seeing textbooks in California which portrait inaccurate Indian history and Hinduism.
I appreciate IQC's decision to reject HMH because these textbooks are Hinduphobia.
but rejecting them alone is not enough.
Recently, National Geographic submitted documents with corrections.
National Geographic books should be adopted only if all these changes are reflected in their textbooks.
I request you to accept the recommendations of the academic coalition by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other top academics.
Thank you for listening.
Good morning, respected members of the SVE.
I'm Sujata Joshi, a concerned parent from San Jose.
I'm greatly disappointed with negative portrayal of India and Hinduism.
My daughter came here four times with tears in her eyes and requesting to stop the bullying of Hindu kids.
I'm here to support IQC's decision to reject HMH 628 and K-6 programs.
National Geographic has also omitted many sections from 2016 framework.
They are submitted corrections.
Accept those only if all the requested changes are really good.
I also demand that all the recommendation from academic coalition of Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other top academics to be accepted.
Thank you.
Respected members of SBE, I am a homemaker and a mother of two daughters who are in fourth and first grade.
I was shocked and heartbroken when I heard about this textbook issue, which made me come all the way from Pasadena, leaving my kids behind to voice my opinion.
I strongly believe that education is an effective medium to mould students' personality.
The education I received during my school years still has a great impact on who I am today.
The information children learn in elementary, middle and high school shapes their thinking process.
Today's kids are tomorrow's leaders.
In order to create responsible citizens of future, we must teach children to respect each other and to respect each other's religion and culture.
I cannot accept the negative and biased approach towards Hinduism and India taught in any school.
I thank and strongly support IQC for the rejection of HMH programs and humbly request you to do the same.
Thank you for listening.
Hi, good afternoon.
My name is Mary Yin Liu.
I am a local McDonald's business owner and also executive board member for APAPA, Asian Pacific Islander American Public Affairs Association.
And our community is united today.
We are an inclusive community.
We believe in diversity, fairness, and
Also, education.
I have children in the public school systems, and I would like them to have the opportunity to see and experience the culture and religion of India and Hinduism that is positive, that reflects many of our travels.
And they will not have the opportunity to do that.
So I urge you to consider your position seriously today.
You know, history is made based on interpretation of the facts, and you are empowered to truly make history.
Much groundwork has been laid before today in good faith and with due diligence.
The community has reached out to many book publishers.
Most have made these simple updates and accommodations.
However, we are appalled and disappointed to see the disparity remaining with these three publishers.
And we ask that they treat the races and countries and religions equally for all, not just a few.
Thank you.
Hello.
I'm Shantaram Nekar from the Hindu Education Foundation.
I'm here to present a petition from more than 14,000 people, parents, community members, leaders, et cetera, from across the state and the country, asking for unbiased and fair portrayal of Hinduism in all the textbooks in California.
So a formal printout of the petition has been submitted online.
It's 600 pages long.
So I have a copy which has been circulated out here.
I really urge you to consider the voice of all the people very, very strongly.
In addition, I also kind of just want to empathize the really good work done by IQC over the past seven years, detailed work.
I thank them for the work.
And I support their recommendation or their son to reject the textbook from HMH.
I also wish that the textbooks from McGraw-Hill and National Geographic will be accepted only if the proposed changes are accepted.
Thank you very much.
I, Vijay Handebag, a concerned parent, a practicing Hindu, and a member of Hindu Education Foundation, commend the IQC for the hard work it has put in the process to adopt the K-8 history textbooks.
At the same time, I would like to draw your attention in the last-minute submission and attempt to disrupt this process by a group calling itself SAFA.
Unlike our coalition that actively participated in all the public hearings, panel deliberations with hundreds of Hindu American community members, parents, and children of diverse social and professional backgrounds from all parts of California, taking time off of work and school to make public comments, SAFA has chosen to intervene at the last minute for reasons unknown to us.
They had ample opportunity to participate in the process and submit their views to the IQC and publishers.
And our engagement is not against any caste or religion, but for a fair and accurate depiction of Hinduism and India in adherence to CA education code and framework.
Thank you.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Samir Kalra, senior director with the Hindu American Foundation.
First of all, I'd like to start by appreciating the hard work of the IQC over this process of the last year.
As part of this process, we have provided feedback to most of the publishers, participated in several hearings, and submitted public comments to the IQC.
While we have had constructive engagement with many of the publishers and saw many areas of improvement, we are disappointed that there are still specific draft materials that do not adequately or accurately reflect Hinduism in India.
And despite our constructive engagement with publishers, including HMH, they have not incorporated all of our feedback, and therefore I want to emphasize that we cannot endorse their textbooks since they do not reflect a balanced narrative grounded in academic consensus or are consistent with the framework.
Consequently, we support the recommendation of the IQC to reject the drafts of both Upton Mifflin programs.
We also support the edits suggested from McGraw-Hill in a letter dated October 31st from the Coalition of 30 Academics led by Professor Jeffrey Long.
And finally, we support the adoption of National Geographic Learning's program with the acceptance of all of their proposed edits from November 6th.
Thank you very much.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Chandrasekhar Wagh, representing Hindu Education Foundation, and also a concerned parent of two kids.
I'm here to represent a coalition of support from a group of 38 academics led by Professor Jeffrey Long.
We have received a coalition support from more than 75 organizations, including Anti-Defamation League, Silicon Valley Interreligious Council, Californians Together, Asian Pacific Islander American Public Affairs Association,
Also, many Indian, Hindu, Jain, and interfaith organizations.
We also have received support from 17 elected officials.
A letter of support has been handed over to honorable board members.
So, what we are asking here to reject is the Hafton-Mafflin Court, Kids Discovery California Social Studies, K-6,
reject Hoplin, Mifflin, Harcourt's social studies for California 628, adopt National Geographic if their proposed edits of November 6th are accepted in their entirely, adopt McGraw-Hill if all of the edits corrections recommended on October 30th are incorporated in their entirely.
Thank you very much.
At this time, we would like to make certain that all numbers 24 through 48 have lined up.
If you have not done so, please do so now.
And out in the lobby, we are asking people who have numbers through 100 to be lined up.
Thank you.
Dear members of the State Board of Education, I am Soham Shikawat, studying in 7th grade in Iron Horse Middle School.
I've come here to talk about my experience last year, in 6th grade.
Last year when I found out that our class was learning about the Hindu religion, I got very excited.
But I got disappointed when I read and saw pictures of things that are not true in the textbook.
Also, our teacher said wrong information about our Hindu gods.
Hearing this, I got very shocked.
My parents corrected the information for me, but for people of other religions, their parents might not know the right information and they might assume that the information being read in class is true.
This child will then think less of children like me and I don't want to face easy, avoidable discrimination.
To me, Hinduism is not just a religion, it's who you are from inside.
So please help correct this oversight in books.
Thanks for listening.
Respected member of State Board of Education, I'm Gulshan Jeet from San Ramon, California.
The edits that the French Hindu phobic group, South Asian Histories for All, is suggested seems to be driven by hate.
They are requesting to add more caste into the textbooks, even though caste forms more than 30% of the content in sections on Hinduism and Asian India in all textbooks.
No other section discusses social structures of its civilization in such detail.
It sounds strange when they say caste is being erased.
When they are trying to do so is to twist that content in such a way as to perpetuate hatred against Hindus.
The narrative of caste which they want to introduce into the textbook is highly Hinduphobic.
The changes that they suggest will not only lead to Category 1 violation, especially Category 1.10.
I hope that you will see the inaccuracies and hateful motives of these edits and reject them.
Thank you.
Dear members of State Board of Education, I am Radha Krishna, resident of Los Angeles Studio City.
I am here in Sacramento missing my work day to make myself heard and to speak against the demonization of Hindus and its religion.
I fully support the decision of IQC, Instructional Quality Commission, to reject the two programs of HMH Houghton, Mifflin, Harcourt, which are racist and Hindu-phobic in nature.
I also request board members to consider all the recommendations put forth by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 prominent academics.
Thank you.
Good morning, board members, Superintendent Torlakson, Julian Conetti, President and CEO of the California Hispanic Chambers of Commerce.
As many of you know, over decades, the Hispanic community here in California has always strived to assure that Hispanics are portrayed in historical, accurate, equitable, culturally competent manner in textbooks.
And we've worked with legislators and educators and elected officials throughout the state.
Today I'm here before you to urge you to reject the two proposed textbooks from Houghton, Milfen, and Harcourt, as we feel they do not portray Hinduism in India in a historical, accurate, equitable, or culturally competent manner.
And we feel this is also consistent with the academic recommendations that were led by Professor Jeffrey Long.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Glenn Fuji, National Executive Director of APAPA, and I'm here today to support our Hindu and Indian American communities.
And our biggest concern right now is that they've gone through a decade quest of trying to get equality and being treated with dignity in the California textbooks K through 8.
We're strong believers that with your support, we really
We really urge you to reject these two textbooks, K-8 and California Textbook System from HMH, who really disrespect and inappropriately represent both the Hindu and Indian American communities.
And we're fighting just to get your support.
We strongly believe and urge you to help us today.
Thank you very much.
Dear members of State Board Education, I am Bhargavi parent of two parents, two kids in San Ramon Valley School District.
I am a volunteer for SEWA International.
We serve all people in communities including Indians and non-Indians.
I'm here to oppose Hindu phobia and hatred against my heritage.
IQC has shown the courage to reject hatred and prejudice by rejecting two Hinduphobic books.
We request SBE also to reject all hateful content, some of which is in other books and other being pushed by Hinduphobic groups at this last moment.
I request SBE to say no to hatred against Hindus in all forms.
Thank you for your time.
Dear members of the School Board of Education, I am Kedar Bhole.
My son, Neil, is five years of age.
He is a student of La Rosa Elementary School in Temple City, California.
My wife, my son, and I are practicing Hindus.
I am deeply concerned with the depiction of Hinduism in the sixth grade textbook drafts.
This is why I have taken a day off from work today and I've driven 400 miles to speak to you.
I am grateful to the Instructional Quality Commission, the IQC, for their recommendation to reject the textbook drafts of Harcourt.
However, this is not sufficient.
I find the contents of McGraw-Hill and National Geographic Education to be biased as well.
I stand here to oppose hatred against Hindus and Hinduism.
I agree with the comments and the suggestions made by Professor Jeffrey Long and his team, and I strongly urge you to implement these recommendations.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Mala Gavin.
I'm a retired teacher from Rowland Unified in Southern California.
Diverse cultures was a central theme in my curriculum.
I am deeply concerned about the draft textbooks, depictions of Indian Hinduism.
Remember just a few years ago when entire school districts held workshops for all the teachers on cultural proficiency so that we could rid ourselves of bias and discrimination?
What use is that if we have bias and discrimination in our textbooks?
Having respectful portrayals of all cultures is necessary for our credibility.
Students begin to doubt everything that is taught to them if we do not give them truthful information.
I have studied the Bhagavad Gita.
Page 280 of the McGraw-Hill 6th grade textbook uses a translation that should be replaced by one from the Bhagavad Gita as it is the most widely published Bhagavad Gita in the world translated into 50 languages.
I request also McGraw-Hill grade 7 be replaced.
Page 160.
Not accurate.
Thank you very much.
Respected members, I am Vinayak Fadnavis.
I am standing here on behalf of Hindu Education Foundation.
On Monday, a last-minute letter was submitted to you by HMH regarding their 6-8 program that was rejected by IQC.
They have made several claims in the letter.
We would like to show how the claims are based on their subjective analysis and not the criteria as defined by California's Code of Regulations.
Analysis is in front of you.
The appendix has the tables that has the data.
Here are the broad points.
One, HMH in their letter acknowledged that higher than normal volume of corrections, but classify the majority of errors incorrectly as errata.
We have analyzed their changes utilizing the definitions of California Code of Regulations, Title 5 Education, 5 CCR Section 9510H and R. Our analysis finds that their claims are not only inaccurate, but they are misleading.
We have provided a grade-wise data with severity of changes that clarifies much higher volume of major changes.
In our analysis, we found that 26% or 946 of changes that they submitted were significant changes.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I'm Shankar, and I am a resident of Brea, California.
HMH's drafts are blatantly racist, stereotypical, and show how Hinduism is inferior to other religions.
Even the changes that were submitted were incomplete, where the edits talk of replacements but don't tell full details of what the replacements are going to be.
No publisher content can be allowed based on a promise of change when the content itself is not known.
The handful corrections for the Hinduism and Ancient India section fail to even address the violations of Category 1.
Hence, we ask you to recommend the rejection of HMHS 6-8 program as recommended by Instructional Quality Commission.
Thank you very much for listening.
Namaste.
I am Ashutosh.
I am a father of a son who is born and raised, being raised in Mountain View.
And I wanted to bring, I'm part of the Hindu Education Foundation, and I wanted to bring your attention to the hundreds of parents and children that are outside.
It's raining outside, but they are here with
with a sense of urgency because this is their last chance to get heard.
The books that you publish, the resources that California Board of Education has, many of the other states in the country do not have those same resources.
So the books that you publish are read not only in California but in other states in America.
So this is a sense of urgency from many of the parents across the states and people have driven here from all the way to San Diego.
They have been driving since yesterday.
I really want to bring this to your attention that the hinduphobic edits and the hinduphobic content that Harcourt has been pushing for and that should be rejected and the voice of these children and parents should be heard.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Jagish Parikh.
My son, Dvij Parikh, is a second grader at Fremont Unified School District.
We live in a very diverse multicultural world where the Bay Area is a shining example of it.
It is imperative that the goal of structured education everywhere should be to promote and foster friendship and unity among children of all color, race, religion, and sect.
I was a little bit dismayed when I saw the current draft single out Hinduism for all the negative portrayal while other religions are presented in a very sensitive manner.
There are clear laws and educational code sections.
detailing a neutral, bias-free representation of all religions.
I fully support IQC's decision to reject HMH K-6 and 6-8 textbooks, which have the worst content on Hinduism.
I ask and request the board to reject other books like McGraw-Hill and National Geographic, which are equally worse, so that our future generations are taught the virtues of respect.
Thank you.
Good morning, respected SPE members.
My name is Sumad Basavapatna from Shiboya Middle School in San Jose, California.
I'm a seventh grader there.
I was here in September for the IQC hearing and I was quite happy to hear the rejection of the HMH textbook drafts.
These drafts had only demeaning depictions of the Hindu religion and of India.
There is no mention of positive aspects like yoga, medicine, contributions to science, math, astronomy, metallurgy, and Hindu female deities.
Such glaring omissions are impossible unless the authors are driven by hatred, prejudice, and Hinduphobia.
And someone tries to condense many thousands of years of Hindu history into a dozen or so pages and attempts using such material to introduce Hinduism, they're liable to go astonishingly wrong in a disrespectful way.
California's education system mandates a balanced perspective, and the HMH drafts do not do so.
I request the SBE to reject HMH textbooks.
Please also accept the changes penned by Professor Long and other academics.
to fulfill law code 51501.
Thank you for your time and patience.
Respected board members, my name is Raviteja Pillamari and I'm an 8th grader studying in Kennedy Middle School and from Cooper Junior School District.
And I'm here because of the misrepresentation of Hinduism in the textbooks.
And because of this about 1 in 8 respondents of a bullying survey on Hindu American students said that their teachers made sarcastic remarks about Hinduism in front of the entire class.
A student quoted in the report says, after being made fun of by my friends I didn't tell anybody else I was Hindu so I don't experience problems so much as I feel awkward sometimes.
Others reported deep emotional scars from bullying incidents.
And the purpose of standards is to project the cultural diversity of society, instilling in each child a sense of pride in his or her heritage.
This is not how I felt when I was learning about Hinduism.
I felt sad that this was how my culture was.
This is how my culture was represented in the textbooks.
And this is how my classmates, peers, and friends also felt.
I want the board to reject the HMH textbooks.
Respected board members, thank you for listening to my speech.
Good morning, respected members of the State Board of Education.
I am Sunita Gupta.
The edits that frozen Hindu phobia group South Asian History is suggesting seems to be driven by hate.
They are requesting to add more caste into the textbook, even thought
caste from more than 30 percent.
Of contents in section of Hinduism and Ascent India in all textbooks, no other section discuss social structure of civilization in such details.
This is willful destruction of fact and will have severely adverse effect on Hindu and other children as well.
The change that they suggested will not only lead to Category 1 violation.
I hope that you will see increases and hateful motives of these edits and reject them.
Thank you.
Respected SBE members, my name is Shivani Kanth and I'm an 8th grader in Miller Middle School.
In 6th grade, I was excited that I was going to learn about Hinduism, but I was greatly disappointed upon the information in the textbooks.
The information was focused on the negatives and not the immense positives in my religion.
My parents teach me about my culture and the information in the textbooks contradicting everything that was taught by my parents.
The material in the textbooks is false and focused on the negatives in my culture.
Learning from these textbooks at school hurt my pride of being an Indian American.
I'm outraged that the textbooks such as HMH, National Geographic, and McGraw-Hill choose to focus on the negatives of my religion instead of its immense positives.
While I thank IQC for rejecting HMH K-6 and 6-8, I urge you to support IQC's decision and keep her court rejected.
Thank you.
We are currently listening to speakers 50 through 75.
If you have one of those numbers and are not currently in the boardroom, please line up so that you can make your presentation.
Thank you.
Respected members of State Board of Education, my name is Snehalata, and I'm coming from Fremont.
I thank and fully support the decision of IQC to reject two programs of HMH.
These programs are worst of all, and even after the huge number of revisions and rewrites submitted at the last minute, which collectively do not even address all the problems.
Even HMHS, hundreds of revisions are incomplete, as they have promised to replace some context.
They have not even said what those replacement would be.
How would the draft textbook could be adopted when it is not even complete?
Is HMH expecting this process to last for another 10 years?
What about the taxpayers' money?
And what about the children?
And what about the process itself?
Hence, I ask you to reject HMS2 programs as recommended by IQC.
Thank you for listening to me.
Good morning, everyone, respected board members.
My name is Vivek Jambakar, and I come from Irvine, California.
And I have been a California resident since last 17 years.
And I'm a proud father of an eighth grader and a third grader.
I was really appalled by the biased views against Hinduism and Indian civilization being still making through the draft versions of some of the textbooks what our kids are going to learn in the future.
And I am fully supporting Professor Long's letter, which he has drafted with his 38 academic friends.
And I would like to really request you to reject the drafts from McGraw-Hill and the National Geographic, which are still making way.
And I thank you for rejecting the draft from the HMH.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Good morning, board members.
This is Vishal Sharma.
I'm from Orange County, Southern California.
And my two kids, 10 and 6 years old, they go to Irvine schools.
We drove almost last night to reach on time and to get this opportunity, so thanks for that.
When I look at the picture, cow eating trash, I wonder when this misinterpretation will go.
So really, really, that is very disturbing for me, my family, my friends.
So I'm here to oppose the hatred against Hindus and Indians.
And I fully support the decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMH.
And I sincerely request to reject HMH's two programs as recommended by IQC.
And I support the letter by Jeffrey Long and 38 other distinguished academicians.
Thank you.
Good morning, members.
My name is Deepak Mehrotra, father of two young kids from San Ramon, California.
I'm here to ensure that the future of my kids studying in California does not entail bullying and hatred because they are Hindus or they are from India.
I'm quite appalled to see some fringe Hindu phobic groups submitting to the board last minute things to stop these proceedings.
I have here papers print out from social media which I'm going to submit to show you some of their core leaders thinking just so the board knows what kind of people are you dealing with.
So this is that South Asian histories for all.
One of the submissions here, again on social media recently, states, Hindus believe in monkeys and half elephants, unquote, alluding to our Hindu gods.
Hate speech 101.
Another printout here, ridiculing Hindu priests doing prayers for rain, calling them stupid, young, Indian, white, threaded, Brahmin, and vulgarities.
I cannot speak in a public forum.
More printouts supporting supporting Hindus getting hacked by communists in India and saying they deserve it.
And similarly, communist Marxist leaders are being praised.
Good morning members of the State Board of Education.
My name is Leslie Conpol and I'm an 8th grader in Lawson Middle School in Cupertino.
I'm here to express my concern about how derogatory and stereotypical content about our particular culture in textbooks has long lasting impact on the students.
The students belonging to that culture are not able to understand and appreciate the richness of their own culture and end up and end up to develop inferiority complex about it.
Students from other cultures form wrong impressions and ideas about them, and it severely hampers their learning process.
It also encourages bullying and other bad behavior towards the students of the affected culture.
Hence, it is very important for you to ensure that no hateful or biased materials finds its way into the new textbooks.
I wholeheartedly support the recommendations made by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other accommodations to the board as they attempt to bring fairness and parity to the textbook contents regarding Hinduism and India.
Thank you for listening.
Good morning, respected members of the SBE.
I am Vasmati, mother of the two girls, grew up in Indian culture.
I am proud American Indian.
Today, I am here to support Jeffrey Long and other academics who are seeking accuracy in our children's school textbooks.
Children's textbooks should teach our kids unbiased and positive aspects of culture and history of Hindus and Indians.
Negative aspects of Hindus lead to the hatred and bullying of the Hindu kids at the school.
Hinduism, Indian culture, which taught tolerance, nonviolence, and dharma among different religions, Hindu, Muslim, Jewish, Christian, Zoroastrian, et cetera, lived together in India from centuries.
And so I stand here as one of among hundreds of Hindus who speak today saying just one thing, stop hatred and misrepresentation of Hindu culture beliefs in children textbooks.
Let's help our children grow strong and self-esteem who are future leaders makes our country great.
Thank you for listening.
Good morning.
My name is Arvind Malik from the Sacramento area.
For most of history, India was the wealthiest region of the world.
In both ancient and medieval times, India represented about one-third of the world's economy.
That's an even bigger share than the United States in the modern day.
During the British colonial times, unfortunately, India turned from the world's richest country to one of its poorest countries, and racist colonial powers deliberately diminished Indian history and achievements.
Unfortunately, many of the proposed textbook materials are following the same racist and colonial pattern that the British showed.
Instead of showing Indian advancements in surgery, medicine, science, and math, they show ancient India as being poor and backward, which is very factually inaccurate,
and unfair.
It's demeaning and distressing.
It's not consistent with California law and fairness and decency that we're all used to living in California.
I would appeal to the panel to reject all such textbooks that use racist images and texts.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Kevin Cabrera, and I'm here today to speak wearing two hats.
First, as a trained historian, I believe it is important to teach and educate our students on historical inquiry, analysis, interpretation of documents, and the idea that new information can shift a historical narrative.
I stand here to speak about the Mendez et al.
versus Westminster et al.
court case.
The school desegregation case occurred in Orange County in the 1940s.
This landmark case ended school segregation in California and paved the way to ending school segregation nationally.
While the historic framework recommends teaching this case, the narrative is of the Mendez family.
Eliminating the narratives of the other four families involved, Ramirez, Guzman, Estrada, Palomino, and the respective school districts.
Respected members of the State Board of Education, I am Preksha Deshpande from Sunnyvale.
I want to bring to your notice that the edits which the fringe Hinduphobic group South Asian Histories for All is suggesting has factual inaccuracies.
In their edits, they emphasize that the Jati system or what is better known as the caste system has existed only among Hindus.
This is not true and the fact is that it has existed in Sikhs and Buddhists also.
It is for this reason that the marginalized communities within Sikhs formed Ravidasi Gurudwaras in the first place.
There is enough evidence in the Pali literature, which is a source of ancient Buddhist texts, that Buddha too condoned the Jati system in many ways.
To press that it existed or exists only within Hindus is a blatant lie that religious fundamentalists within South Asian histories for all are perpetuating.
The changes that they suggest will not only lead to Category 1 violation, especially Category 1.10, but also violation of the norms of social content.
I urge you to reject the inaccuracies and save the children from the textbook, from hateful content.
Thank you.
Dear members of the State Board of Education, I am Rishita Rokaria, a sixth grader at St.
Joseph Feller Elementary.
I am highly flustered and alarmed about false pictures of modern India.
In my class, we're learning about the caste system.
My classmates happen to think that Hindus have an unfair belief in which each group has more.
powers than others.
Also, the textbook McGraw-Hill has two pictures.
One is of ancient India, and the other is of modern India.
I cannot tell the difference.
Why, you ask?
Because there is no difference, even though modern India should be displayed on a more higher level.
In fact, India is one of the most developed countries in Asia.
I highly support IQC's decision to reject MHMK K-6 and HMH 6-8 programs.
I also acknowledge Professor Jeffrey and 38 other top academics.
I approve you take all the recommendations.
Thank you.
Hi, good morning.
Respected members of the State Board of Education, I am Saloni Rukaria, sixth grader parent and a teacher from Milpitas Unified School District.
Fringe Hinduphobic group South Asian Histories for All is asking for removing or distorting content in the textbook that is present in the framework, including Hindu History of Harappa, which is on page 214 of 2016 HSS framework.
Saraswati River, which is on line page 215, line 814 of framework.
So, this would lead to violation of guidelines 1.2 of HSS adoption.
Hence, all their changes need to be rejected.
In one of the changes, they said that Harappan civilization is not mentioned in the framework, whereas it could be found at page 214.
Their suggestions are full of errors and would lead to serious violations of category 1 of adoption guidelines.
They have no backing by academics and are not even signed by anybody.
So looking at the magnitude and adverse effect of the edits suggested by them, I earnestly appeal you to reject them.
Thank you.
Respected members of the SB, I'm Ram Rao and I'm an 8th grader at South Lake Middle School.
My brother, a 6th grader, brought his history textbook home and as I was reading over it, I noticed that Hinduism was not accurately described.
In some places, it was portrayed as an inferior religion to some others.
It is my earnest request that you support the IQC in their rejection of HMH drafts and reject other drafts which have content not meeting the California framework.
My reason for the request goes like this.
Every one out of three Hindu American children have reported that they have been bullied based on religious beliefs and practices.
Many children have said that this happened after the section on Hinduism in ancient India were taught in schools.
I stand here in solidarity with all Hindu American children who have been bullied and who have to face discrimination in classroom.
Therefore, I request you to reject bias drafts and stop this menace of bullying.
Thank you.
Respected board members, good morning.
I'm Ankur Tyagi, working and living in Foster City.
I wish to express my views on the negative portrayal of Indian culture and Hinduism.
In these years, IQC, I believe, has indeed done a good job, and I thank and support them for canceling the two HMH programs.
I'm shocked, however, that National Geographic, which completely ignored the new framework, has been approved.
For example, it skips the core Hindu
teachings, festivals, and tries to show Hindus as being primitive and dirty.
It is prejudiced and racist to portray and associate dirty pictures with Hinduism.
Nat Geo has submitted a document to CD with corrections.
Their book should be adopted only if those proposed changes are accepted.
I demand that all recommendations of academic coalition by Professor Geoffrey Long and 38 other top academics be accepted.
Please let these kids have an opportunity to form an opinion of their own.
Thank you.
Respected board members I am Manasi Nekar and I am a sophomore at Westmont High School.
I am here today to stand against bullying of Hindu teens.
The negative portrayal of Hinduism in the textbook causes one in three teens to be bullied.
As a teenager students like me try to find our identity.
If students are being bullied for expressing their religion they grew up feeling embarrassed about their beliefs and identity.
We want to build a nation with confident citizens rather than ones with low self-esteem.
So please help teenagers like me by rejecting HMH's two programs as recommended by IQC.
I have been here multiple times.
Thank you IQC for letting our voices be heard.
Respected members of California State Board of Education, good morning.
My name is Prabhakar, president of Roseville.
I am father of a son who is studying sixth grade in Roseville City School District.
I am shocked and worried to see the inaccurate, biased, and discriminatory content about ancient India and Hinduism in his textbooks.
I fully support the recommendation of the Instructional Quality Commission
to reject the Harcourt textbook, but I would like you to do more to fix the problems.
McGraw-Hill also has a lot of prejudicial and racist content.
If McGraw-Hill does not accept the suggested corrections, please reject McGraw-Hill as well.
I also demand that all the recommendations of Academic Coalition by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other academics be accepted.
I stand here to oppose hatred against Indians and Hinduism.
Thank you for your time.
Hello everyone.
My name is Vijaya.
I'm from Irvine, Southern California.
I'm a mother of two kids.
First of all, I'm very much shocked to see how come in this country, which is known for the land of justice and equality,
irrespective of any race and religion, some publishers like HMH are able to spread hatred and discrimination.
So I strongly support the recommendations of IQC and I want this board to take the decision as soon as possible to make our kids' future bright.
Because if the kids are not learning love, peace and harmony, which is
already being taught in our culture.
They are not spreading this in the world.
So if we want to make this country bright, we have to ban these books and make the recommendations correct.
Thank you so much.
Good morning.
I am Manas Ray.
I live in Folsom, California.
I have a very simple and humble appeal to the learned men and women who are framing this syllabus.
Please help to stop poisoning the minds of the California school kids against a civilization, culture, and religion which has not radicalized a single soul still today to pick up a gun or truck to kill innocent people in California or USA.
Not a single pastor or priest of this religion in USA have been accused of child abuse.
So think positively of it and take action.
You can do it.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I am from what some people call low caste or backward class.
My name is Hari, and I'm a senior vice president in a global financial institution in Los Angeles.
I have two kids in the California system of education.
My plea is to treat Hinduism fairly per law.
Simple.
Currently, I see a continuation of anthropological, orientalist, colonial narrative that the world has moved away from.
The divide-and-conquer virus planted by the books written during the British colonial period is still being used by so-called scholars who do not practice Hinduism but rather take the easy road to scholarship by quoting from colonial writings.
It just simply doesn't go away.
I want to make it clear that the fringe Hinduphobic hate group South Asian Histories for All does not speak for me, a low-caste person so-called.
They blatantly try to use caste to erase our history by removing sages and saints from lower caste background, Valmiki, Vyasa, Guru Ramdas, in the framework ground and also trying here.
We need to stop.
The coalition is just purely Hinduphobic.
I would like to urge you to reject all the books written by HMS.
Thank you.
respected SB, and the concerned parent of the kids going to Cupertino schools.
I fully support the decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMH.
While some other textbooks programs are good, but the HMH programs are blatantly racist, Hinduphobic, and the worst in the quality.
There are numerous violations of Category 1 of the adoption guidelines, especially Category 1.10, which prohibits adverse reflection based on the religion and ethnicity.
They also violate the California law, which prohibits religious discrimination.
For example, both the HMH-6 and HMH-68 accurately show Buddhism and Sikhism as an improvement over Hinduism, which is a clear adverse reflection and violates Category 1.10 of the Adoption Guidelines.
Hence, I ask you to reject the HMH-2 programs as recommended by the IQC.
Else, I hold this board responsible for bigotry, discrimination, and hatred against Hinduism and India.
Thank you.
Hello, dear sir and madam.
I am Dinesh Jha.
I live in San Jose.
I have two kids going to Aberdeen Elementary School.
I support IQC's decision to reject HMH books for K-6 and 6-8, which have many violations.
I support the recommendation made by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other academicians.
Please accommodate all their changes.
Further, I stand with the hundreds of Californians here to ask that McGraw-Hill drafts be rejected as well.
These programs are blatantly racist and Hinduphobic.
They have numerous violations of Category 1,
adoption guidelines especially category 1.10 which prohibits adverse reflection based on the religion and ethnicity.
How can I accept the baseless claim made by McGraw-Hill book in the 6th grade page 264 which says that Buddhism is an improvement over Hinduism as if Hinduism was defective.
Further erroneously conveys that meditation was not part of Hinduism.
Due to such violations?
to accept Hinduism here.
Thanks.
Thank you, board members.
My name is Rama Tubanti.
I'm from Pleasanton.
My kids go to Pleasanton Unified School District.
And I'm here to fully support the IQC's decision to reject HMH K through 6 and then 6 to 8 programs.
And also fully support Professor Geoffrey Long and then 38 other top academicians that recommended the changes.
And the main point I would like to say is Hinduism is not a bad religion or anything.
It teaches the way of life and truth to the world.
So the Vedic scriptures and Hindu rituals all teach to love people, not only just humans, nature and animals and everything in the world.
Please support.
Respected members of State Board of Education, I am Chandra from Folsom, California, raising two kids in this state.
Today I stand here to oppose negative aspects against Hindus and Indians in the 6th to 8th grade children's school textbooks.
I thank and fully support the decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMH.
Even after the huge number of revisions and rewrites submitted at the last minute, which do not even address all the problems, HMH has to
submit 4,600 edits collectively for their programs that just four days ahead of IQC's deadline.
HMH itself has completely accepted that its books have huge problems.
That is why they need such major changes and rewrites.
Just for HMH 6th to 8th program, more than 100 revisions are complete, rewrites which is not allowed as per the adoption.
Hence, I ask you to reject HMS2 programs as recommended by IQC.
Thanks for listening.
Thank you very much.
Dear members of the State Board of Education, I'm Arul Verma and I'm a freshman currently attending the King's Academy in Sunnyvale.
You probably did not know that one in every three Hindu American children are bullied because of the portrayal of my religion taught in classrooms.
For example, HMHK through six and six to eight have pictures that show Hindus with trash as dirty.
This caused a seventh grade student to be called a dirty Hindu by one of his classmates in a class lesson.
I do not want to see any issue of bullying arising again because of a simple Hindu religion.
Therefore, I commend IQC for rejecting two Hindu-phobic books that clearly show Hindus associated with trash as dirty, and I stand with all Hindu-American children that have been bullied because of biased textbooks.
I also request that the recommendation of academic coalition with Jeffrey Long and 38 other top academics be accepted.
Thank you.
Dear members of the State Board of Education, my name is Monica Verma.
I'm from San Jose and a concerned mother of two kids who are 9 and 14 years old.
I would like to take this opportunity to express the shock and disagreement with some of the contents in public school books that misinterpret India's history and Hindu religion.
It causes embarrassment to me, leaving little doubt how much bullying kids may have to face because of the inappropriate and derogatory content
the books have on Hinduism and ancient culture of India.
The religious and historical details are not very accurate.
In addition to that, using modern day pictures to support it has no relevance to actual facts, hence degrading the quality of instructional material, which is wrongfully being imparted to the young minds.
I would therefore request the board to please instruct the publishers to thoroughly verify the contents before putting them in any books, be it any area or topic.
Thank you so much.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Kaushik.
I'm a civil engineer.
I'm a proud father of two kids.
While walking in, I noticed a nice statement in the notice board.
It says, healthy students create successful students.
So we all understand that mental health is part of overall health.
When this kind of material is published in the books, we know that it really impacts the mental health of a student because they are bullied.
I have heard
girls getting, Hindu girls being called as sniper dots.
Can you believe it?
In the schools, they are called sniper dots because they wear a Sindhu on their forehead.
So if you see the global picture of this, when you take a kid, when you depress them so much, and also when you use such derogatory terms on the religion that is founded on principles of forgiveness and peace,
It really depresses the student.
Once we have a depressed student, we have a depressed society because we should all remember that school is the first society a child encounters.
So I really request you guys to process this thing and thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Sheikha Saxena, and I'm a fifth grader from Elliott Ranch Elementary.
I'm here to talk about how books are lying about our culture.
California is one of the most diverse states in USA.
Because of that, we have the responsibility to make every culture look good.
But the Indian culture has been portrayed so it looks like a hot mess.
One issue is that books keep bringing up bad terms about Indian culture like cows, cats, and curry.
This leads to Indian kids getting bullied on stereotypes.
This also leads to many lies that kids carry out throughout their life.
All in all, I know your job is hard, but it's not an excuse for what is happening to Hinduism.
Thank you very much for your time.
Respected members of SBE, my name is Mahesh Kinnekar.
I work for Stanford, and I'm here as a concerned father of two kids.
We write you to address a letter submitted to the State Board of Education on November 1st by a group named South Asian Histories for All, or SAFA.
The letter claims that the history social science framework is not being followed, amongst other defamatory comments and statements about Hindu American community.
We take this opportunity to offer our observations on the changes that this group has suggested, as well as text that it cites as problematic in the textbook drafts.
Our overall observations are as follows.
In 32 of the 43 proposed revisions that SAHAFA has suggested, the original text from the textbook draft complies with what is mandated with the HSS framework.
In most cases, the text is nearly identical to what is mandated by the framework document, while in others, the text is clearly included in order to comply with the framework.
SAFA appears to be seeking directions and modifications of text that conforms to the framework.
Good morning, SBE.
Myself, Samruthi Zarkar, and I'll be continuing the speech.
So two changes are based on old revisions of textbooks, drafts, and are thus moot, as either the publishers and or the Instructional Quality Commission have changed the text.
None of the edits cite any scholarly references.
Many of SAHFA's suggestions adversely reflect upon Hinduism, thereby placing several textbook drafts in jeopardy of violating Category 1.10 of the HSS Adoption Criteria and the Social Content Citations.
Thanks for listening guys.
Good morning.
I'm Komar Tripasuri, continuing on to the same point there.
Given the SIHF's contentions about erasure of history, it is indeed ironic that nine of the total 43 edits call for deletions of content from the textbook drafts.
They even suggest a deletion of significant portion of the section on Hinduism in one of the textbooks.
While they claim to talk for the lower castes, we do not see any of their edits, any suggestions to add the cultural or religious contributions of lower castes.
It is rather because of the efforts of HEF that Hindu sages and saints from so-called lower castes were included in the framework in 2016.
We thus respectfully request the State Board of Education to reject these suggested revisions as they're not academically or historically sound, contradict the HSS framework, and would lead to gross violations of the HSS textbook adoption criteria, as well as numerous social content criteria.
Thank you.
Respected members of the State Board of Education, I am Deepna Sarkar from Fremont.
I stand here to support IQC's decision to reject HMH books for K-6 and 6-8.
My biggest anxiety is the way my culture and civilization are inaccurately portrayed in the textbooks.
It had been a very contradicting sixth grade of history science as I was forced to write incorrect notations against my will when I knew all along that it was wrong.
I was excited that all of it was going to change when the new textbooks came.
However, they're even worse than the previous books.
Accurate instructional materials can certainly be one of the factors in mitigating anti-Hindu bias and bullying, while helping to create safe learning environments for all students.
Thank you.
Good morning, dear members of the State Board of Education.
I am Praveen Tamar, parent of two children studying in Irvine.
I stand here to oppose hatred against Hindus and Hinduism.
I support the recommendation of academic coalition by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other top academics.
I fully support IQC's decision to reject HMH K-6 and HMH 6-8 programs.
But that's not enough.
Books by National Geographic, McGraw Hill, contain many of the same errors and misrepresentations.
They don't meet the standards set by content framework, violate California law in many categories.
Only Hinduism
is presented in negative manners with tags and references of social issues.
Social issues exist in all human societies, comprising all the religions.
Why mislead kids that social issues exist only in Hinduism?
Thank you.
Namaste.
I am Aparina Basavapatna from San Jose.
I am an eighth grader.
I stand here today to oppose hatred against Hindus and Indians.
I fully support the IQC board's decision to reject the HMH history program.
These faulty publications degrade Hinduism by including pictures of caricatures representing Hindu deities.
They even show Indians with trash signifying that they are dirty.
This picture.
It's not fair.
These books are biased.
Until and unless they're driven by utmost contempt, how could anybody write such discriminating books?
How could these books promote self-esteem and enable a safe, respectful, and welcoming environment in our schools?
They have many violations of Category 1 and 1.10, which prohibits adverse reflection based on religion and race.
I really ask you to incorporate Professor Long's work into use.
Let us not deprive California of what it needs, and thank you for your time and patience.
Good morning, respected members of the State Board of Education.
I am Sunita, mother of two kids studying in 6th and 10th grade, Cupertino School District.
I'm extremely shocked by seeing the textbooks in California, which portray inaccurate Indian history and Hinduism.
I appreciate IQC's decision to reject HMH because the textbooks are Hindu phobia, but rejecting HMH is not alone enough.
National Geographic has excluded newly added sections from 2016 framework.
National Geographic has submitted a document to the CDE with corrections.
So these books should be adopted only if these changes are reflected in their textbooks.
I also request you to accept the recommendations of the academic coalition by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other top academics.
Thanking you.
Good morning.
I am Samita Tripasiri from San Ramon, California.
I am here today opposing the hatred towards Hindus and Indians.
Many Indian students throughout California are being bullied.
The reason is because Hinduism is being portrayed incorrectly in the California textbooks.
What I mean by this is that the publishers are misrepresenting our culture.
I agree there are negative aspects to many religions and cultures throughout the world, but the publishers seem to highlight and exaggerate the Hindu religion the most.
As I mentioned, bullying happens a lot because of the textbooks.
One of several bullying incidents states that, I was at lunch and it was after we learned about Hinduism, they started saying my religion is the devil's religion and that I will go to hell.
This clearly points out the problems with the textbooks.
I urge the board to reject all material that has hatred against Hindus and every other community.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Swati.
I support IQC's suggestion to reject HMH draft.
Weird But True is the name of National Geographic book series.
Just like the name Weird But True, National Geographic has failed to mention Hindu contributions to the world, like concept of zero, yoga and meditation.
They have disregarded the new framework, so please reject their draft.
McGraw-Hill has failed to accept many edits from Professor Long and his team.
If these recommendations are not included, please reject McGraw-Hill draft.
Today, sadly, we are witnessing mass shootings.
In this social media age, messages of hate are thrown at us from all directions.
Respected members, the root cause of this hate is disinformation.
Therefore, it is very critical at this point to stop publishers from spreading disinformation and to prevent publishers from planting seeds of hate against Hindu culture in young minds.
Thank you very much.
Namaste.
Respected members of the State Board of Education, I'm Rakesh Wagh from Foster City.
I stand here to oppose hatred against Hindus and Indians.
IQC has shown the courage to reject hatred and prejudice by rejecting two Hinduphobic books so far.
We request SBE also to reject all hateful content, some of which is in other books.
Textbooks should be tool to formulate positive thoughts in young minds, and not the place for hatred, politics, or propagating nefarious agenda.
These formality years for kids should be in learning and appreciating the positive contributions of various civilizations and not fed with a cocktail of hatred and prejudice.
I support the recommendation by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other academicians.
Please consider them incomplete.
Thank you.
Respected members of State Board of Education, my name is Harkini Wagh.
I'm a 5th grader from Brewer Island Elementary School, Foster City.
I have heard stories from some of my 6th and 7th grade Indian origin friends about how they were bullied in school for being a Hindu.
I'm worried that I will have to suffer the same fate because the textbooks incorrectly portray my religion as inferior.
My religion never taught me to have negative prejudice against somebody who follows another way of life or prays to another form of God.
And I expect the SPE will present Hinduism with equal respect as it has shown to other religions.
Fighting with my classmates on whose religion is superior is the last thing I want to do in middle school.
Can you please fix those textbooks?
Thank you.
honorable members of the Department of Education of the State of California.
I am Ramakrishna Swamy, a Hindu saint and religious leader from Modesto, California.
In Hinduism and Indian culture, the social classification of mankind, firstly into the quadruple category of intellectuals or Brahmins, secondly into warriors and administrative statesmen or Kshatriyas, thirdly into mercantile businesspersons or Vaishyas,
And fourthly, into laborers, peasants, and shudras cannot beget any hatred or injustice for the reason that any civilization cannot function at all without such classes in society.
Even Roman and Greek civilizations had such classes based either hereditarily or occupationally.
Even now, such classifications exist in the modern global society with paraphrased labels.
I have a lot more to say, which I will give in writing.
And I second the move initiated by Professor Jeffrey Long.
Thank you.
Dear Board of Education, my name is Anish Dara.
I'm a fifth grader from KC, Foster City.
We are very appraising of your decision to reject a sixth grade textbook.
However, a few other books are making Hindu children uncomfortable in their schools and sometimes even neighborhoods.
They show irrelative topics rather than the sacred cities in India.
Hopefully, you understand that the books are illegally passing off bad information about the Indian civilization.
On my vacations to India, I have not seen any of this fake news except occasionally, but again, that is cited everywhere.
Good qualities such as yoga and eating healthy food is never shown in anything.
Hindu students are being bullied in day-to-day life.
and my friends in sixth grade feel the pain.
Next year I will be undergoing the same taunts as the middle schoolers.
We should have a society with the racial free harmony rather than bullying.
Thank you for listening to my presentation.
respected members of board.
I'm here, my name is Gautam Khandelwal and I'm here to support IQC's courageous decision to reject two programs of HMH.
And I say that because respected members, our, this great land of America is known for its innovation and science and technology, freedom of speech.
We are the oldest democracy in the world.
But think about it, if some science book doesn't teach all this, and instead of it, it teaches the Civil War, Native American suppression, this Iraq War, Vietnam War, what kind of impression that book will create on the student's brain?
Unfortunately, that's what HMH is doing with Indian and Indian civilization.
It is only talking about caste and all similar social evils.
So my sincere request to this board is that please reject those programs.
I demand dignity for India over hatred.
Thank you.
I am Professor Keshav Patel.
representing Vishwa Hindu Parishad of America, and Vishwa Hindu Parishad India, as well as Hindu University of America.
I'm from La Palma City.
I'm very much thankful to you for giving this opportunity to make some corrections, whatever is required in our textbook, California State textbooks, which is not written in a proper way.
Being a professor and trustee, I am shocked at the hatred against India and the Hindu culture shown in the California State Textbook.
I reject it and request you to make necessary changes for the sake of students and the bright future of the young generation.
I fully support the IQC's decision and reject the HMHK 628 program.
And I also support the recommendations of academic coalitions by Professor Geoffrey Long and 38 other top academics.
Okay.
Good morning, members of the board.
My name is Murugan Krishnan, coming from Orange County.
I've been living in this country over 20 years.
When I talk to my other non-Hindu friends, I ask them, when you say India or Hinduism, what comes to your mind?
They tell me vegetarian, yoga, guru system, those kind of things.
When we read the history books here, all we see is monkeys and cows eating dirt, those kind of portrayal.
We are one of the only religions celebrate women as a goddess.
But those kind of things are not mentioned.
Other religions, we treat all the religions equally.
We treat Buddhists and Sikhs as brothers and sisters.
But in this book, K6 and K6-8, it is said that Sikhism and Buddhism as an improvement over Hinduism.
It is kind of a divide and conquer these publishers are doing.
This is comparing one religion over another.
I don't know whether it's a good practice.
And so I just want all of you to support these programs and do the right thing, do a dignity for India, and do some good representation.
Thank you.
Namaste, board members.
This is Mayuresh Dhani.
I work at Redwood City, but I'm not there at work because I want to make children of my future so that they have, you know, they should be
proud of their Indian culture, which I see not happening.
I've been in this country only for about two years, but what I see is that there's a racial hatred and prejudice against Hindus predominantly, which I don't want to be happening.
This might
this might be because of the National Geographic learning, you know, the framework which was bypassed and the core Hindu teachings and festivals, they were also tried to be showed as dirty, which is not true.
So I just demand that the academic coalition is, okay, sorry.
Yeah.
Hello, my name is Samrat Jaka.
I'm going to sixth grade next year.
I have heard from my brother about the previous issues he experienced while going through the India chapter in his sixth grade.
He is a victim of teasing and bullying due to the improper explanations in the book of our culture.
I don't want that to happen to me.
Looking at the frameworks, my culture is shown very badly in some of them.
My culture is not shown as nicely as other cultures are shown.
They are showing us they are better than Indian Hinduism.
That's not right.
A lot of the information is wrong and negative.
For example, this picture has a farm man and monkey, but the topic is Maurya Empire.
How does this even relate to the empire?
Please reject the HMH frameworks and use the recommendations by Mr. Long and 38 others.
Thank you.
Respected members of State Board of Education, I'm Sri Lakshmi.
I'm coming from Foster City.
I'm a mother of two kids, like 10 and 7, and I'm here to oppose the hatred against Hindus and Indians.
I fully support the decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMH.
These programs are blatantly racist, hateful, and against LGBTQ community and very poor in quality.
They have numerous violations of Category 1 of adoption rules, especially Category 1.10, which prohibits adverse reflection based on religion and ethnicity.
For example, in a blatantly racist depiction, it shows Indian laborers working alongside monkeys and thereby equating Indians with monkeys.
This is really disrespectful for the farmers who feed all the families.
And me coming from the farmer's family, like my ancestors, my parents, my grandparents and forefathers are from farmer's background.
I really feel like I'm disrespectful for that.
And thank you very much for your time.
Thank you.
Respecting members of the board.
Namaste.
Namaste means a gesture where the acknowledgement of the soul in one to the soul in another.
Hopefully the soul of a student will be acknowledged.
I'm Dhwani Maru a sixth grader started a new phase at Monroe Middle School with all new friends new studies and new teachers.
But this summer I read the history textbooks for the coming next 10 academic years which made me feel low in esteem
seeing my motherland India and disgrace of its culture and Hinduism.
I am worried that my friends will make joke on my country and its religion, and they would start bullying me by keeping names.
As a student and as a child, I don't want my morale to go down.
How will I study in such an environment?
And this could also happen to other kids.
Hopefully you all understand how
Bullying can affect the growing kids and their parents.
My concern is when all truth facts about other civilizations are given, then why not Indian civilization?
Thank you.
Respected members of SBE, my name is Rajesh Yavantikar.
I work here in high-tech company and I'm here, I'm a proud father of a daughter as well.
She goes to the Folsom Cordova District School.
I stand here to oppose the hatred against Hindus and Hinduism.
I commend and fully support the decision of IQC to reject
two programs of HMS.
These programs are blatantly racist, hinduphobic, and worst in quality.
They have numerous violations of category 1 of adoption guidelines, especially the category 1.10, which prohibits the adverse reflection based on religion and ethnicity.
They also violate the California law, which prohibits the religious discrimination
My ask is to reject racist publishers like McGraw Hill, HMH, and Discovery.
Thank you for your time and patience listening.
respected member of the SBE.
My name is Abha Killedar.
I stand here among hundreds of Hindus who are speaking today and thousands of others who have sent letters and signed petitions across California.
Today I am speaking out against the harmful perception and racist content that McGraw Hill is attempting to put in the textbook for our youth.
This publisher has the duty to compile with the framework set forth by the California Department of Education, and if McGraw-Hill chooses not to accept this correction, the book themselves must be rejected, as was HMHS content.
Further, the recommendation put forth by the academic coalition led by Professor Jeffrey Long must be accepted if we wish to create a safe and fair learning environment for the students across California.
Thank you for your time.
Hello to all.
My name is Balu Shastri.
I'm an energy market specialist from Los Angeles.
First off, I would like to also just lend support to the LGBT colleagues and their efforts.
I went to school from L.A.
from preschool.
I was born and raised in L.A.
and I would like to think Los Angeles is, you know, the epitome of diversity and inclusiveness.
Yet, in school, I faced insulting comments about Hinduism, mocking the idea of seeing divinity in animals.
A couple of kids even told me that I'm going to hell.
I don't think this is the kind of circumstances that any kid should face.
So I would urge to reject HMH as recommended by the IQC, and I would urge to support the edits by Jeffrey Long and 38 other academics.
Thank you, and have a good day.
Hi, my name is Sanjana Prabhakar.
I'm from San Jose.
And I'm here for the same reason as many of us, to reject HMH as recommended by IQC and support the edits by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other academics.
I'm here.
I came to U.S.
when I was 19, and I had my three kids born and brought up here.
So my first daughter, when she went to school, she was harassed and she was bullied, but she was able to handle it.
We took her to India for many, you know, to show her the actual India.
But my other daughter was not able to take the bully she was facing in school.
And she went into depression.
And I mean, as a mother, you can't even imagine what we have gone through.
and she was severely depressed.
She was in lockdown for five days, and she was on medication.
I mean, I don't think any of you, you can see a mother's situation, and I don't want other kids to go through this, and I would request you to take the recommendations of Professor Jeffrey Long.
Thank you.
Hello.
I'll come to the meaning of that at the end of my small talk.
Respected members of State Board of Education, I'm from Folsom, California, and I have two children who have completed education in this system.
I stand here to support IQC's decision to reject
HMH K-6 and HMH 6-8 programs.
I stand in support of the recommendations of academic coalition by Professor Jeffrey Long and the 38 other top academics.
Please, please accept all their recommendations.
Biased portrayal of Hinduism, which is lopsided and is inaccurate.
sixth grade textbook of HMH 6 to 8 program calls Vedas the sacred Hindu scriptures as a collection of spells and charms.
No other sacred book is like this.
Hence, I ask you again to reject HMH programs.
Thank you.
Dear members of State Board of Education, Namaste.
I am a 6th grader from Emperor Elementary School in Temple City, Los Angeles.
I have read the chapter on Indian culture in my social studies textbook.
I can certainly say that it is not an accurate representation of my religion.
A bullying report on Hindu American children says that a student was bullied after they learned about Hinduism.
Please drop any textbook drafts that do not promote civil behavior towards each other.
It will be a great step to stop bullying in schools and promote harmony.
I would also like to see topics covering yoga, Indian music, and dance in my textbooks.
Many people in California practice these arts and benefit from them.
In fact, yoga originated in India and has many health benefits.
Let's make our textbooks better and stop bullying.
Thank you.
Dear members of State Board of Education, I'm Neelima from Dublin and a parent of two.
I fully support IQCF's decision to reject HMH K-6 and HMH 6-8 programs, but that is not enough.
I support the recommendation of Jeffrey Long and 38 other top academics.
Please include them.
On page 177 of 6th grade textbook of HMH 6 through 8, program calls Vedas the sacred Hindu scriptures a collection of spells and charms.
Spells and charms?
No other sacred book is mentioned in such denigrating terms.
This is inaccurate, biased, and discriminating.
I stand here to oppose hatred against Hindus and Indians.
Please consider this and don't make any child experience painful and leaving bad memories to them.
Thank you for your time.
Namaste everyone, respected members of the board.
My name is Vijay Gugnani and I'm a concerned father of two kids, one currently a high schooler and other one a second grader.
My son, who is high schooler now, he went through a humiliating and horrible experience of
uh, learning highly inaccurate and distorted presentation of Hinduism in sixth grade, um, uh, our, our California education board ethnic and cultural group section clearly states to instill sense of pride in his or her heritage, um, and that no religious group should be
portrait as inferior.
I don't see that.
How is that possible when books are portraying India and Hinduism in a completely negative light?
I strongly believe you guys will take a right decision today and drop misleading and completely stereotyped narrative suggested by HMH, McGraw-Hill, National Geographic, and we'll support edits submitted by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other academics.
I sincerely hope that my second grader doesn't have the same negative experience.
Thank you very much.
Hi.
Hi my name is Suchai and I'm a student at Cuesta Elementary School Mountain House.
To me my country is a place where I get together with my aunts uncles and grandparents and have fun.
To me my country is a beautiful place.
To me my country is full of amazing and colorful cultures and traditions.
But not everyone thinks of my country in this way.
There was a class of 6th graders who were taught about Hinduism in this way.
The teacher put a bunch of papers into a hat.
Half of them said Brahmins and half of them said Untouchables.
Each student picked up one piece of paper from the hat.
If they were Brahmins for the rest of the week, they could talk only to other Brahmins, but they had to stay away from the Untouchables.
If they are an Untouchable, they had to stay away from the Brahmins.
That's not what Hinduism is.
One of my friends of other religions learned about my culture.
I don't want them to think about slums for people and the caste system.
I want them to think of the beautiful festivals and temples that fill up my country.
Thank you!
Respected board members, I am Sunil Agarwal, concerned parent of 8th grader and 1st grader studying at LAUSD.
I believe our education system should encourage and motivate children when they read and learn about their own culture, history, and religion.
When I read sixth grade history book, I found untruthful and derogatory representation of India and Hinduism.
I could not expose such untruthful and unequal right up to my daughter and decided to take her to India for sixth grade education.
I brought her back once she completed her sixth grade in India.
I have another first grader.
I hope that by the time when she is in sixth grade, she will be reading all positive aspects about her heritage and religion.
Hinduism gave number zero yoga, surgery, and so many wonderful things.
According to Medicine Project, India was number one item in terms of GDP till 17th century in the world.
Yoga is providing healthy lifestyle to millions of people around the world, but students are not exposed to such wonderful gifts of Hinduism in India.
I urge board to please accept the changes.
Thank you.
Dear members of State Board of Education, I'm Radha, a concerned parent of two kids from Cupertino.
I stand in front of you to speak against the demonization of Hindus and Indians.
I stand here as a Hindu, as Indian, as an Asian, with the support of other Asians and Pacific Islanders.
I stand here to support Jeffrey Long and other academics who are seeking historical accuracy.
I commend IQC for rejecting the two Hinduphobic books that have the images that clearly depict
Hinduism and India as filthy backward culture.
However, I think this is not enough and much more needs to be done.
I strongly urge the board to say no to hatred against Hindus in all forms.
We, Hindus of all diverse backgrounds and of all castes, vocations, communities, languages, demand that hatred against Hindus be stopped.
Thank you.
Dear members of the State Board of Education.
I'm Aditya Fadnavis studying in 6th grade in Lawson Middle School in Cupertino.
I feel worried and insecure in my school environment after reading the bullying report released by HAF.
I am utterly shocked that the textbooks which encourages these types of bullying are considered for adoption in California.
I fully support IQC's decision to reject HMH K through 6 and HMH 6 through 8 programs but that is not enough.
I request you to consider rejecting the other textbooks from McGraw Hills and National Geographic and help bring a secure environment in our schools.
Thank you.
Hi, good morning, everyone.
I hope I'm audible.
First of all, good morning to everyone, all the state members of education.
My name is Prasanna, resident of San Jose, a parent of two children who are studying in San Jose school, and a proud husband.
My wife is also a teacher in one of the private schools.
And today, I'm representing all four of them.
So first of all, I would like to congratulate IQC for their decision to reject two HMH programs.
But I believe that itself is not enough.
Today I stand here with two split sentiments.
Part of me is in complete disbelief.
that the textbooks which will bring racism to classroom are scheduled to get into our academics syllabus.
And part of me is very hopeful that the State Board of Education will listen to the request made by thousands of parents like me and make a right decision.
I strongly urge SB members to consider the recommendations made by Academic Coalition, by Professor Geoffrey Long and 38 other academics.
Thank you for listening.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Vinod, and I'm a parent of a third grader in San Jose.
A few weeks back, the IQC rejected the HMH textbooks drafts for K-6 and 6th grade.
I'm really delighted about that.
The problem with the HMH textbook drafts is that it has only the demeaning information about Hinduism and India.
In the first page of grade 6, module 6,
has a picture of Lord Indra on an elephant with a beautiful gold crown with precious jewels, but the narrative refers to him as a unicorn.
This kind of textbook is unacceptable to me as a parent because I, as a parent, would not encourage this kind of name-calling, but this is not what the textbook is promoting.
These kind of drafts clearly violate California Education Code 51501, 60040, and 60044.
I request the SBE to go ahead with the IQC recommendation of rejecting HMS draft.
Thank you.
Dear members of the State Board of Education, my name is Akshata.
I'm a parent of four-year-old and here to express my deep anguish on how Hinduism and India have been represented in the textbooks.
As I became aware of this issue, I have been worried thinking how my son would be impacted with such biased, stereotypical, and inaccurate textbooks creating prejudice against his culture and religion.
I deeply appreciate and wholeheartedly support IQC's decision to reject the Hardcourt K-6 and K-6-8 books.
I do believe that National Geographic also carries problematic Oriental content against Hindu civilization.
Our history should be documented through we the inheritors of the civilization rather than the invaders who came to plunder, erase, divide, and enslave our identity.
I humbly request SBE to reject Hardcourt.
National Geographic has submitted a document to the CDE with corrections.
National Geographic books should be adopted only if all these changes are reflected in their textbooks.
Thank you.
Respected members of State Board of Education.
My name is Rishika Sahoo and I'm a fifth grader in Brewer Island Elementary School in Foster City.
My older sister is in 9th grade and she learned misguided information about Hindu culture.
I know the many truths about Hinduism but her classmates don't.
I don't want to go through what my sister felt and read about my culture negatively in her school.
I also don't want to be teased taunted and bullied by my classmates due to what the textbook will say next year.
So I please don't.
So please don't make my textbook next year misguided and hinduphobic.
I think and support IQC's decision to reject Harcourt's two programs.
Thank you for listening.
Respected member of the State Board of Education.
I'm Manoj Kumar Sahu father of two children.
studying in ninth grade and fifth grade in San Mateo County.
My first child has learned negative perception and presentation of the Hinduism from the middle school textbook that wireless California State Law Education Court
After coming from home, she told us that she was disappointed in the Hinduism section of the textbook.
I don't want my second child to learn the same misconception about Hinduism.
So I'm here to support IQC's decision to reject HMH K-6th grade and HMH 6th to 8th grade programs.
And I request you, please reject McGraw-Hill programs.
learn that they have not adopted 2016 testbook framework.
Thank you for listening.
Good morning, everyone.
I'm Manish Jain, and I follow Jainism.
I'm standing here to oppose bullying originating from racial discrimination in social science textbooks from 6th to 8th grade.
In my opinion, the content of books published by McGraw-Hill Publishers discriminate against Hinduism in India, which indirectly motivates racial discrimination against American students following Hinduism.
California Governor Jerry Brown passed a bill on anti-bullying.
However, the social science books published by McGraw-Hills directly or indirectly motivates bullying.
I request you to seriously reconsider McGraw-Hills' recommendations.
Politics and hatred should not guide our textbooks, but research and facts should.
Thank you for your time.
respected members of the State Board of Education.
I am from Rancho Cordova, Sacramento, father of two kids, studying in sixth standard and kindergarten.
I stand here not only to fight hatred against the Hindu Americans, but also support the African American communities.
All communities, all parents, all educators have the concern of children in mind.
That's why we need to stop hatred against all communities and need to respect for all communities.
I stand here to support Jeffrey Long and 38 other academics who are seeking historical accuracy.
I request that the recommendation by the Jeffrey Long and the academic group be accepted to address all the problems.
Thank you for hearing.
Thank you for listening.
Thank you.
Respected members of the California State Board of Education, my name is Vishnu Mata and I'm an 8th grader living in Mountain House, California.
I would like to talk about the problem of bullying of Hindu American students as a result of information in the 6th grade education system.
I suffered first-hand experience from this terrible outbreak of bullying of Hindu American students.
I do not want other students to feel the pain and shame that I did.
If textbooks indirectly encourage kids to call Hindus untouchables, or tell them that all Indians grew up in slums, it is an injustice to the rest of the population.
It is an injustice to know that many Hindus will be bullied like me.
And it is certainly an injustice if other kids must feel all the wretched feelings that I had to feel.
and this must change now.
I advocate for all changes that my fellow speakers have made, and much more.
If we can change the outlook of even one student, then we have definitely succeeded.
Thank you, esteemed board members.
Hi, my name is Chen Mai and I'm a sophomore at Mount House High School and I stand here to oppose hatred against Hindus and Indians.
Currently, I'm taking a college class on Eastern religions, including Hinduism.
During our lecture on Hinduism, my professor said, and I quote, Hindus believe that everyone else in the world is Hindu.
It's a way of living that everyone in India is made to follow.
I was baffled by this statement, so I raised my hand and told him, I'm a Hindu and I accept other religions.
This is to which he replied, saying, maybe you're not a Hindu.
This exchange occurred in a college class with over 50 other students.
The Hindus in our class tried to tell him that this isn't what we believe, but these misconceptions were so deeply rooted that there was nothing we could do about it.
The beliefs that people have in adulthood reflects what they were taught from a young age.
If we can fix this false perspective that people are holding from their childhood, we can stop people from having experiences like this.
America is a country that has the blending of different races, and we're here to create awareness and acceptance.
respected member of SBE.
My name is Ekanath Pai, and I live in San Ramon with my wife and two kids.
They also attended SRVUSD.
So 11th grader in Texas was told by her classmates to convert to Christianity, to become more civilized.
A seventh grader in New York was bullied by the classmate saying her Hinduism was devil's religion.
Such unfortunate events are a result of textbooks presenting Hindus as primitive, dirty, and bad.
There is no such place for hatred and bullying in a civilized place like ours.
So the solution is to present Hinduism in a dignified and respectful manner.
I support recommendation of Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other scholars.
I also urge you to take your responsibility seriously, please, and to reject all content that promotes hatred and bullying, just the way IQC has done recently.
Thank you.
Dear members of the SPE.
I'm Mukta Shinde a fourth grader from Cupertino Union School District.
Textbooks should tell the correct history about Hindus.
If they don't then students from all communities will think the history it's correct and pass on the wrong information.
So I urge you to stop this from happening because only you can do it at this point.
Thank you for your patience and listening.
This is good for you.
Good morning.
My name is Shadipta Sen.
I'm a professor of history at UC Davis.
I have taught history of India and South Asia in this country for nearly 25 years.
I'm here representing the 100 leading scholars from South Asia from top-ranked American universities who are signatories to this letter that we have distributed, asking you to desist from voting on adopting these textbooks till you fix these mistakes that we have underlined.
I implore you to convene a new review board of experts from institutions such as Davis, Berkeley, and others in the UC system to look into this matter.
Publishers have been put under tremendous and unfair pressure to erase facts about the historical inequities, inequalities of caste and gender.
by lobbyists who also want to marginalize the contribution of Buddhists, Jains, Sikhs, Muslims, and Dalits to South Asian history and civilization.
Such sanitized and biased textbooks will not help our young students prepare for high school and college-level history courses.
My research and teaching are funded by you, California taxpayers.
It is my responsibility to make sure that K-8 teachers are not forced to misrepresent Indian and South Asian history to our children.
Thank you.
I'm Anasuya Sengupta.
I'm with South Asian Histories for All.
We represent eight religions, multiple castes, and over 20 groups.
I speak after one renowned historian, Professor Sen, and over 100 Hindu nationalists, because this is what education has come to, history by brute force and alternative facts.
I'm a Rhodes Scholar.
I'm a Hindu.
The Hindu American Foundation does not speak for me and our diverse South Asian communities.
They've lobbied to erase caste oppression, the histories of Buddhism and Sikhism, demonized Muslims, and reduced my practice of Hindu pluralism to Hindu supremacy.
The curriculum framework that you adopted was for parity and fairness.
California students deserve better than propaganda and lies.
SBA, please act now.
Enforce your framework.
Fix the mistakes.
Thank you.
Hello, I'm Rakesh Patak from San Jose.
This is a picture of an Indian empire, a section in the HMH K-6 textbook.
Is this an empire?
This is a blatant caricature of Indians.
It shows monkeys working with humans.
This is a violation of California state law education code section 51501.
Google can do better.
I'm relieved that IQC has rejected both the drafts from HMH.
Is it enough?
No.
We need to do the same for National Geographic.
Why?
It has outdated and completely disregarded HSS framework of the latest 2016.
It completely ignores the scriptures and the basic concept of Hinduism, Vedas, yoga, primary goals in life.
I request you to
Follow the recommendations of Professor Long and the other academics who have submitted what should be corrected in these books.
Thank you.
Dear board members, my name is Umesh Pathak and I'm from San Jose.
From India, I'm from Gaya, where Buddha got enlightenment.
That's where I come from.
To come to the point, IQC recommended rejecting one of the racist publishers, HMH Harcourt, K6 and 628.
However, IQC missed rejecting McGraw-Hill and National Geographic published textbooks, leaving me still distressed.
I request all of you to not only reject HMH, but also National Geographic and McGraw-Hill for K6, 6 to 8, since these two publishers do not care to follow the framework that you have agreed upon.
For example, both publishers ignore oneness of all living beings, and National Geographic ignores Jainism entirely in Chapter 10.
I expect you to make sure that you and publishers follow the frameworks and law of the land before allowing any book in the schools to eliminate religion and ethnicity-based bullying of students, such as my sons, in the schools and society.
And yes, I don't also like propaganda.
Hello all, I am Vishwanath Jakka from San Jose, a father of a 9th grader and a 5th grader.
I would like to first start off with saying thanks to IQC for correctly rejecting the two Hinduphobic books.
However, I would like to ask SBE to reject those two as well and not only there, reject other books that are propagating this Hinduphobic content.
So it's not just the other publishers.
There are other groups who are, in the last minute, bringing in new, unvalidated, incorrect information to solve the process.
I stand in front of you to speak against the demonization of Hindus and our culture.
I also stand here with the support of LGBTQ community, Asians, numerous interfaith groups, and representation by academics, educationalists, and those of Hindus.
We have a diverse background with all communities, castes, religions, and regions and languages.
I urge SBE to stop the propagation of hatred against Hindus and Hinduism.
Thank you.
Respected members of the State Board of Education, good morning.
I am Ashta Lakshmi, a Tamil, a practicing Hindu from the Bay Area.
A fringe Hinduphobic group, South Asian Histories for All, SAFA, is suggesting edits that are not just hateful, but are inaccurate and violative of HSS adoption criteria.
The changes that they suggest will not only lead to Category 1 violation, especially Category 1.10, but also violation of norms of the social content.
What this fringe group, SAFA, is trying, through its edits, is to present a Hinduphobic view of caste and thereby spread hatred.
They are systematically trying to erase the history of Dalits, lower caste Hindus, their spiritual movements, and even instances of emancipation that come from within the Hindu society.
They try to attribute all of the emancipation of Hindus to Buddhists, Sikhs, and Muslims.
They have not even mentioned a single instance of positive contributions of lower caste Hindus in their edits, wherein history is full of such examples.
Looking at the magnitude and adverse effect of the edits suggested by them, I earnestly appeal you to reject these edits.
Thank you.
Good morning.
First of all, I really applaud you.
You're very good listeners.
My name is Ravinder Kumar.
I'm a proud father of daughter and son, who already graduate to be a doctor and software engineers.
And both of my kids felt bullied because of the history lesson that perpetuate the stereotype about the homeland.
I don't know, gentlemen, ladies, how you feel when your kid come home bullied, but I felt pretty bad about that.
In my earnest effort to save my next generation from being bullied and misrepresentation of Hindu religion and Hindu culture, I fully support the recommendation of the Instructional Quality Commission to reject the textbooks of HMH, but
but I would like you to do more to fix the problems.
McGraw-Hill has a lot of prejudiced and racist content.
I also demand that all the recommendations of Academic Coalition of Professor Jeffrey and Long, 38 other top academics, be accepted.
Thank you very much.
Have a good day.
Hello, respected board members.
My name is Ramani Cheru from San Jose, and I'm a proud practicing Hindu.
I am here to talk about the misrepresentation of one of the oldest religions in the planet.
There is a quote that a picture speaks 1,000 words.
The pictures displayed in the textbooks from publishers like HMH represent Hinduism in a very disgraceful manner.
I would request you to reject such publishers and replace the content.
May I suggest replacing the images with positive aspects like yoga and meditation, cultural diversity, scriptures, and spirituality that Hinduism can offer?
Thank you.
Hello, I'm Jyoti Agrawal, a resident of San Jose, father of two children.
I stand here to support IQC's decision to reject HMH book for K25 and 628.
Further, I support the recommendations made by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other academics.
I appeal the chair to accept all their recommendations.
The HMH program deserved to be dejected because on page 177 of 6th grade textbook, it calls the Vedas, the sacred Hindu scripture, a collection of spells and charms.
I am outraged.
No other sacred book is mentioned in such denigrating terms.
This is inaccurate, biased, underwhelming and discriminatory.
IQC has shown the courage to reject hatred and prejudice by rejecting two Hindu phobic books.
We request SBE also to reject all hateful content and say no to hatred against Hindus in all aspects.
Thank you and please do the needful.
Namaste, members of the State Board of Education.
My name is Shilpa Jakka.
I'm a parent of a 9th grader and a 5th grader in San Jose.
I stand here to support IQC's decision to reject HMH books from K-8 period.
Some of the pictures are racist and discriminate against Hindus.
How could somebody propose such books for schools?
They have numerous violations of Category 1 of adoption guidelines, especially Category 1.10, which prohibits adverse reflection based on religion and ethnicity.
They also violate the California law, which prohibits religious discrimination.
Further, I support the recommendations made by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other academics.
I appeal the chair of State Board of Education to accept all the recommendations.
Thank you.
Hello, Namaste, respected members of State Board of Education.
I am Divya, and I'm a parent for a four-year-old.
I reside in Folsom, and I stand here today to oppose the hatred that our textbooks are displaying against Hindus and Indians.
I thank and fully support the decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMH.
I understand that even after a number of revisions and rewrites submitted by the publisher at the last minute,
even that does not show all the right aspects of Indian culture and history.
There are a lot of errors, even the small errors.
For example, the K-6 teacher edition of page number 469, their revision says Martin Luther King Jr.
instead of the Martin Luther King.
So what we are standing here and asking is to depict the great Indian civilization with dignity and the truthfulness.
Hence, I conclude by saying that please accept the rejection of IQC, HMH, and two programs, and recommend the IQC.
Thank you.
Respected members of SBE, namaste.
My name is Vaishnavi Ravinuthala, and this is my third time speaking here for the following cause.
I, as a sophomore in high school, can vouch for all the Hindu children who get bullied.
One of three Hindu American children get bullied.
Why does this happen?
This happens because of the wrong impressions of Hinduism in India made on students and teachers.
In my school, because of pictures of slums and poverty in India, my teachers and classmates think that India is completely covered in slums.
How does today's poverty even relate to ancient history?
In fact, according to the study by OECD, The World Economy, by Angus Madison, India's GDP was 25% or above until the 1800s.
It's been almost two decades since this work was published, but none of the books refer to such authentic information.
This is pure arrogance because this esteemed CDE is giving a free ride.
They should stop now.
Please reject all textbooks that portray ancient India in a negative way.
Thank you.
Dear members of the State Board of Education, my name is Aditi Gajar and I'm a 10th grader attending Evergreen Valley High School in San Jose, California.
Living in such a diverse place, I find it bothering that my culture and my religion are displayed so negatively in the 6th grade world history textbooks.
In sixth grade, when our class finally got to the India chapter, I noticed that many key aspects were either missing or misrepresented.
The textbook syllabus and use of words caused me to question my own culture.
However, California state law education code sections clearly state
that a governing board shall not adopt instructional materials for use in the schools that in its determination contain any matter reflecting adversely upon persons on the basis of race or ethnicity, gender, religion, or nationality.
Thus, I ask you, why are Hindu children having to feel alienated in their own classroom because of content in their own world history textbooks?
Good morning CDE community.
My name is Shiva and I attend Chaboya Middle School.
I want to raise a question of about why should India be represented as a poor and needy country.
Would you show the U.S.
with all the ugly faces in the country.
Of course not.
One day my mother wanted to take a campaign at my school middle school to get signatures for the last hearing here on
28th of September.
We asked the school for permission.
When the assistant principal answered, she said, oh, your sons can start a club here to raise money for the poor and needy of India.
This response taunted our family for days.
Where did the assistant principal get this from?
She saw books with pictures of ancient India.
In fact, until 1800s, India's GDP was 25% or more of the world's GDP.
Bias information is the law that there should be no bias information on religions in textbooks which the students and teachers take as credible is not acceptable.
Please reject books that are biased against India.
Thank you.
Dear members of the State Board of Education, I'm Divya Shenoy, a 10th grade student at Evergreen Valley High School.
In the 6th grade, I was excited to learn about my culture, only to be bent by ignorance and disgust from my classmates after reading the textbooks.
My classmates confused deities for demons and mocked cultural dances.
In response to this behavior, I felt ostracized and ashamed of my religion.
Hindu students surveyed across the United States also feel the same, experiencing awkwardness and exclusion, and they deal with depression due to this bullying.
I commend IQC for removing both HMH programs for middle school and elementary school children.
Additionally, Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other scholars' recommendations should be taken into account when bettering the textbooks.
Thank you.
Hello everyone, my name is Shivangi Singh and I'm a junior at Evergreen Valley High School.
I came to speak on this subject about two years ago and I'm kind of disappointed that nothing's happened yet because I'm a firm believer in the idea that education should be unbiased and that
You should have both the good and the bad portrayed throughout the textbooks for the education to truly be unbiased.
But I'd also like to remind you that every single religion has skeletons in their closet, but not every single religion is being portrayed the same.
So I just want to bring up the case that you've been giving everybody else a fair chance, but we haven't received a fair chance.
And I think that
you should really accept the recommendations of Professor Jeffrey Long and all of the other academics in the coalition.
And students deserve to receive an unbiased education.
And by continuing to uphold this clear show of distaste towards my religion, you're not just hurting my people, you're hurting all of these other students who are going to be receiving a very small-minded and negative view of a religion that is very important to all of us.
And that is not something that I think can be justified by a school board of education.
Thank you.
Respected members of the State Board of Education, Namaste.
My name is Madhuri and I am a parent of two children from San Jose City, Evergreen School District.
The edits which fringe Hindu-phobic groups such as South Asia Histories for All is asking for contents that are disturbing and contain hate material.
I urge not to add these to the textbooks.
Their changes clearly lead to major revisions to the textbooks at this last minute and such big changes at the last moment are not in accordance with the adoption guidelines.
An example of such an edit is Hindu History of Harappa which is on page 214, line 829
to 831 in 2016 HSS framework.
Saraswati river which is on line of the page 215 line 814 of the framework is being asked to be removed.
This would lead to violation of guidelines
1.2 of HSS adoption in one of the changes that they say Harappan civilization is not mentioned.
I sincerely request you to uphold the adoption guidelines and reject the hateful and inaccurate edits.
Respected members of the State Board of Education, my name is Skanda Vasishta.
I am in eighth grade and I attend Winston Churchill Middle School.
When I was in sixth grade, prior to the Hinduism unit, I was excited to expand my knowledge about my religion.
However, after reading the chapter, I was shocked to see the negative portrayal of Hinduism.
This affected me personally.
My peers would ask me questions about Hinduism that made me feel awkward.
On a test, I wondered whether I should put the answer that matched up with my beliefs or the answer that came from the textbook.
I have nothing against other religions, but as the year went on, I observed that other religions in the textbook were idealized, while Hinduism was described as a negative, unclean religion.
Please take some action and reject the HMH history textbooks that show Hinduism in a negative way.
Thank you for your time.
Good morning.
Respected members of State Board of Education, I am Gururaj Narasimha, living here in the USA since 2005.
I strongly urge the board to reject history textbook from HMH publications and implement recommendations by the academic coalition led by Professor Jeffrey Long.
I am proud of this country that provides opportunities to culturally diverse people from all around the world.
I'm also proud of India, where I come from, and proud of my Hindu religion, which has taught me to be tolerant, peaceful, and nonviolent.
My son studies in a local middle school here and like millions of kids of his age has been taught about the religions of the ancient world in his history textbook.
It was shocking that Hinduism was portrayed in such a negative way in his textbook.
I don't want my children to feel low about their rules.
I don't want them to be bullied in the school because of their religion.
I see only positive things being said of other religions, then why this indifference towards Hinduism?
Textbooks should show Hinduism's huge contributions to the world in the fields of science, art, architecture and well-being instead.
Again, I strongly urge the board to reject history textbooks from HMH publications.
Thank you very much.
Namaste, respected board members.
My name is Ranga Thattiparthi.
I'm a father of two girls who go to the Folsom-Kodawa school district.
I would like to point out here inherent bias in the textbooks published by HMS against Hinduism.
In particular, I would request you to remove the outdated and inaccurate narration about Indians and Hinduism.
Indians and Hinduism.
I fear my children will be a subject to the racial bias by fellow kids due to their faith they followed by birth.
Hinduism has given to a lot in the field of mathematics, philosophy, yoga.
And instead of that, instead of that, the book says, demonize Hinduism by showing the visuals in the textbook in bad light.
Thank you for listening to me.
Namaste.
Our Veda has been telling we are living in a heliocentric era, which is not accepted in several religious books yet.
Like this, Veda has lots of knowledge in every modern science.
By 15th century, Christopher Columbus or Vasco da Gama were searching for India, not any other area.
Eventually, India got inverted in 17th century.
Invaders has practiced the evil practice such as divide and discriminate policy.
They created the caste system.
India never created a caste system.
They created a caste system such as Dalit.
We worship sage called Ved Vyas, Valmiki.
The vested interests call them as Dalit.
We don't call them as Dalit.
We worship them.
Hinduism, or Sanatana Dharma,
can proudly say that holy books never teach us anything against any God's creation.
We call all God's creation as Vasudeva Kudumbakam.
Education system has to emphasize to the student that practicing divide and discrimination is bad.
Students should be taught.
Thank you.
State board members, my name is Ted Levine and I'm president and CEO of Kids Discover.
We are a family owned and operated company and we've been producing elementary curriculum materials for over 26 years.
Kids Discover's entire editorial team has worked tirelessly in conjunction and in partnership with HMH to produce the HMH Kids Discover K-6 program that is up for adoption.
The public commentary that's been voiced today and over the last several months forces a small company like mine to look at itself in the mirror, to pay close and special attention to the words that we've selected, the images we've chosen, the art that we've created in order to promote inclusion and support communities all across the state of California.
I stand here today to say that you have been heard, that Kids Discover has heard you, and that adjustments have been made to the program within the parameters and procedures that the state affords us in order so that the program is in full compliance
the California Education Code and State Framework.
This program was created by good, hardworking, thoughtful professionals, people who show up every single day to put teachers and students first.
This is in fact our livelihood.
I would ask that the board members approve the HMH Kids Discover K-6 program based on the merit and objective quality of the program and not based on the public commentary.
Thank you.
Dear esteemed custodians of the future of the American students, I'm Harsha Shetbalkar, a resident of Folsom with kids in school.
World is already a divided place, divided over ideas and beliefs.
Equality and peace can be upheld only when we respect each other.
In this particular case, we can promote equality by showing all civilizations in the same light.
Indian civilization should not be thrashed while other civilizations are shown in spotlight.
There are plenty of good aspects in the Indian civilization which has been around for about 6,000 years.
I implore the respected board members to accept the IQC recommendations to reject hard code.
This act will influence students to respect other civilizations and all Indian students to feel proud of their legacy.
Thank you very much.
Good morning.
My name is Roy White.
I'm an Air Force veteran, founder and president of a national organization called Truth in Textbooks.
I live in Burney, Texas.
TNT conducted reviews of 25 social studies textbooks.
We have submitted a total of 21 of these reviews to you.
totaling 336 pages, identifying 1,263 errors.
The remaining reviews will be submitted in the coming weeks.
The book with the most number of errors, 139, is Discovery, Education, Medieval, and Early Modern World History, Grade 7.
Very close behind with 133 errors is the Pearson California History, Social Science, Grade 7 World History, Medieval, and Early Modern Times.
We've conducted reviews in North Carolina, Texas, and we'll be conducting reviews in Florida.
The public will be able to have access to these reports on our website at truthintextbooks.com.
We do this as a public service to the California school administrators who wish to have an independent review of books under consideration in the coming months and in years hopes that they will purchase the most accurate textbooks adopted by the State Board of Education.
I probably came further than anyone else for a one-minute speech, but thank you very much for your time.
Good morning respected members of the State Board of Education.
My name is Isha and I am an eighth grader at Winston Churchill Middle School.
A bull  a bullying report on Hindu American children.
says that one female in 10th grade noted that her classmates had frequently tried to convert her, and instructional content only created more negative impressions of Hinduism.
She said, having an incomplete, brief, and completely generalized unit, which only focused on negative aspects of Hinduism, does not help to dispel the persistent stereotypes.
I've seen too many friends give up on their faith and hide the Hindu identity to avoid being socially isolated.
As a student in this age, I've also seen this happen to many of my friends.
The guidelines for instructional material clearly states that their purpose is to enable all students to become aware and accepting of religious diversity while being allowed to remain secure in any religious beliefs they may already have.
Then why are Hindu children not allowed to feel safe in their religious beliefs?
Thank you for your time.
Good morning, board.
My name is Dr. Mari Zwick-Metrehi, and I'm here with the South Asian Histories for All Coalition.
I'm one of the researchers behind the new report that we've submitted to you called Caste Survey of the United States, which shares the results of one of the first survey that documents quantitatively and qualitatively that caste discrimination very much exists in the United States.
It directly contradicts false statements in textbooks like National Geographic, Teachers Curriculum, Pearsons, McGraw-Hill, that say that many Hindus, both in South Asia and the United States, don't identify with a caste.
That makes it seem like caste doesn't exist, but our report has found that one in four Dalits in the United States experience physical assaults as a result of their caste.
Two in three have faced discrimination in workplaces as a result of their caste in the United States.
And one in three have reported discrimination in schools on the basis of their caste in the United States.
And in fact, we found that caste discrimination touches every aspect of our caste-oppressed immigrant lives, from relationships to food to every institution we speak of.
Thank you.
Namaste.
My name is Satsuka Yayavanam.
I am a sixth grader from First Avenue Middle School in Southern California.
I was appalled to hear Hindu students being bullied by other students in their class and also teachers making sarcastic comments on Hinduism.
We will be learning about ancient India and Hinduism in a month or two.
Now I'm starting to get worried to learn about Hinduism at school and no child should be scared to learn about their own religion.
I am here to express my concern in wrongly portraying Hinduism in the California textbooks.
I believe that you will take the right decision by dropping all the drafts that demonize Hinduism.
This will set the right direction for children for the next 10 years and will be a remarkable step in teaching the right aspect about Hindu religion.
This would be a great step in stopping bullying of Hindu children in schools.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Rao Panaganti.
I represent Vasavi Seva Foundation from Bay Area, which has 2,000 plus families.
My children have grown up.
Still, I came from San Jose to request you to remove the offensive material against Hinduism from California textbooks.
Thank you for giving me this opportunity to speak here.
Thank you.
Dear members of the State Board of Education, I'm coming from the Bay Area and the mother of young children, and I stand in front of you to speak against the demonization of Hindus and Indians.
I stand here as a Hindu, an Indian, as an Asian, with the support of other Asians and Pacific Islanders.
I stand here to support Jeffrey Long and other academics who are seeking historical accuracy.
We Hindus of diverse backgrounds and of all castes, vocations, communities, languages, and regions are here to demand that hatred against Hindus to be stopped.
I comment IQC for rejecting the two Hindu phobic books that have the images that clearly depict Hinduism and India as a filthy backward culture.
However, I think that this is not enough and much more needs to be done.
I strongly urge SBE to say no to hatred against Hindus in all forms.
Thank you.
Hi, good afternoon, and dear members of State Board of Education.
My name is Satish.
I live in Milpitas, and I have two kids.
Both go to elementary school in Milpitas.
And I'm here to oppose Hinduphobia and Hatred Against My Heritage.
I fully support IQC's decision to reject McCraw-Hill's K-6 and McCraw-Hill's 6-8 programs.
These programs are blatantly racist and homophobic.
There are several blatantly racist depictions and such portrayal.
It shows Indian labourers working next to the monkey and thereby equating Indian labourers with the monkeys.
And IQC has shown the courage to reject and prejudice by rejecting too.
Hindu phobic books, but that is not enough.
I support the recommendation of Academic Coalition by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other top academics requesting you to all to consider their recommendations and take it forward.
Okay.
Thank you.
Hi, respected members.
I'm Saurabh Sameya.
I came here from Milpitas to put the concerns against the California textbooks has disturbing images of Indian and Hinduism and malign the image of Hindu, which is not the actual Hinduism is.
So I request the suggestions made by IQC to remove the draft of HMH from 6 to 8.
and not showing only the negative aspect of Hinduism in the textbooks.
This gives a very wrong impression to the kids.
Thank you very much.
Respected SB members, my name is Satish Mahajan, living in San Jose.
I'm a concerned parent of 10-year-old son Abhi, who is fifth grader.
Hinduism, since Vedic time, has evolved with the contributions from diverse communities within.
I feel proud that the communities like the one I belong to have greatly contributed to Hinduism.
Male and female sages and saints from all these diverse communities help Hinduism grow, rejuvenate, and reform.
they have been role models for Hindus all across social backgrounds.
These are the kind of people that come to my mind when I think of Hinduism and its history.
A group of academicians calling themselves South Asia Faculty Group, South Asian Histories for All, do not think so.
They believe that saints and sages hailing from all these peasant communities, many times categorized as even outside of the Varna system, should be removed from the curriculum.
It is like denying the contribution of masses as it does not fit in their theory of Hinduism.
More importantly, let me ask a question.
Who are these people from these organizations?
Since 2014, I'm following the textbook issue, visiting social gatherings in Bay Area and many other places.
I never interacted with these people from this organization.
I request you to deny these people and their claims entirely.
Thank you.
Hello, good afternoon, board members.
My name is Sanjeev Bhattavadekar from Pleasanton, California.
My daughter goes to Pleasanton School District in fourth grade.
I stand here to oppose hatred against Hindus and Indians.
In the current textbook, sixth grade HMS calls Vedas, the sacred Hindu scriptures, a collection of spells and charms.
Spells and charms.
No other sacred book is mentioned in such denigrating terms.
This is inaccurate, biased, and discriminatory.
The California textbook standards is to project the cultural diversity of society, instill in each child a sense of pride in his or her heritage, develop a feeling of self-worth,
and to enable all students to become aware and accepting of religious diversity while being allowed to remain secure in any religious belief they may already have.
However, the current textbook format doesn't allow.
They have overlooked even new format also.
So, I support the letter.
I fully support the decision by KC to reject HMH.
Thank you.
Respected members of State Board of Education, I'm Hindvi, sixth grader from Fremont, and I am highly disappointed at the way Hinduism and India are portrayed in the HMH, K-6, and other drafts.
There are adverse reflections and historical inaccuracies.
Apart from that, meaningful spiritual philosophies, such as belief in universal plurality, are completely ignored.
Hinduism and India are represented in a demeaning way, which gives a wrong perception of me and my fellow Hindu friends.
This is very insulting and needs to be corrected right away.
We often end up having workshops and debates at class on falsified content such as caste system.
This can encourage bullying and disrespecting Hinduism in India.
I want rights of my fellow students and myself to be protected.
I request the board to seriously consider the falsehood in drafts, reject them, and help bring the facts and correct content.
I support IQC's rejection of hardcourt programs.
Thank you.
respected members of SD.
Myself, Devapriya.
I'm from Kupatuna, a concerned parent of a four-year-old son who is going to preschool now, and he'll be going to public school from the next year.
So I'm here to stand against the, you know, hatred against the Hinduism, all the Indian civilization, which is happening in the California textbooks.
And I'm really worried to see that what will happen to my son when he's going to school from next year and he'll be bullied by his fellow friends and how he'll come back.
But today I see a difference when he goes to school, happily he's coming back, you know, with his friends, playing.
But I don't know what will happen tomorrow when he's going to read his books and then, you know, being bullied by his friends.
Having that said, I have been following up with these hearings for quite a long time.
And I was part of the hearing from the IQC team last time.
And I was really happy in their support towards rejecting a couple of publishers' content in the books.
And I am urging you today to reject all the other publishers who are putting the wrong contents and putting the Hindu civilization in a bad way.
So thank you for the time and listening to me.
Respected members of the State Board of Education, I am Sharanya Jhavi, a sixth grader from the Pleasanton Unified School District.
I noticed that India and Hinduism are portrayed incorrectly in my textbook, and I believe this needs to be corrected immediately.
It is insulting.
A bullying report on Hindu-American children says that a student who was bullied said that, I was at lunch and it was after we learned about Hinduism they started saying my religion is a devil's religion and that I'll go to hell.
This clearly points to the problems with textbooks.
I stand here in solidarity with all Hindu-American children who have been bullied because of hatred created by bad textbooks.
Why are Hindu children not allowed to feel safe in their religious beliefs?
I urge the board to reject all material that has hatred against Hindus and every other community.
Thank you.
Namaste, member of state board of education.
I thank and fully support the decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMH.
Even after the huge number of revisions and rewrites submitted this collectively doesn't address all the problems.
Every one out of three Hindu American children has reported being bullied based on their religious belief and practices.
Many children have said that bullying occurred after the section on Hinduism and ancient Indian
were taught in schools.
Hence, it is extremely important that the hatred and the bias in the textbooks be addressed immediately.
I am Sethanshu Swaprasad Samal from Hayward, working as a software professional in Silicon Valley.
I am a proud Hindu and also father of a two-year-old son.
who will be exposed to the negative effects of the inaccurate information about Indian civilizations in all those textbooks in few years.
Hence, I ask you to reject HMS2 programs as recommended by IQC.
Thank you all.
Respected members of SBE, I'm Sunil Rath from Sunnyvale.
I'm standing with the Hindu students who are bullied by their fellow classmates.
I stand here to oppose the hatred against Hindus and Indians.
I support IQC's decision to reject HMH K-6 and HMH 6-8 programs.
In many places, HMH has not even submitted what those replacements would be.
How could a draft textbook be adopted when it is not even complete?
Hence, I ask you to reject HMS-II programs as recommended by IQC.
I support the recommendations of Academic Coalition by Professor Geoffrey Long and 30th Order Academies.
Please take all their recommendations.
Thank you.
To the respected members of the state's board of education.
My name is Shreya Cola.
I attend Warm Springs Elementary School and I'm in 6th grade.
A report was filed for bullying a Hindu American student.
The student says and I quote I was at lunch and it was after we learned about Hinduism.
They started saying my religion is a devil's religion and that I'll go to hell.
This clearly points to the problems with our textbooks.
I stand here in solidarity.
with all the Hindu American children who have been bullied because of hatred created by bad textbooks.
Why are Hindu children not allowed to feel safe in their religious beliefs?
I strongly urge the board to reject all material that has hatred against the Hindus and every other community.
Thank you.
Respected board members, I am Shruti Pathak, and I'm a ninth grader at EVHS High School, Evergreen Valley High School.
I would like to start by saying I support the decision to reject the books from HMH, which display an intentionally negative portrayal of Hinduism.
However, the effort is still not over.
Drafts from National Geographic, as well as McGraw-Hill, still have blatantly racist content that promote Hinduphobia.
If accepted, these books will continue to initiate bullying and create tension in schools for Hindu children.
A report from the Hindu American Foundation states that one of three Hindu American children have complained of bullying based on their culture and beliefs.
That is not a statistic to be proud of.
I stand here in support with my fellow Hindu American children who stand victim to such hateful content.
Thank you.
Hi, I'm Lakshmi Nagarajan, member of Ambedkar Kin Study Circle, here today representing the South Asian history for all.
Sir, madam, I see the Cupertino kids here saying that they are bullied.
90% of Cupertino population is Asian.
Are we saying we are bullying ourselves?
I don't get it.
And blacks were treated like slaves, but that is not removed from the history.
So my point is the students have
need to learn, study, fact as fact, reality as reality.
The future generation needs more courage to annihilate the caste.
The first and foremost step to annihilate the caste is to accept its existence.
IQC framework reads that the caste system provides social stability and gave the identity to each community.
Stacks contrast to this.
Crimes committed against Dalits by non-Dalits is every 16 minutes.
90 crimes a day, every day.
Four Dalit women are raped by non-Dalits.
And every week, 13 Dalits are murdered and six Dalits are kidnapped.
And are we still saying that it's going to give the stability?
Good afternoon, respected members.
I'm Karthikeyan Shanmugha, member of Ambedkar King Study Circle, California, here today representing South Asian history for all.
Sassan, madam, my request today is to expand a little bit of the Gupta dynasty, which covers in the grade seven.
So Gupta dynasty covers between the 6th and 3rd and 6th century AD, which is partial.
It stops with saying that the Gupta period is a golden period.
Request you to elaborate how the caste system become irreparably rigid during the Gupta dynasty by stopping sub-caste or jati mobility.
It is during the Gupta period, Brahmins firmly established their social status by monopolizing education, art and culture.
Sati.
Widows were forced to burn themselves on the funeral pyre of their husbands as a practice was introduced in the very dynasty.
According to Dr. B R Ambedkar, it is during this very period, untouchability was introduced by making cow killing as a sin and beef-eating as an offense.
As secular Indian historians put that during the rule of Gupta, Indian society becomes Aryan patriarchal society.
without understanding how the.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone.
respected members of SBE.
I'm Bhaskar Vempati, father of an eight-year-old.
I support the recommendations by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other academicians.
I commend and fully support the decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMH.
These programs are blatantly racist, Hinduphobic, homophobic, and worse in quality.
There are numerous violations of Category 1 of adoption guidelines.
especially Category 1.10, which prohibits the adverse reflection based on religion and ethnicity.
They also violate the California law, which prohibits religious discrimination.
For example, it has caricatures of Hindu deities.
HMH 628 calls Vedas, the sacred Hindu text, as a collection of spells and charms.
My ask is to reject the racism publishers like McGraw-Hill, HMH, and Discovery.
Thank you for listening, and thank you once again.
Namaste, respected members of State Board of Education.
My name is Shwani Kollat and Arrington High School and I'm studying in 10th grade.
I stand here to oppose hatred against Hindus and Indians.
A 11th grader from Missouri City,
Texas was told by her classmates that she should convert to Christianity to become more civilized.
This, I believe, is because Hindus are primitive, dirty, and bad.
Do we not see the pictures in the textbooks that do that?
I'm here to support Jeffrey Long and 38 other academicians who are seeking historical accuracy.
I request that recommendations by Jeffrey Long and the academic group be accepted to address all the problems.
Thank you.
Good afternoon members of the SPE.
Thank you for providing this forum and listening carefully to our grievances.
I'm a parent of a fifth grader.
I'm afraid that next year in middle school he may experience shame and confusion due to religious history curriculum as depicted in the disputed texts.
The content in HMH texts are especially outrageous.
These being textbooks and not opinion columns, I insist that they be unbiased and accurate.
The beauty of Hindu religion lies in the fact that there are numerous interweaving bays that it provides to reach God and self-realization.
But instead of providing these principles, I found in the text what it had was misrepresentation, distortion, and critical positive omissions.
Pictures are worth a thousand words, and most of the pictures in these texts, especially the HMH text, are really outrageous.
They are derogatory, irrelevant, biased, primitive, and condescending.
I can keep going on.
These absolutely need to be replaced with appropriate ones which are more respectful.
Hinduism is an ancient religion, but is very current and very relevant religion in modern times, and should be presented with the same reverence as other modern religions.
Hence, I support the IQC decision to reject the curriculum and also support the academics strive for accuracy.
Thank you very much.
Namaste.
Jai Shri Ram.
My name is Nitin Barve.
I'm a resident of Cupertino.
I have a sixth grader boy.
And I started noticing some differences in him when he comes back home.
He has been a very proud practitioner Hindu.
And recently, I've started seeing some elements of doubt on his face.
And I cannot accept that.
These are formative years.
We all know that society around us is very divisive, full of hatred and bigotry.
And the last thing we want to do is add to that.
The middle school years are very formative.
These are the years which shape the rest of your life.
And it's your responsibility to make sure that the text that you present to them is adequate, correct, and complete.
And the last thing you want to do is present them with any confusing, inadequate, incorrect material.
So I request you to, in fact, I sincerely hope and demand that you think about it very responsibly and accept all the recommendations made by Professor Long.
Thank you.
Respected board members of education, I'm Rashmita Halkar.
I'm mother of a fourth grader from Fremont Unified School District.
I'm here to express my full support to IQC's decision to reject HMH text for K to K6 and 6 to 8.
And I support the recommendations of top experts and Professor Jeffrey Long.
If a kid gets bullied and feels embarrassed because of his or her ethnicity or cultural background, as a parent, it concerns me.
Specifically, if a kid is learning this from textbook and teachers.
This is a negative impact of classroom education.
Hindu culture has a great contribution to the mankind, which he can or she can discuss with his classmates and teachers.
For example, invention of zero yoga and meditation.
Just think about the positive impact that he will have.
by learning yoga and meditation.
Specifically, it is important in today's stressful life.
So I am, I fully support the IQC's decision and reject HMIT textbook.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Good morning, respected board members.
My name is Ashok Chigulapalli.
I come from Fremont, Fremont School District.
I have two daughters.
One has completed college, the other one is a high school senior here.
I'm happy to see that IQCA has rejected the two books from HMH, the intentionally negative
and the incoherent portrayal of Hinduism by HMH does not deserve a place in our school.
Given the current as well as proposed draft contents of some of the publishers, it is no surprise to me that one in eight Hindu-American
Respondents of a bullying survey said that their teachers made sarcastic remarks about Hinduism in front of the entire class.
11th grade from Missouri City, Texas was told by her classmates that she should convert to Christianity to become more.
Thank you.
Please continue.
Respected members of State Board of Education, I am Balaji Kesarla from Dublin, California.
I stand here to oppose hatred against Hindus and Indians.
Imagine you are an Indian parent eagerly waiting for your child to come home from middle school.
When they come home,
Your child tells you, mom or dad, read this book and you read it and you come across a page about India.
You get excited to see a page in a published textbook about your own culture.
But as you read it, your excitement vanishes because the page is offensive, not exciting.
That is why I'm here.
A lot of Indian parents experience this after their children tell them what they study in social studies.
I don't think any would want their
anyone would want their culture to be offended in a published textbook.
This is having adverse effects as it is spreading hatred among kids and Indian kids are being bullied due to this.
We want all children to be respectful of each other and not to bully or hate each other.
I'm really hoping that the board members are going to reject HMH2 programs as recommended by IQSU.
Thank you and have a wonderful day.
Respected members of State Board of Education, I'm Prashanth Andreddy, father of two kids.
My son, the other one, goes to the Russell Ranch Elementary School in Folsom.
I stand here to oppose hatred against Hindus and Indians.
I fully support the decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMH.
NF has already said about, you know, the day long, you know, my friends have been talking about the vilification of the Indian culture and Hindus and all that.
So I'm not going to repeat all that stuff.
Keeping this inaccuracies aside, please think about the negative impact it has on the young impressionable minds.
How it will impact their self-esteem, especially the Indian-American kids.
One in every three Indian-American kids are subjected to bullying.
These publications only make matters worse.
Eye for an eye makes the whole world blind.
Hence, I request you to reject HMS2 programs as recommended by IQC.
Thanks for giving me a chance to speak.
Thank you.
Respected panel members, thanks for giving me this opportunity.
I'm Krishna Uttakuru.
I'm a member of Livermore Hindu Community Center and I'm also a member of Virat Hindustan Association.
I want to tell you all a small story.
Poor little Johnny had a cancerous tumor in the stomach and his parents took him to a dentist and poor little Johnny died because of wrong medicine and wrong diagnosis.
The reason why I'm telling you this story is what kind of credentials does the authors of this textbook have to write about Hinduism?
Do they understand Sanskrit?
Did they read any Hindu literature to understand?
And one of the speakers was talking about Dalits getting atrocized and discriminated in Hindu culture.
But the authors of popular textbooks like Vedas, like Vedavyasa is a Dalit and Valmiki is a Dalit.
They are not Brahmins.
And all the demons like Ravana, Narakasura were Brahmins.
So dharma or the righteousness was always given place in Hinduism and not the caste.
So I request you to reject all the textbook content which is having anti-Hindu rhetoric and which is causing all the kids in the California schools getting bullied.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board.
My name is Umashankar.
I'm a ninth grader.
My daughter is a ninth grader at Livermore Unified School District, and I'm also representing Hindu community and cultural center in Livermore.
I also represent Vasavi Seva Foundation, which has about 2,000 plus families in Bay Area.
I also represent an Indian connecting group at a major tech firm in Bay Area.
I've taken off today to come to express my concerns on the syllabus that HMH K-6 and HMH 6-8 as published in the textbooks of 6th grade social studies.
The IQC's rejection of it is the right way to go and I'm here to fully support it.
The bullying report from the Hindu American Foundation shows what kids go through.
I quote the experience of one of the students in a school saying that I was at lunch and it was after we learned about Hinduism in the textbook, they started saying my religion is a devil's religion and that I'll go to hell.
That was really sickening to hear and it is not good.
I fully support the recommendations of Professor Long and other academicians to fix this problem.
Thank you.
Namaste everyone.
My name is Naveen.
I fully support the letter by Mr. Professor Jeffrey Long, 438 Academics and IRQ's decision to reject HMH books.
Please let Hindu people, kids live with pride and dignity.
Please do not encourage and spread the racist, biased values and hate in this society.
There are millions of good things
to share why few textbooks only printing the negative things against the Hinduism.
Please don't let my kid face horrific terrible bullying in the school because he is a Hindu, Indian or Asian kid.
Thank you so much.
Good afternoon, respected members of the State Board of Education.
I am Raj Nagaraj from San Ramon, California, and a parent of two boys in high school and elementary school.
I stand here to oppose hatred against Hindus and Indians.
I also support the IQC's decision in rejecting HMH books for K-6 and 6-8.
Further, I support the recommendations made by Professor Jefferson Long and 38 other academics.
I appealed the chair of the SP to accept their recommendations.
I would like to bring to your notice that one in eight respondents of a bullying survey on the Hindu American children said that his teachers made sarcastic remarks about Hinduism in front of the entire class.
I don't tell anybody else I was a Hindu, so I don't experience problems so much.
I feel awkward sometimes.
These were the words by the student.
Others also reported deep emotional scars from bullying incidents.
I stand with you, these children, who are facing bullying and hatred, and demand that hatred against Hinduism must be immediately stopped.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon, Namaste, and board members.
My name is Govind Ranganathan.
Two of my kids are in the middle school in the present and unified school district.
And my wife and I were shocked when we saw the books in what they depicted on Hinduism, the stereotyping, and that resulted in shaming and bullying of my kids.
And they felt ashamed to be Hindu, which is kind of not good.
So a religion that has given ahimsa, non-violence, that has given karma, that has given yoga, and
And if you're in a country of land, liberty, and equality, where you're being shamed because you're a one religion, which is unacceptable, which should not be.
All of us should rise up and say it is unacceptable.
So I demand that please implement the recommendations by Professor Jeffrey Long and 30 other talk academics.
And I appreciate your patience and listening.
And thanks for your help in this just cause.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, this is Lakshman.
So I'm a father of a fifth grader.
When I saw this new draft from the HMH book, I was really shocked.
The front page says about unicorn.
I don't see this unicorn has any place in Indian history or mythology.
all the pages like the pictures for Hindu religion point of view they have the pictures like laborers working with monkeys there are some so they are not teaching any good thing what Hinduism gave so what I want be teach the fact but be fair with all the religions like Hinduism, Sikhism or Buddhism so I want these kids when they learn from the book they respect each other
It's not like they are getting bullied because Hinduism is portrayed in a negative way.
So, I fully support IQC recommendation and reject HMH books.
Thank you.
I'm Dandapani from Ambedkar King Study Circle, California.
I'm here today representing a broader coalition, South Asian Histories for All.
Sirs and Madam, on October 28, 2017 in Uttar Pradesh, India, an eight-month-old pregnant woman was attacked brutally and murdered by the upper caste Hindus for the reason that she touched their trash can.
The poor victim belonged to an oppressed caste who were forced to do manual scavenging for generations.
As per Dr. Ambedkar, caste is a state of mind, it's a disease of mind.
The teachings of the Hindu religion are the root cause of this disease.
The future generation should learn about origin of caste and it shouldn't be delinked from Hinduism.
If we don't call this out and accept its existence and cruelty of the caste system, it's going to stay longer.
So please keep the caste oppression and send the books back to IQC and kindly enforce the framework, fix the mistakes.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Shanti Kadiresan, member of Ambedkar Study Circle, here today representing Border Coalition of South Asian Histories for All Coalition.
I'm living in this country for 20 years.
And in these 20 years, majority of the people, whomever I met, asked my caste directly or indirectly.
Because unlike other Indian states, people from Tamil Nadu don't carry the caste or family name as their surname.
I'm pretty sure it's a case of my friends here from both sides.
So please modify the sentence in the framework that today many Hindus in India and in U.S.
do not identify themselves as belonging to caste.
Today majority of the Hindus in India and in U.S.
identify themselves as belonging to a caste with a very few exception.
So I humbly request you guys to delay the vote and fix the mistake.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Nachia P. Kumar.
I am from the same state that the person who just spoke before me.
I have a son who's a sixth grader, goes to Southern California school here.
I'm also an educator and a yoga instructor.
I've been practicing yoga for generations.
I'm not from one of those higher castes.
We are not oppressed with any of the things that's mentioned in there.
So when I see these books stereotyping, has stereotyped narratives, it just hardens my mind.
It's not the truth.
So I request the board to reject HMH and McGraw-Hill drafts for violating the California framework.
Another violation is it is decoupling practices such as meditation from Hinduism.
The law of this land prohibits any stereotypes and patronizing of minority groups.
I believe this board has the wisdom to do what the law requires and do the right thing to protect the young American Hindu children.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, dear members of SBE.
My name is Madhu Gururajachar, father of two children who attend California schools.
National Geographic's materials are severely outdated.
They completely disregard the new social, the history social framework adopted by the State Board in 2016 and they leave out 20 key topics in the framework.
Examples of such omissions include the complete failure to mention positive contributions of Hinduism like the Bhagavad Gita, contributions
by Hindus to mathematics, medicine, etc.
National Geographic also tries to create a false equivalence of Hinduism with caste, which in turn is erroneously portrayed as the primary defining characteristic of the Hindu practice.
I respectfully submit that the National Geographic book should adopt all the recommendations or else it should be rejected.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Anupama Rao, and I'm a mother of two children studying in Santa Clara.
My son went through the upsetting experience of being taught highly Hinduphobic content when he was in his sixth grade.
And it was very difficult for me as a mother who identifies with my religion and my identity to be able to communicate and convey to him that what he was learning in his textbooks was completely inaccurate.
It is really important for textbooks, which serve as an irreplaceably critical role in children's learning, to stay away from inaccuracies of this nature.
So we are, through the education medium, rooting out any implicit and explicit biases that our children grow up with as they grow up in this community.
I really request all of you that you support the IQC recommendation to reject the HMH textbooks and urge them to adopt all of the recommendations of academic coalition by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other top academics.
Thank you.
Hi, sorry you all are eating through this thing.
My name is Dolly.
I'm a Dalit American and I'm also a physician assistant and I'm with South Asian Histories for All.
I submitted the legal notice to the board so that we could protect the rights of the caste oppressed and enforce the frameworks and protect the facts.
I know a lot of the textbooks are saying that caste has ended, but the facts are that every day in India, three Dalits are murdered, two are raped, and three houses are burnt.
And this morning, if we want to talk about caste oppression, the Hindu fundamentalists here called us casteist slurs outside, had a self-appointed usher who physically threatened us, multiple ushers physically threatened us.
They called the state police and they had us kicked out of the building.
I then provided medical care to a Dalit sister who had her first episode of epilepsy due to the harassment that she faced here this morning.
She just testified here earlier.
All of this to try and prevent us from testifying to the truth of the caste system.
All of this to prevent us from testifying to the truth of the caste system that exists here and in India.
Protect the frameworks and stop the system of ultimate facts.
Don't let mob rule survive.
Hi, my name is Kedar Reddy.
I'm with the South Asian Histories for All Coalition.
I'm a Hindu Californian, born into an upper caste family, and I believe that our textbooks shouldn't whitewash caste oppression.
Its historical origins in Hinduism, the people it's impacted, it continues to impact, and the brave people who fight back.
Uppercast Hindus keep complaining that reading about caste oppression makes them feel bad.
You know what makes me feel bad?
Caste denial.
That's like families, white families saying, don't teach about slavery.
It makes us feel bad.
That's like straight people saying, don't teach about homophobia.
I'm saying this as a Hindu.
Say no to textbooks that downplay casteism.
There's no place for whitewashing or discrimination in California and not in our textbooks.
Protect all Californians and not just complaining upper-caste Hindus.
Enforce the frameworks.
Fix the mistakes.
Thank you so much.
Hello, respected members of the State Board of Education.
My name is Shravan Yampati.
I made myself available today to voice my opinion on the denigration and representation of Hinduism in ancient India in school textbooks.
Hinduism actually has a rich history of more than 5,000 years.
Hinduism gave the world of yoga, Vedas, Ayurveda and many more things.
I am shocked and deeply upset on how HMH and McGraw Hill programs stereotype and demonize Hindus and Hinduism.
Their programs are outrightly biased, prejudiced, filled with hate against Hinduism.
We want children of this great nation to learn facts, truth,
mutual respect across among different religions and cultures.
Stop demonizing Hinduism.
Stop hatred against Hinduism.
I fully support and stand with IQC's decision to reject the hateful books of HMH.
I also support the recommendations by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other academicians.
Please ask questions.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, dear members of the State Board of Education.
My name is Rahul.
I'm from Sunnyvale.
I'm a proud parent of two children studying in the Cupertino School District.
I'm here to thank and fully support IQC's decision to reject two programs from HMH, as I think core values of Hinduism are not represented correctly in those programs.
I also support recommendations from Academic Coalition
led by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other members.
I request you to consider that young minds are like a clean slate, and we need to write the correct and bright side of any culture on it.
Thank you.
Hello to the members of SV.
I'm Yogesh Bramey from San Ramon.
I support the recommendations by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other academicians.
Please consider them in full.
I thank and fully support IQC for showing the courage to reject textbooks with hatred and prejudice towards Hindu religion.
However,
It shocked me to the core when I saw the stereotypical deception of Hinduism and ancient India is still present in the certain textbook drafts.
Even their last month's submissions are not much useful.
In spite of the presence of so many strong laws against racism, it pains my heart to see such bias and negative tone of narration in those textbook drafts.
Deliberately ignoring the achievement of Indians and Hindus, it is showcased as if we have nothing to present to the world.
As custodians of the fairness to the children, I urge the panel to reject these textbooks.
Thank you.
respected members of SBE.
I'm Srinivas Badami from Dublin, California.
I'm father of two.
I missed my workday to make myself heard here because this information is very critical.
My elder daughter is currently in sixth grade.
She's reading the HMH book, and she has been questioning quite much content, even in the current textbook too.
I hope the new books will have the correct information, and my younger daughter hopefully will get to read the correct history of ancient India.
more disturbingly last year during framework process this group engaged in hindu phobic attacks on hindu american groups parents and even children they also tried to minimize and ridicule the very real experience of hindu american students who have been bullied in the classroom because of their religious identity
This was apparent during the framework hearings last year when constituent members of SHFA belittled Hindu-American children in their testimony and made thumbs-down motions in the air while young Hindu-American students relayed their experiences of alienation and bullying to the members of IQC and SBE.
Time.
Good afternoon, members.
Thank you for giving me this opportunity.
I'm a physician and cardiologist in the community for several years.
And I came out to this meeting and come out as a Dalit at 74 years of age.
And the question is, does the caste system exist in the U.S.?
I think the caste system exists in its full glory with the demonic oppression and suppressions.
The reason I did not come out as a Dalit is because to escape this oppression and suppression.
So believe it or not, it exists in its full glory in the U.S.
And the reason I did not come out earlier is because I don't want my children to suffer from the same oppression and suppression which I went through in India as well as in this country.
And because of all these reasons, I will request this board not to approve the textbook recommendation at this time.
And I want the true facts to be established and change it to the actual facts rather than imaginary facts.
And thank you for this time.
Thank you, Jim.
Namaste to all board members.
I really appreciate the efforts of the IQC in identifying the inaccurate information.
I think in this age of information, it is very important to get that we provide the right, accurate, appropriate information to our children and our educational institutions.
So it is not fair to demonize one particular culture which has been teaching, encouraging the love, peaceful harmony, not only among the human beings, but all the creatures on this planet.
So I request you to consider these points and thank you.
Namaste.
respected members of the State Board of Education, and my brothers and sisters.
I am Makhan Keshav Goyal.
I am from Milpitas City.
My granddaughter is studying in John Shenote Elementary School, Milpitas.
On the outset, I command the decision of IQC for rejecting Harcourt K-6 and 6-8 textbooks, which had the worst contents for our future generation.
I recommend that you take a serious look at the other publishers who are not from Harcourt, like McGraw Hill and National Geography, and reject them as well as they are clearly missing the marks of following the framework.
Our kids and the world at large need to learn to coexist and respect all as they are rather than pass judgment over one another causing stereotyping and bullying.
Even after having strict law, I find it appealing that the named publishers push hate speech and derogatory contact only for Hinduism.
Respected board members, I am Pranshu Wagh and I go to Horner Junior High.
I am here to stand today against bullying of Hindu teens.
The negative portrayal of Hinduism in the textbook causes one in three Hindu teens to be bullied.
As a teenager, students like me try to find our identities.
If students are being bullied for expressing their religion, they grow up feeling embarrassed about their belief and identity.
We want to build a nation with confident citizens rather than ones with low self-esteem.
So please, help teenagers like me by rejecting HMH's two programs as recommended by the IQC.
respected members of state board education.
I'm Venkat from Foster City.
At a time of great division in our country and around the world, the importance of next generation is brought up to respecting each other's religion and maintaining a dignity is very critical.
The sort of hatred is being pushed by fringe elements.
Even in the textbook is clearly a hate speech, which has no place
either in the textbook or anywhere in the civil world.
It is not just against California Department of Education guidelines, but also against the spirit of our Constitution and against the spirit of education.
The revisions that they are suggesting that have no academic backing and will lead to very serious social content violation.
I stand here to support Jeffrey Long and 38 other academicians who are seeking historical accuracy.
I request that recommendations by Jeffrey Long and the academic group be accepted to address all the problems in the books.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I'm with the South Asian Histories for All.
And the question before us is whether we value justice and how much we value justice.
And what are we going to do about it?
The caste apartheid that has brutalized the entire Dalit population
for over 2600 years.
Their lived reality cannot be erased.
Last week, a young lady was sitting outside of a temple with her infant child and she was being pushed aside and she was bludgeoned to death.
for making, bludgeoned to death with her infant child for making the area impure by the priest.
Another young man dared to have a mustache and he was killed for simply that he had the audacity to have a mustache.
Should we acknowledge the lived realities of the people or should we succumb to mob rule?
This is the question for us.
Good afternoon, respected members of State Board of Education.
My name is Rahul Rajiv, and I'm a senior at Mountain House High School.
Although it has been about six years since my world history experience, there are memories that still come to mind.
I remember flipping over the last page of the chapter on ancient India and wondering, where was the information about yoga, Ayurvedic medicine, or all the scientific discoveries I heard about growing up?
Instead, these were replaced by topics such as the caste system, which I remember reading about three whole pages about.
This, along with other topics that have been emphasized in the textbooks, have led to several bullying incidents, one of which was a 12th grader being told to convert to Christianity in order to be more civilized.
Having an incomplete, brief, and generalized unit, which only focuses on the negative aspects of Hinduism, does not help to dispel the persistent stereotypes.
I have seen too many friends give up on their faith and hide their Hindu identity to avoid being socially isolated.
As a senior in high school, I wish the best for generations of Hindus to come.
Hello.
Namaste to all.
Respected members of the State Board of Education, I am Lalit Bansal, a grandfather from Pasadena, California.
I find it very disturbing to see that today so much hatred against Hindus is being spread by some fringe
Hindu phobia groups, like the South Asian historians for all.
One of their leaders had put up a post on social media recently which refers to Hindu being blind followers of monkey or a half elephant thing, a reference to Hindu gods.
They even ran a campaign to raise the statue of Indian civil rights leader Gandhi at different places, including Vernon Davis.
They are even trying to erase Gandhi from the textbook, probably because he was a Hindu.
It is a well-known fact that many prominent civil rights leaders like Martin Luther King Jr.
were inspired by Gandhi, and such a request to remove him from the textbook shows a strong bias against Hindus.
I earnestly require you to reject such hatred.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Sudeep Sabnis.
I'm a resident of Campbell, San Jose with Campbell Union as our school district.
I wish to state that inclusion of text like the Bhagavad Gita by translators outside the tradition as done with McGraw-Hill and Discovery is an adverse reflection of Hinduism.
McGraw-Hill uses a translation by Edwin Arnold, page 280 of 6th grade text.
He was a poet and a journalist, clearly not qualified for the task at hand.
The excerpt should be replaced by one from Bhagavad Gita as it is by His Divine Grace A.C.
Bhaktivedanta Swami Prabhupada,
which is the most widely published Bhagavad Gita in the world and has been translated into 50 plus languages used in universities like University of Chicago, Berkeley, Georgetown, et cetera.
I endorse the recommendations by Professor Long and Hindupedia.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
My name is Dr. Gurbaksh Singh Baga.
I'm here with the South Asian Histories for All.
Just let me tell you, mob rules cannot erase the facts.
Every single one of the textbooks hides caste oppression.
There is not only one caste.
There are 6,743 castes.
Please Google it and find out.
Here is an example.
Discovery Education textbook says that Dalits were outcast because, and I quote, their jobs usually involved activities
that were believed to be impure and unclean.
This sentence is a lie.
It is an alternative fact.
Dalits were not discriminated against because of their occupation, but vice versa.
Unclean occupation, like cleaning human waste by hand, were forced on them by discrimination and social control by Hindu Tawa, by Brahmanism.
We ask that any material that says Dalit were mistreated because of their occupation.
And thank you very much.
Hello and good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Anand Raite and I'm father of two daughters who are currently in Arvind Unified School District.
I want my daughters to be proud of their origins and roots and the school board here can help them by including factual information, focusing on the positive aspects of Hindu religion, thereby protecting them from the bullying as well.
I'm here to appeal you respectfully to consider the opinions of scholars like Professor Jeffrey Lang and others.
I am here to support and appreciate ICQ decision to reject HMH 6 and 8.
I earnestly request you to give due emphasis to one of the oldest civilization from Mohenjo-darota and Harappa and its currently evolving and contemporary nature.
and also the currently involving inclusive philosophy.
My fellow Hindus have presented here a few statistics here, but they are really focusing on a few negative aspects.
Are these really representative and are these really the ground level experiences of everyday people?
And the answer is definitely no.
I hope the school board will see through all this and reject this distorted picture.
Most important, help my daughters and thousands like them to have a respectful life with due pride.
Thank you.
Dear members of State Board of Education, thanks for a chance to speak today.
I am Mangesh Phadke, parent of two children studying in 6th and the 10th grade in Cupertino School District.
I'm here to express my absolute shock and outrage about the content being taught to my kids about one of the oldest and greatest civilization, as well as religion of the world, that is India and Hindu religion correspondingly.
In this context, I support the recommendations by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other accommodations in this matter.
I stand here to oppose hatred against Hindus and Indians.
Hindu religion was presented to USA and rest of the world by a Hindu monk, namely Swami Vivekananda, at the Parliament of World's Religion on 11th September, 1893 in Chicago.
It was held by the entire world, including USA, as a religion of peace and brotherhood.
California education books, especially by HMH, does not reflect any of those core concepts.
I fully support the decision of IQC to reject two programs of HMH.
These programs are bluntly racist, hinduphobic, homophobic, and worse in quality.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, dear members of SBE.
My name is Sachin and I come from Fremont.
I'm a resident of California for the last 17 years and a proud parent of two girls.
I feel blessed to raise my kids in such a culturally diverse state, but I am dismayed in horror when I read what HMH textbooks have to say about India and Hindu civilization.
It shows images of cows eating trash, human labor and monkeys working together, scary-looking, gaudy images of Indian gods.
All these images and text represent a poor, dirty, and primitive picture of India.
You should really take a look at these images.
You don't need to be a Hindu to feel the horror that I feel.
Remember, a picture is worth a thousand words.
And these are the images my kids are going to be reading about.
So I'm really worried about raising my kids in California if these textbooks aren't changed.
Hence, I fully support IQC's recommendations to fully reject HMH K-8 textbooks and also support Dr. Jeffrey Long's recommendations.
Thank you for your time.
Dear respected board members, my name is Ankit and I come from San Jose.
I'm here to support recommendation of South Asian histories for all.
I am a Buddhist and I come from a Dalit family and I want to quote National Geographic's textbook, quote, the Buddha taught a person of any caste could attain nirvana, which is the ultimate peace, end quote.
I ask to please remove the attempts of the Hindu lobby to Hinduize the Buddha.
Americans may not be aware, but these are the strategies of the right wing to raise the resistance of the Buddha to the caste.
Buddhism resists caste, that is why many people converted to Buddhism, like Dr. B. R. Ambedkar, who is the father of modern India and who wrote the constitution.
I want to close by a three statement.
Please enforce framework and fix the mistakes.
Stop the alternative facts.
And last, mob cannot erase the facts.
Thank you.
Jai Been.
Hello, respected board members.
My name is Thiba Soundarajan.
I am a software engineer that works in San Francisco.
I'm also a Dalit American.
This morning, I was pushed at, yelled at, and harassed by Hindu fundamentalists while waiting to testify.
I also had to take care of my two sisters who fell ill because of this harassment.
However, me, as a result of this California public school system, I'm still here to tell you today that caste-based oppression does not create social stability.
The phrase that the caste system creates social stability is a lie.
We see that, and our communities, especially Dalit communities who have faced violence against the hands of Hindu fundamentalists, and what happened this morning can clearly demonstrate that.
I support the recommendations from South Asian Histories for All.
Please enforce the frameworks, fix the mistakes, and please remember that mob rule cannot erase facts.
So before the next speaker, I just want to remind everybody that we need to respect all speakers here, and we do not want any outbursts.
Every speaker deserves the same respect.
So I'll ask everyone in the audience to please give the respect that you expect when you talk as well.
Thank you.
Go ahead, ma'am.
Namaste, honorable members of the board.
I'm a proud mother of an elementary school student in Fremont Unified School District.
I read the HMH textbook and was outraged with the information they sent about Hindu religion.
I found inaccurate and unfavorable comparisons of Hinduism with other religions and generally a negative approach towards Hinduism.
I fully support IQC's decision to reject the textbooks of HMH for K-8
And I support the recommendation of the academic coalitions by Professor Jeffrey Long and his team.
Textbooks need to be giving education accurate information and not create any confusion or wrong impression in their tender minds.
Thank you.
Namaste.
My name is Jay Singh.
I'm a father of two primary school children and live in Santa Clara.
That's where they go to school.
I've lived in various parts of India, 30 years, different parts, different states.
Came close to different religions and quite a bit.
And coming from a scholarly family,
When we talk about Indian civilization, ancient Indian history, Hinduism, these subjects are very near and dear to the family.
So this is part of life.
This is where I'm coming from.
When I looked at an HMS draft which someone forwarded very recently to me, I was a bit shocked.
I was looking at this vague information.
I was looking at misrepresentation of ancient India and
a lot of negative connotation when we talk about Hinduism.
Hinduism, which is a synonym for humanity in all fairness.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you very, very much.
Thank you.
Next speaker, please.
Good afternoon, my name is Deen Mori Sandarajan and I am a Dalit American.
I'm here to say that mob rule does not get to determine a fact.
The fact that today we had the cops called on us, we had men harass us, my mother was crying, my staff member had an epileptic seizure because of the tension and the lack of protection for caste-oppressed minorities to speak with parity to access this process shows that democracy is being hijacked.
We are seeing what happens in Charlottesville when white supremacists roam the streets and try to rewrite the history of slavery.
What we are seeing in California is Hindu fundamentalists trying to rewrite the facts about caste.
That goes against all of the evidence that we've submitted, both from the South Asia Faculty Group, from the UN, from major civil institutions in both India and the United States.
I should not have to brave violence to be able to speak my testimony.
I should not have to have my family and my community members be crying.
I have been attempted to be ejected from this building four times today by people that reported me to the Board of Education simply for carrying the dangerous history of my people.
This is the dangerousness of my people, the fact that my people are cleaning up shit still under the caste system.
But that also is the reason why history matters, facts matters, and you cannot shut it down.
Good afternoon.
My name is Preeti Shekhar.
I'm a journalist and a radio producer and a human rights activist from India.
I'm a practicing Hindu, upper caste Hindu woman, but I want to learn about caste.
I want to learn about how different people have struggled to name and fight their subjugation.
Just like how white kids learn about racism and slavery in this country, people like us and our kids need to learn about the history of caste oppression.
I want to learn from Dalits how I can work with them and others towards real social justice and restitution for caste violence.
But I see that possibility made smaller by California textbooks that erase the word Dalit, like the National Geographic one, or texts that connect caste with stability, like Pearson's.
Please equip students our future generations with the ability to see describe and combat discrimination not deny it.
We request the board to please enforce the framework and to fix the mistakes.
Thank you.
Respect.
Respected members of State Board of Education.
My name is Soham Kanhekar, and I'm studying in eighth grade.
Many Indian kids have been ridiculed and made fun of because of these textbooks.
Every one out of three Hindu American kids has reported that they have been bullied on religious beliefs and practices.
Many children have said this has happened after the sections on Hinduism in ancient India were taught in schools.
Hence, it is extremely important that the hatred and the bias in the textbooks be addressed immediately.
I stand here with the Hindu American children who have been bullied and have faced hatred in the classroom like me.
I have missed my own history test to support kids like my own brother who would learn through these future textbooks.
I fully support the decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMH.
I request SBE to say no against hatred against Hindus in all forms.
I support the recommendations of academic coalition by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other top academics.
Please take all their recommendations.
Thank you.
Good afternoon to all the members present here.
My name is Krish Jaigar.
I'm an immigrant from India, and I'm here with the South Asian History for All.
We have seen textbooks from companies like Pearson, National Geographic, and they all bear the mark of the Hindu nationalist groups.
How can each of the publishers make the same kind of mistakes?
On behalf of the Indian-American community, we ask you to do three things.
First, delay the process so you can do a review.
Second, fix all the mistakes.
Look at our recommendations.
They were endorsed by over 100 scholars of South Asia from Title VI US universities.
And third, send the textbooks back to the IQC.
Let them make the final edits.
The Hindu nationalist groups claim to represent all Indians, but their lobbyists don't represent us.
The real Indian-American community is on your side.
Thank you.
Dear members of the State Board of Education, my name is Praneeta Grewal.
I'm a 7th grader in Iron Horse Middle School, San Ramon.
I'm here today because I'm a Hindu and I want all my friends to learn correct information about my religion.
But unfortunately, that is not happening.
For example, McGraw-Hill textbook has some problems.
The textbook originally inaccurately said that Ashoka became Buddhist after the war.
But in fact, he embraced Buddhism three years before the actual war.
IQC made a correction in only one place in the last hearing after it was pointed out.
But in two places, the error still exists.
I request that the recommendations by Jeffrey Long and the academic group be accepted to address all the problems in McGraw-Hill.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Gurmeet and I'm from Fremont.
My son is in sixth grade and more than me, he's more worried about the discrimination and bullying in the class because after some time they're going to read the same text.
On page 177 of sixth grade textbook of HMH 6 to 8 programs called Vedas, the sacred Hindu scriptures, a collection of spells and charms.
Spells and charms?
No other sacred book is mentioned in such denigrating terms.
This is inaccurate, biased, and discriminatory.
I support the letter by Geoffrey Long and 38 other academicists.
Hence, I ask you to reject HMH-II programs as recommended by IQC.
Thank you.
Respected member of the Education Board, I'm Praveen Agarwal from St.
Ramon, and my daughter just spoke to you about how deeply distressed she is.
I'm here supporting the recommendations by Professor Jeffrey Long and all other accommodations and request our honorable panel to please consider the suggestions.
I also thankfully support IQC for rejecting such textbooks which spread negativity towards any religion and creating an environment of racism and division in the schools.
It is really sad to see the depiction of Hinduism and ancient India being represented in the textbook in such a negative fashion.
even when the country and the same religion has given the leaders like Gandhi, a guru like Buddha and Guru Nanak, and a practice like meditation and yoga to the world.
And not only that in the ancient history.
In the modern history, nine out of 10 CEOs of the top tech companies are Indians.
So the country, which has embraced different religions, ethnicity, and culturalism, has to be depicted in the correct fashion.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Manoj Kumar Ekarwal.
I am from San Ramon, California.
I am father of two kids.
I am here to oppose hatred against Hindus and Indians in California textbooks.
I thank and fully support the decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMH.
These programs are the worst of all.
even after the huge number of revisions and rewrites submitted at the last minute, which correctively do not even address all the problems.
HMS had to submit thousands of pages of revisions
Let us be clear, even then the problems are not getting solved.
The height is, even with their submitted edits, you can find several errors at a quick glance.
Just for example, K-2-6 teacher edition, page 469, the reason says Martin King Luther, Jr., instead of Dr. Martin Luther King.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you.
Respected members of state education, my name is Jaydeep Dey.
I'm from Dublin, California.
I have a fourth grader and a kindergartner.
And as a parent, I'm really worried about the contents that my kids are going to study in the sixth grade, which is filled with hate against the Hindus.
I fully support the decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMH.
While some of the textbooks programs are good, the HMH programs are racist, Hinduphobic, and worst in quality.
They have numerous violations of Category 1 of adoption guidelines, especially the Category 1.10, which prohibits adverse reflection based on religion and ethnicity.
They also violate the California law, which prohibits religious discrimination.
In the name of religion, we are seeing enough hatred in today's world, and we don't want to add more to it by spreading lies and hatred against Hindus.
I request the board members to reject HMH2 programs as recommended by IQC.
Thank you.
Respected of the Board of Education, Namaste.
This is Vikas Prashad from Sanderman, proud father of a seven-year-old first grader.
I'm here to support the recommendations from Professor Jeffrey Long and his 38 scholars.
Please consider them in full.
I also like to thank and fully support IQC's decision and showing the courage to reject the textbooks showing prejudice and hatred towards Hindu religion.
However, it shocked me to the core when I saw the stereotypical depiction of not only Hinduism, but also in ancient India and some of these textbook drafts.
Even the last month's submissions are not much useful.
In spite of so many strong laws against racism in US, it pains my heart to see that biased and negative tone of narration in those textbook tests.
And it looks like they are deliberately... Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Respected members, I am Anil Rahom.
I am from San Ramon and I am father of two kids.
My kids go to middle school and elementary school in San Ramon.
My daughter's social studies classroom experience was different from the truth.
I have been hoping for better books for my son, so I decided to come here and talk in front of you.
I fully support the recommendation of IQC to reject the textbook of HMH, but I would like you, the respected board members, to do more to fix the problem.
McGraw-Hill also has a lot of racist contents, which is the violation of education codes.
I also support that all the recommendations of the Academic Coalition of Professor Jeffrey Long and his 38 top academics should be accepted.
If the publisher does not accept these corrections, please reject the textbook of these publications.
Thank you.
respected member of the State Board of Education.
My name is Anand, and I'm a father of an 11th grader and a third grader in Saindraman.
I stand here to fully support the IQC for sharing the courage to reject hatred and prejudice for rejecting the HMH book.
Also, I request SBE also to all harmful content, some of which is in the other books and some of it is being pushed by the Hinduphobic groups in the last movement.
I request SBC to say no to hatred against the Hindus in all forms.
Textbook is not the place for the politics.
It's not the place for the hatred.
Hence, please reject all forms of hatred today.
I support the recommendation of Professor Jeffrey Long and other recommendation.
Please consider them.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Gulshan Bhatia.
I'm from Laguna Hills.
I didn't go to high school or middle school here, but my children did, and I remember the pain they went through, and hence what we felt about their pain.
Through a country of 1.3 billion people, there are spread cases of casteism, but it is saying that a new scientific phenomena
or new social awareness does not get prevalent simply by convincing or eliminating his opponent, but rather a new generation is born which is familiar with the idea and those who are opposed to it eventually die, not killed, die, and the new idea becomes accepted and gets in practice.
So all the laws are against casteism.
The people from that category are given preferences.
Even the president of India today is president from that caste.
Thank you very much.
Namaste, dear Board of Education.
My name is Jay Prakash from Santa Clara, California, having a son of fifth grade.
I'm shocked to see dark contrast, the content my son is going to study and what was taught at my home.
With deep concerns, I stand here to oppose the silent hate propaganda against the great Indian civilization.
Okay, so my ask is simple and clear.
So please support Professor Jeffrey Long's recommendations for the K-6 to K-8 textbooks.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Dave Goyal.
I'm from Orange County, city of Irvine, one of the best school districts in our neighborhood.
I moved there because I want to give a good education to my children.
And one day my daughter come home and she start talking about all the Hinduism questions.
And I was surprised where she's getting from.
And I could tell she have a shame in her eyes when she was talking about it.
So I asked her to let me read the books.
So I read the books and I was surprised.
This is California.
People over here come from all over the world, all religious, everybody get respected.
How the textbook can be so biased?
Not going furthermore, I will just urge you guys, please fix these issues forever.
And as for President, let's make California great again.
Thank you.
Respected board members, I'm Sushil Sood from Arcadia, California.
I came here, my kids are already grown out of college, they are in college, but I came here to take this opportunity to talk about what they went through when they were in school.
And they were bullied, but me and my wife, who is a high school teacher in Glendale Unified in California itself, we tried to work with them and make them understand what the true religion is, how they should face those discriminations they were having in school.
It was hard and very difficult.
Now they've grown out, but I want to take this opportunity to request you guys to take into consideration recommendations by Professor Jeffrey Lang and make those amendments in the textbook so the future generation who is coming should not be facing that kind of discrimination and should live with their head high with dignity.
Thank you.
Namaste, my name is Samriddhi Pathak.
I am a fifth grader from Laneview Elementary School, San Jose.
Recently, I overheard my parents talking about incorrect, misleading, and biased content in the new draft of CA textbook publishers about India, Indian culture, and Hinduism.
Several of my middle school friends shared their horrific and discouraging bullying experiences due to this racist biased text in CA textbooks.
I am deeply concerned afraid that I am going to face the same bullying experiences as I am a Hindu Indian origin kid.
I am sure you can stop this by happening by rejecting such type of textbook publishers.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, respected board members.
I am Prashant from Pleasanton.
I stand here to oppose hatred against Hindus and Indians.
I thank and fully support the decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMH.
HMH's hundreds of revisions are incomplete, as they promised to replace some content.
They have not even said what those replacement would be.
How could a draft textbook be adopted when it is not even complete?
Who reviews them?
Can you adopt drafts or textbooks based on promises made by publishers?
This is completely volatile on the basis of adoption.
Hence, I ask you to reject HMS2 program as recommended by Equis.
Thank you.
Respected members of the State Board of Education, I am Raju Chamarti, Chief Academic Officer at the University of Silicon Andhra.
I also manage a non-profit initiative teaching a South Indian language to more than 9,000 students in 200 cities across 35 states in the U.S.
with the help of 1,500 passionate volunteers.
McGraw-Hill book has several inaccuracies.
IQC made corrections in some places, but several errors still exist.
I support the recommendations by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other recommendations.
Respected members, this is history, not a Hollywood story, and the history should not be distorted or misrepresented.
It is the responsibility of the board to provide the facts and not the fiction in the history books.
Please help correct the problem.
Thank you.
Respected Member of State Board of Education, I am Mandar Joshi from San Ramon.
I stand here to oppose hatred against Hindus and Indians.
IQC has shown courage to reject hatred and prejudice by rejecting two Hinduphobic books.
We request SBE also to reject all hateful content, some of which is in other books and some of which is binged by Hinduphobic group at this last moment.
I request SBE to say no to hatred against Hindus in all forms.
Textbook is not the place for hatred.
It is not the place for politics.
Hence, please reject all forms of hate today.
I support the recommendations by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other scholars.
Please consider them all in full.
Thank you.
Board members, thank you for this opportunity to speak in front of you.
My name is Ajay Goel.
I'm a resident of Folsom with children going to Folsom Cordova School District and a practitioner of Hinduism.
First of all, thank you for including information about Hindu text in the books.
I have a very humble request.
Many of the details that are contained in the books have been translated by
by people who are not practitioners of Hinduism.
As per the Vedic texts, it says that one who is following these Vedic texts, one who is a devotee of the Lord can understand, can develop understanding of the message given in those books.
So our request is if you could kindly include text by the translations from the from Acharyas, from teachers who are practitioners of those books.
Especially the one I personally follow is Bhagavad Gita as it is spoken and written by His Divine Grace A.C.
Bhaktivedanta Swami Prabhupada.
He is the founder Acharya of International Society for Krishna Consciousness.
Thank you.
Thank you very much for the opportunity.
Respected SBE members, I'm a proud Hindu parent of two young kids.
I live in San Ramon.
I completely support the IQC decision to reject head-filled textbooks, which are HMH K-6 and 6-8.
I completely agree IQC says that the program does not meet all the evaluation criteria in Category 1, specifically criteria statements 1.3 and 1.4.
which talks about religious discrimination and adverse reflection.
The program has numerous errors that exceed the definition of minimal in number.
The program also includes depiction of individuals from various religious groups that constitute adverse reflections.
as defined in state standards evaluating instructional material for social content and are not consistent with the criteria statements 1.10.
And that correcting these issues would require rewrites to the whole program which are not permitted as per CCR section 9524A5.
It is highly critical that we provide fact-based, unbiased information to our young generations to develop a healthy atmosphere.
Hence, I request you to please reject the other two textbooks, McGraw-Hill and Discovery, that are still biased and misrepresented.
Let's see.
Hi.
It's so good to see you all.
Thank you.
My name is Praveen and I'm from San Francisco.
I wanted to hear because I'm queer, I'm Hindu, and I'm Californian.
And I'm here to say, to request to say no on the textbooks and to delay the approval vote.
As a queer desi, I believe that queer liberation is connected to all people.
My family is actually upper caste, and the caste that I can tell you is a very real living issue and affects lots of people, to the extent that my grandmother had issues sharing the same food or touching the same people.
As I grew up, I've met folks from lots of different walks of life.
My family also attempted to cut out the caste conversation, and they were ashamed of it, and for good reason.
But the reality is that there's millions of living, breathing people
some of whom are in this room that have lived experience of their identity and their religion and their place in the Indian society and in the diaspora.
And by erasing caste, you're erasing their lived experience.
Thank you so much.
My name is Bulvinder Kaur, and I work with the Jigar Movement and with high school students from 14 high schools in the greater Sacramento area.
I've seen firsthand the discrimination of Sikhs in schools and witnessed the lack of representation and misinformation of Sikhs in the textbook.
Furthermore, it is evident that there is Islamophobic language, um, that exists.
As a Sikh, I not only advocate for accurate and inclusive language for Sikhs, but also LGBTQ+, Muslims, Buddhists, Dalits, and all groups that aren't being accurately included.
We must recognize that flaws in our system exist to be, to be privileged and to be in spaces like this.
You must be able to have transportation to downtown Sacramento and be able to give up a day's pay to be here in this space.
We should recognize who is not in this space as well.
We've gone through the process, you've established the framework, so we ask you to enforce that framework and fix the mistakes.
I hope you will actively work with historians and individuals who work on the real histories and not promote alternative facts created by majority groups with money.
Thank you.
Respected members of the State Board of Education, my name is Aditi Varma and I am a resident of Mountain House and a freshman attending Mountain House High School.
About one in eight people who responded to a bullying on Hindu American Children's Survey said that their teachers had made sarcastic remarks about Hinduism in front of the entire class.
A student quoted in Port mentions that, after being made fun of by people I thought were my friends,
I didn't tell anybody else I was Hindu, so I don't experience problems so much as I feel awkward sometimes.
There have also been reports of deep emotional scarring because of bullying incidents.
Being a Hindu girl myself, I know that I was crushed inside when I learnt information like this and when these incidents happened to me.
And I would like to also say that I'm grateful to IQC for rejecting two of HMH's programs, which are blatantly racist and hinduphobic.
I request you to take all the recommendations of the academic coalition by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other top academicians and import SBE to reject the programs of HMS as recommended.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Saithi.
I'm a sixth grader in Simi Valley Unified School District and I drove six hours missing school today to show my opposition to bullying.
Every one out of three Hindu-American children has reported that of being bullied based on religious beliefs and practices.
Many of my friends have been teased based on Hinduism in ancient India taught in class.
Hence it is extremely important that the hatred and the bias in the textbooks be addressed immediately.
I stand here in solidarity with all the Hindu-American children
who have been bullied and who have faced hatred in classrooms.
Thank you.
Hello everyone.
Namaste.
I am Shravani Balapalli, a fourth grader at Red Oak Elementary School in Oak Park, Los Angeles, and I am the sister of a sixth grader.
I miss my school today to make myself heard.
I fully support the recommendation of IQC to reject the textbooks of HMH.
I request you to dismiss all such drafts which promote negative impressions like my sister's textbook.
Let me tell you why.
When my parents and my sister were discussing my culture and religion and how it was described in my sister's social science book, I felt so confused and worried by the way how it is portrayed.
We know of an older friend who came home crying because of being bullied in school after the lessons on Hinduism.
I don't want my friends to look down upon me for the unfair message the sixth grade textbook is trying to convey.
Instead of focusing on the negativity, it can focus on so many positive aspects such as dance, music, culture, festivals.
Thank you.
Respected members of SBE, I am Krishna Pandey and I live in Rancho Cordova City.
I support the recommendation made by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other academic people.
I commanded and fully support the decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMH.
These programs are reject Hindu phobic and bad in qualities.
They have numerous
violation of category 1.0 of adoption guidelines, which prohibits adverse reflection based on religion and ethnicity.
They also violate the California law, which prohibits religious discrimination.
Time.
Okay, thank you.
Namaste, respected board members.
I'm the Rekha, parent from San Jose.
I'm closely following the textbook adoption process and I am here today to oppose hatred against Hindus and Indians.
I would like to emphasize on the fact that the main source of education for kids is from textbooks and teachers.
It clearly shows biased content against Indian civilization and Hinduism in these drafts.
This misinformation leads to polluting young minds and bullying.
Though I appreciate and stand by IQC's recommendations to reject HMH series, I request you to please reject series from McGraw Hill who are on the same path.
I also support the academic coalition letter by Professor Long and other 38 scholars.
I humbly suggest SBE to please accept their recommendations.
Thank you.
Time.
Respected members of SBE, namaste.
My name is Jaswanti Chander and I am an Indo-Fijian
and born a Hindu.
First of all, I sincerely want to thank the IQC's decision to reject Hilton Mifflin Harcourt because the textbooks are homophobic, Hindu homophobic.
So I feel rejecting this is not enough.
The seven textbooks, the seven great textbooks completely reglosses scientific achievements, aesthetics and philosophy.
Even the whole bhakti movement within the Hinduism is reduced to a single mention.
And I can speak with experience because I worked in the school system for 15 years.
Thank you, ma'am.
Respected members of SBE, sadar namaste.
I am Uma Singh and I am born a Hindu.
I support the recommendation of Professor Jeffrey Long and the 38 other academicians.
I commend and fully support the decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMC.
These programs are bluntly racist, Hinduphobic, homophobic, and worst in quality.
They have numerous violations of Category 1 of Adoption Guidelines, especially Category 1.10, which prohibits adverse reflection based on religion and tendency.
May I ask to reject racist publishers like McGraw-Hill, HMH, and Discovery.
Please, I say please stop hatred against Hindus.
Stop demonization of Hindus.
Thank you so much.
Dear SBE and dignitaries on the dais, my name is Anil Anam.
I'm a proud Hindu, resident of United States for last 19 years.
My kids are in the college of the US system.
Hinduism is one of the most tolerant religion on the Earth.
That's a known fact to everyone.
Not sure why the SIFA and other organizations are behind the Hindus for demonization of the Hinduism.
Hinduism has given knowledge on mathematics, politics, yoga, astrology, sciences, and many other subjects.
Every civilization has certain classifications which has pros and cons.
But at the age of these kids learning about this, it's more to expose them the world of religions than portraying negative and inaccurate acts of a particular religion.
I suspect I support completely the IQC recommendations.
And moreover, this is the fight against the civil rights.
This is not the fight against the civil rights.
Yeah.
It is more about our children learning about the world cultures.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Ganesh Sapate, a parent of two children from Castro Valley District.
I fully support the decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMU.
These programs have numerous violations of Category 1 of Adoption Guidelines, especially Category 1.10 prohibits adverse reflection based on religion and ethnicity.
They also violate the California law, which prohibits religious discrimination.
I request SBE also to reject all this hateful content, some of which also represent in other books like National Geographic, and is being pushed by Hinduphobia groups at this last moment.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Craig Givens, and I'm with the African American Education and Economic Policy Advocacy Group.
I'm here with Ms.
Taylor of the Black Parallel Education Board.
I ask that you reject all the textbook adoptions for the eighth grade, history, social science.
If your objective is to portray all people and communities fairly and accurately, you should reject these textbooks.
A prime example is the way the Emancipation Proclamation is treated in your history books.
Most people think that Abraham Lincoln woke up one day and thought freedom of slaves was a morally right thing to do.
This is totally false.
The North was losing the war to the South.
Desertions were high.
Issuing the Emancipation Proclamation provided 200,000 plus black troops union.
Those black troops called the United States Colored Troops was a decisive factor in winning the Civil War.
Failure to include Abraham Lincoln with the James L. Cochran stating exactly why he issued Emancipation Proclamation diminishes and undermined the contribution of black troops to winning the Civil War.
Thank you.
I'm courteous.
So just remind the audience that we're going to say respectful and no sounds other than those that are speaking here at the podium.
Thank you very much.
I'm Curtis L. Gardner with the same organization.
African American history must be contextualized.
The technical vendors are not presenting African American event in context and I'm opposed to any product that are not adhering to laws and your state board policy and has an insufficiency issue.
How many of you know if there had been no Emancipation Proclamation and the use of the United States Colored Troop, there would be no United States as we know it today.
Most of you would be pledging allegiance to the Confederate flag of the Confederate States of America.
Emancipation is just one of several issues that must be addressed and corrected.
West End representative yesterday addressed the use of supplemental materials when he found that the information that he purchased was insufficient.
The problem that we are discussing today is not new.
It was addressed back in 1890, 127 years ago, in a history of the Negro race by Edward A. Johnson.
Thank you so much.
Hi, I am Nachi Apanmuthu Kumar and I am a 6th grader in Valley View Middle School in SVUSD.
I am learning Hinduism in class.
In the current books and upcoming editions, Hinduism is very poorly represented.
Photos about Hinduism
are negative.
It shows something near the trash.
Unfortunately I haven't seen anything positive about Hinduism in my textbooks.
It is common for other kids in the class to look down upon me or my Hindu friends and our culture since it is misrepresented in the textbooks.
It leads to bullying.
Reject drafts of HMH and National Geographic as per IQC.
Thank you.
Dear respected members of State Board of Education.
I am Saket Vennela.
Sixth grade student from Portola Highly Gifted Magnet Los Angeles.
I'm here to express my displeasure about the way Hinduism is portrayed in classrooms from a student's point of view.
I felt very sad when I looked at the negative portrayal of Hinduism in National Geographic.
The pictures related to Hindus are very derogatory.
Core ideas of Hindus like Vasudhaiva Kutumbakam, Universal Brotherhood, meditation, and I have no mention in these in the books though.
I feel these textbooks are biased and encourage unfair treatment and bullying in schools.
While I am very happy with IQC's decision to reject HMH books, I request you to please consider rejecting National Geographic.
Thank you for your time.
If I may stop the speakers for just one moment, currently we are on number 245.
If you're in an overflow room and you have numbers 246 to 300, please make your way to line up in the main lobby.
Thank you.
Hello, everyone.
Namaste.
My name is Lakshmi.
I'm a mother of three kids going to OPAR schools in Los Angeles.
I support rejection of HMH by IQC, and I request you to confirm.
The Hindu phobic group South Asian Histories for All is a group of political radicals and religious fundamentalists whose only aim is to perpetuate hatred against Hindus.
All their edits only seek to adversely reflect on Hinduism while promoting their own religions.
This is problematic and will create more social content violations in the book.
This will also create violations of Category 1.10.
I support edits given by Professor Geoffrey Lang and 38 other academicians.
Please include them.
Thank you.
Respected member of State Board of Education, namaste to all.
My name is Sandeep Karma.
I am from Fremont.
And I'm here in front of you to speak against the demonization of Hindu and Indians.
I stand here with the support of Asians, LGBTQ communities, and the numerous Hindu, Jain, and interfaith groups, accommodations, educators, and thousands of Hindus and Indians across California.
It is that textbooks have become a battle, a tool of spread political view.
We all can have political views and opinion, but textbooks are not the place for such things.
We want all children to become the respecting of each and others, not start hating to the each others.
I stand here to support Jeffrey Long and 38 other accommodation who are seeking historical accuracy.
I request that the recommendation by the Jeffrey Law and the academic group be accepted, addressed, and all problems in the books.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Chaitanya Devadkar.
I'm with South Asian Histories for All.
Hindu nationalism is like white nationalism.
The oppressive history of the Hindu caste system is not up for debate, just as the horrors of slavery or the genocide of Native Americans are not up for debate.
Contemporary reality is that since 2010, rapes of Dalit women have increased by 65%, kidnappings are up by 45% and killings have increased by 30%.
At the same time, conviction rates have practically halved for crimes against Dalits.
Caste oppression is alive and well in India and in the diaspora.
As taxpayers, we expect public education to awaken and challenge students with the truth, not lull their blissful sleep with myths.
I urge you to say no to Hindu nationalist mythology, enforce the framework, and fix the blatant lies.
Thank you.
I am Surendra Singh, president of Lakshmi Narayan Mandir.
which is major Hindu-Issan in California.
First of all, I give my respect to all the members of SBE and what Hinduism is, it's a very...
I endorse all the remarks made here by various speakers, and I wish not to repeat them.
But the violation made in the textbook is not only wrong, but it's injustice to Hinduism.
Our temple, which is located at 7495 Elder Creek Road, it's open to any individual who likes and who wishes to visit, and we also welcome
Non-Hindus, this is not... I'm sorry.
Namaste, respected members of SBE.
Teaching history comes with uniqueness challenge in the classroom.
Hence, textbooks are not only have to be historically accurate, but also culturally competent.
Material that failed to treat all cultures with fairness actually reflects upon the religious and cultural heritage of the children, cannot only lead to psychological problems within students, but can also encourage bullying of children.
especially from minority communities.
It poses severe challenge in creating a safe and a nurturing learning environment.
We ask you to adopt new curriculum that will give our children access to accurate history.
So we thank IQC and please reject HMS books.
Thanks a lot.
Good afternoon, all board members.
I'm Milensha and Subramanian from Ambedkar King's Study Circle.
We're representing South Asian history for all.
The caste system is deep-rooted and cruel.
For example, the seven-year-old Amruth Eswar Boy lives in Surendranagar district, Gujarat.
Discriminated in a public school, he was forced to clean the toilets and made to sit separately and forced to handle the human waste.
As Dr. Ambedkar writes, the modern Hindu realizes the wrong in caste, but he is ashamed to discuss caste in the public for fear of letting the foreigner know that Hindu civilization can be guilty of such a vicious and infamous system or social code as evidenced by untouchability.
So I request you to enforce the framework and correct the mistakes.
I would like my kids to understand the cost of caste oppression so that they can un-inhalate the caste.
Thank you all.
Hi, I'm a board member.
My name is Kanak Natarajan.
I'm a member of Ambedkar King Study Circle.
I'm representing South Asian Histories for All Coalition.
Hindu practice is cast every day, everywhere, even in US.
Best example, all of your phone, just take your phone and go to google.com and type p.v.sindhu.
The first hit you will get is that PV Sindhu cast.
PV Sindhu, she's a 2016 Olympic medalist, first woman to get a medal in India.
When the California textbooks say that today, Hindus in India and US don't practice, don't identify, don't practice the caste, which is untrue.
That's totally not true.
So the first hit you get on the top of the- Time.
Yeah.
So I request all of you to enter the framework and correct the mistakes.
Thank you.
Namaste, respected board members.
I'm Madan Gumbineni, and I have a fifth grade son.
As a parent, I always taught my son about the ancient glory of Hindu heritage.
I don't want my son to feel inferior about the syllabus in California textbooks.
Finally, I want peace.
I want my son to have a peaceful life.
OK, this is the only one thing we are here.
We are all here.
As parents, we want to see our kids to grow in a peaceful environment.
We don't want them to be bullied by anyone, nothing, right?
Finally, I want to say only one thing is stop hatred against Hinduism.
I trust the board members will hear our plea and reject HMS2 programs and recommended by IQC.
Thank you so much.
Namaste.
respect of the board.
My name is Harish.
I'm from Arcadia, California.
A lot has been spoken today about the misrepresentation of India and Hinduism in the HMH programs, and like many others, I drove 400 miles to support the decision of IQC to reject the programs of HMH.
All that I ask for today is to have a very belief and purpose statement defined by the California Department of Education, which is to prepare the students to live, work, and thrive in a multilingual
multicultural world.
How can we boast of working towards this mission by portraying a specific religion, Hinduism, in the bad light?
It is unfortunate that there are specific organizations who are trying to perpetuating hatred against Hinduism and instigating the hatred ideology among our kids.
Members, we have a huge responsibility to ensure that our kids are taught the right content so they have a better tomorrow.
I hope that you will take strong consideration of all the facts presented by my brothers and sisters and reject the two HMH programs recommended by IQC.
Thank you.
Namaste.
I'm a parent of a sixth grader from Southern California.
I support the recommendations of Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other academicians.
Please consider all the changes and reject the drafts of McGraw-Hill National Geographic as not suitable for use in California's public school curriculum.
They depict inaccurate descriptions of core concepts and scriptures in Hinduism, Indian social structures, and the use of the outdated and colonial era theories of Aryanism and Brahmanism to describe the origins of Indian civilization and Hinduism.
They are against the free and stated objectives of California's education code and the standards for evaluating instructional materials for social content, which prohibit any group from being portrayed adversely or as inferior.
Thank you all for your patience.
Thank you.
My name is Venkatesh.
I'm coming from Folsom.
Thank you very much for taking the time and your patience for listening quite intently with all of us being talking and hope you have understood what we are trying to say.
And I just want to tell one thing.
I don't want to read that same, again, just want to tell one word about Hinduism.
I came, I'm really proud of it because it promotes Vasudhaiva Kuktumbam, which is a core concept of United Nations, which is the need of the hour every single day.
We cannot live in a fair place where we hate each other and we don't trust each other.
This is the concept.
It is not, Hinduism is not just a word or at least a way of living.
That's why so many countries, so many countries, even though I have been away from my country for 10 years, but I'm still connected to it.
So long as my wife, my kids also wanted to be knowing that vast heritage.
They just wanted to know, it's not just because we are Hindus.
Time.
We wanted to be universal.
Thank you very much.
Respected board, I'm a Dalit and I experienced caste till I come to United States 18 years ago.
Do I have to confront this monster even in this country?
You have to think about it.
We may be very small in number, but you can understand who is speaking from the heart and who is not.
I think you can.
And in case of race, as in case of race, caste has beneficiaries and victims.
The beneficiaries want to continue by not talking it, whereas the victims want to destroy it and exposing it.
An African-American slave or a Nazi or a Jew would tell you what they have faced in those days.
Same way, but it is dismantled already.
But in case of caste, still we are facing it in India, as well as here also.
If this is continuous, America is going to have capital, as Dr. Mitchell had already spoke about it.
OK.
And the worst victims.
Thank you very much.
Before we have the next speaker, I have an announcement to make.
I would like to thank everyone for their testimony.
We have heard from a large number of you today and hearing members of the public have continued to sign up to speak as the item has been progressing.
However, the State Board of Education by law needs to be able to maintain a quorum to allow for action by the board today.
Therefore, pursuant to Title V, Section 952, we will have to end public comment at 5 p.m.
today in order to maintain the quorum so we can act one way or another on this issue today.
In order to allow as many people as possible to speak, we would like to encourage the following.
Instead of reading your entire state only your position, such as I support or oppose the IQC's recommendation, come up as a group and designate one person to speak for one minute.
All people will then give up their tickets.
If you don't speak but have a written statement, please provide it to a staff member and it will be part of the record.
So we will end testimony at five today.
In order to act, we must end it.
Thank you.
Go ahead, next speaker.
Good afternoon, respected board members.
I am Balaji from Pleasanton.
I'm here to support Geoffrey Long and other 38 economists who are seeking historical accuracy.
I request that the recommendation by Geoffrey Long and the academic group be accepted to address all the problems in the book.
It's sad that textbooks become a battle towards political views.
We can all have political views,
and opinion, but textbooks are not the place for such views.
We want all children to become respecting of each other and not start hating each other.
Thank you.
My name is Rishi Modi and I'm a sophomore at Amador Valley High School.
I live in Pleasanton.
As a living resident of California, I felt that my presence is needed here today because of the hatred, racism, and prejudice that is being instilled in today's young adults.
I believe that nobody is above the law, so why do we allow such big tech companies such as McLaughlin and McGraw-Hill to break the law by discriminating against hardworking Americans just because of their race or skin color?
If this is the type of learning that we are instilling into our children, no wonder they grow up to learn that just because somebody is of a different skin color, they are lower than us.
Thank you.
My name is Gi-An Chan.
I'm a retired high school teacher.
Now I work with the Sacramento Elder Creek Hindu Temple.
And I want to sort of say that Hinduism practices non-discrimination and loves all the religion.
And at Hilda Creek Hindu temple, everyone is welcome.
And if we are invited by other churches or religion, we do as much supporting as possible.
So this publication in school, I don't think it's desirable.
Our children should be taught to love all the religion and all the culture.
And I may have been in over while this went on.
I would very humbly request the board to remove this from the textbook so that we don't discriminate against one or the other religion.
Thank you.
Can we have the next speaker?
Thank you so much.
Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Rucha Chitnis.
I'm here as a photojournalist, writer, and a women's rights advocate.
Right now, sexual harassment and violence against women is foremost on our minds.
And as a journalist, I've heard firsthand testimonies of Dalm about the structure of caste exacerbates violence against women.
And as an upper caste feminist,
I think we cannot, in our right conscience, erase the intersectionality of caste in our academia and in our history books.
So I sincerely urge you to delay the vote, enforce the frameworks, and fix the mistakes.
Thank you.
Hi, I'm Nolan.
I'm from Bay Area, part of the Ambedkar-Kingsbury Circle.
For centuries, Dalits all over India have been forced to do the dirty jobs.
They have been forced to clean the human fecal waste.
All other jobs have been denied to them for centuries because of the Hindu caste system.
These jobs are often fatal.
This is happening even while there are laws banning manual scavenging.
There is no other reason for the existence of this horrific practice than persistence of Hindu caste system.
For the textbooks, please try to deny.
Trying to deny the caste system is unconscionable.
Thank you.
Respected board members, I am Prashant and I have come down from Seattle over here because whatever decision you guys take will have implication on my son as well.
I am from India and I am also a Hindu but I happen to be from the privileged caste and I can totally understand why some of the members of my strata of society are going to downplay the issue of caste.
It's simply because we are blind to it and we are unable to see the implications on the underprivileged section of our society.
So instead of taking this decision based on emotional value, I implore the board to take decision based on the scientifically available major historians of the world.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Michael Ramirez, son of Lorenzo Ramirez, who is part of this case.
It is my understanding that Mendez v. Westminster, as it's called by some, is in the curriculum.
This book that I hold is narrated by Sylvia Mendez.
It is being used as a third grade study book.
It is filled with the same narrow narratives of the case along with the untruths of the adult books.
But this story has found a new home in the children's section.
I believe the thinking is the children's.
To my surprise, they have stooped to a new low by entering Mr. Estrada into the suit as a returning World War II soldier angered by segregation.
Problem is Mr. Estrada was never in the military.
There was untruth has strained the trust of the et al families involved with the point of not allowing any more interviews including the lawyers family.
Mr. Marcus was instrumental in not only civil rights but human rights in the Mexican people whether citizens of the U.S.
or Mexican citizens living in the U.S.
through the Mexican consulate.
Mendez and Roby are not reliable gatekeepers of this history.
I ask the board to add fresh eyes to teaching our children this very important California history.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Next speaker.
My name is Peter Friedrich.
Today you are witnessing an attempt to tell history by mob rule.
Funded by Hindu nationalists from India who massacre Christians, Sikhs, and Muslims, and daily subjugate, beat, rape, and murder Dalits, this mob demands revisionist history which erases the reality of subjugation in South Asia.
They want you to teach that caste creates social stability, that outcasts chose garbage picking as their profession because they were good at it, and Hindus in India and abroad rarely even practice caste.
Some moneyed and upper-caste people in California want to conceal the ongoing caste oppression of India's poorest and most downtrodden people.
If white nationalists or the KKK demanded textbooks teach that apartheid created social stability, or that Africans came to work at southern plantations to pick cotton picking, would you cave to the mob pressure?
Or will you teach Californian students true, factual, accurate history instead of biased, partisan, mythologized history?
Thank you for your time.
Good afternoon.
I'm Carolyn Laub, coordinator of the Fair Education Act Implementation Coalition.
I'll start by thanking the IQC members for their commitment to ensuring that LGBT people are included in the materials under consideration.
You're now poised to make history by approving the first LGBT-inclusive textbooks in the nation.
Our coalition agrees with the IQC's recommendations to approve 10 of the programs.
We also support the LGBT-related edits submitted by Hill, Studies Weekly, and National Geographic since the IQC's September meeting.
We also urge you to reject both HMH programs, which did not align with the framework or social content standards, by excluding LGBT people.
Rectifying that exclusion would require substantial rewrites, and all of that content has not gone through a thorough public review.
Your historic decision today will ensure that the only materials adopted for use in California K-8 classrooms include a full and accurate account of the roles and contributions of LGBT people in history.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Rick Acolto.
I am the educator at our coalition and also a member of the Fair Education Act Implementation Coalition.
We request that you affirm the recommendations made by the Instructional Quality Commission.
While we had originally recommended the rejection of Studies Weekly, we give our provisional support of the publication only given that the recently submitted edits on LG3 by them are accepted.
From the beginning, we have wanted nothing more than to have fair, accurate, inclusive, and respectful representations of the roles and contributions from LGBT members and communities.
In recent public discourse that emphasizes difference and division, it is our sincere hope that we can build empathy across our differences by learning about one another, our backgrounds, our cultures, and our experiences.
Community is built by acknowledging and celebrating one another and investing in the rich diversity that we each bring.
History may be in the past, but how we talk about it and how we represent each other will determine how they're in the future.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Crystal Torres-Cobrubias.
I'm the Out for Safe Schools coordinator at the Los Angeles LGBT Center, and I want to share with you an event that we had a few weeks ago with the Latino Equality Alliance, an LGBTQ advocacy group in Boyle Heights, Los Angeles, where we brought awareness to the Fair Education Act.
About 80 community members came out.
50 of those community members were students.
Of the 50 students that were there, only two could name an LGBTQ person who contributed to history.
Admittedly, those people they learned about were not people they learned about in their classrooms.
From my experience at that event and my experience working with LGBTQ youth advocates, I know that LGBTQ youth are ready for this content.
The spirit of the Fair Education Act is to give all students access to diverse and accurate history.
That cannot happen unless every single state-approved instructional program is fully and equally compliant with the law.
I urge you to follow the recommendations of the IQC and the Fair Education Limitation Coalition and reject both
both HMH programs as they fail to fully reflect LGBTQ history.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, SBE members.
Thank you so much for your service and for welcoming us here today.
I want to start by thanking the IQC members for their thorough revision and the panelists as well.
It's a very complicated process.
And as a member of the FAIR Act Implementation Coalition, I am here to say that they worked really hard with us and with the public, as you know.
We are here also to urge you to reject the two techniques as they fail to accurately reflect the representations of LGBT people.
And again, we urge you to accept the revisions that have been submitted by Studies Weekly as a mom of a child that is going to be going to Public School Systems California
as an LGBT person myself and as the leader of our vision representing thousands of LGBT families in California would thank you as our families will be raised and grow up finally seeing themselves represented in history and social sciences in this state and modeling for the rest of the nation.
Thank you so much.
Hi, my name is Taylor.
I'm from the California LGBT Health and Human Services Network.
I am also a social worker, an instructor at California State University of Sacramento, and a mom to an eighth grader, most importantly, and I also identify as queer.
I want to encourage you to
The recommendations of the IQC, I think they did a really great job of listening to our concerns and only approving the curriculum that was in line and actually accurately included LGBTQ history.
And along with assuming that the edits are in place for McGraw-Hill and studies weekly that you adopt those.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Cal Zielinski.
I'm a member of the LGBTQ community and I'm a graduate student in social work and a part of the larger community you represent.
I am a student that not so long ago, in service of absence of accurate depictions of historical figures from my community and other marginalized communities.
And I cannot begin to describe the effect of this historical erasure and bias these textbooks has had on the self-image of students like myself and my classmates.
In support of the Fair Education Implementation Coalition, I convey support for the edits that the National Geographic submitted on November 6th.
They proposed additional edits to ensure the biographies of Charlie Parkhurst and James Adams are correct.
And I support these and have suggested and the Fair Education Implementation Coalition has suggested that these edits be taken.
National Geographic has these edits and based on the support, I would offer my full support
And I believe I'm a part of the coalition in order to ensure this reflects the virus community.
Thank you.
Good evening.
I'm Bali Abhay and myself, we represent ISCOM.
and I endorse the recommendations of the Hindupedia and Professor Long because Mahatma Gandhi, he said, be the change you want to see.
That means we would like to see the change which is adopted by the Indian culture, the yoga, the great traditions of Bhagavad Gita, which was written by A.C.
Bhaktivedanta Upadhyay in order to establish the universal love and peace, just like Swami Vivekananda has said.
and Gandhi has also enumerated the same.
So my humble request that we really need to adopt the recommendations given by Hindupedia and the professors Long's, the coalition's accomplishments.
So I'd like to thank you everyone to give an opportunity to speak much.
Am I good?
Hey there.
My name's Anirvan Chatterjee.
I'm a Hindu-American, and I'm here with the Interfaith South Asian Histories for All Coalition.
We kind of all know what's going on here.
There are 300-some people who have come here so far, and it isn't hard to get 300 white Southerners out to say that, let's not talk about slavery.
It's inconvenient.
It makes us feel bad.
It's not hard to get 100 or 300 straight folks to come out and say, let's not talk about LGBTQ history.
It kind of makes us feel bad.
And it is not hard to get 300 Indian, Hindu, primarily Afrikaans people.
People like a lot of people in this room.
out to say, let's not talk about all these inconvenient histories.
It makes us feel bad.
We're feeling fragile.
But we cannot do that.
We cannot do that because Donald Trump pushes alternative facts.
But for us, we are California.
We are the state that protects Latinos, queer folks, that protects Muslims, that protects Dalits.
And we really want to make sure that our history textbook, the truth about what's happening
that we stand up for minority rights, we stand up for historical accuracy, we believe that you have the guts to stand up to people like me who are essentially the white folks of India.
I love white people, but we're not the only ones.
Thank you.
So my name is Bernali.
I'm also with the South Asian Histories for All Coalition.
Coalitions are hard, and our coalition has over 20 organizations.
We have queer activists, religious conservatives, atheists, tenured academics, and everyday community members.
We are interfaith, intercaste, and we embrace this messy pluralism.
We don't always, but we share some core values.
Textbooks should be based on the best scholarship, they should be respectful and nuanced, and they shouldn't whitewash the truth or promote alternative facts.
That's why we have come together to stand up against the Hindu lobbies pushing Islamophobia, caste denial and religious nationalism into our textbooks.
We Belichians believe in dialogue.
We believe in facts.
And we believe in you.
Because this is the best of what California can be.
Will you stand up for true facts and accurate history?
Please enforce the frameworks
that we fought so hard to get right and stakes in our textbooks.
Do not let alternative facts enter California textbooks.
Thank you.
My name's Elmer Sharegill.
You should have all received a letter from the Sharegill law firm.
I'm an attorney.
I'm also a board member of the Sikh Temperamento, executive board member of the California Democratic Party.
I urge you all to be very careful about overturning previous decisions of the board in a way that provides unequal, disparate treatment to a specific group that's lobbying you.
You might open yourselves up to litigation.
I urge you to be very careful about that.
I'm not going to go into the details of the letter.
But I'd like to say that on behalf of South Asian Histories for All, we should have empathy for the Hindu community.
It is not their fault that they are Americans now and beneficiaries of an oppressive South Asian culture.
We are all beneficiaries of genocide in this country, of slavery in this country, and yet we still want empathy from others, and we should give empathy to the Hindu community.
However, we should have the courage to tell the truth.
about internment of Japanese, about slavery, about Armenian genocide, and yes, about the oppression, rape, murder that we saw in South Asia and that we're asking for the truth to be told in these textbooks.
Hello, I am Aditya Doke.
I want to quote a concept from one of the Vedic literature which is Rig Veda.
It was in 1500 BC and one of the concept says that the first class of people that is Brahmins was born out of the mouth.
of the God.
The second class was born out of the arms.
The third class was born out of the thighs.
And the lowest class was born out of the feet.
And this is the Hindu literature which describes the social hierarchy and gave rise to the caste system.
So to sum up, the word Hindu and caste are very deeply interconnected.
So, I urge you, force the framework and fix the mistakes.
Thank you.
Hi.
Thanks for giving this opportunity to speak up my voice here.
Primarily, I am here for the ancient India portrayal in the textbooks.
By the way, I am parent of 12 and 5, and they go to Folsom Cordova Unified School District.
And I am really concerned about the way how the ancient India and Hinduism being portrayed in the upcoming textbooks.
It is being using an unfair yardstick to depict the Hinduism in comparison to other religions.
Each religion has its own, but the way how it is being depicted is very, very unfair.
And it is actually implanting a wrong picture for the young generations to come.
And that is not what Hinduism is about.
And I urge the California Department of Education to make a corrective action to fix these textbooks.
Dear members of the State Board of Education,
My name is Ishan and I'm a student of William Freya Elementary School Cupertino.
America teaches us equality and respect for all.
As an American Hindu student I request equality for Hinduism.
To me Hinduism means diversity universal peace and love for all living beings.
I request you to reject the teachings that hatred among people.
Thank you.
Respected members of the State of Board Education, my name is Sriram Akurseti and I live in San Ramon.
I have a middle school going son along with another attending college.
First, I didn't believe when I heard the presentation of India and Indian culture in Harcourt's draft K-6 textbook.
It shows ancient Indians in Harappa as tribal on page number 176 and 179, apart from many inaccuracies.
It has such demeaning and belittling description of Indian culture dotted with many inaccuracies.
It creates inferiority in the children coming from Indian culture, which further leads to bullying.
The draft has excluded achievements like yoga, meditation, mathematical discoveries, and so on.
It's the author's poor understanding of the achievements of India in ancient times or modern time like now.
As a concerned parent, I strongly support other publishers like McGraw-Hill, Portrait, My Culture, and request the board to reject their social textbooks completely from California.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, members of the State Board of Education.
I am Keshav, representing the Tri-Valley Talib community and also a parent of a child who has completed her education in the area I implemented these books.
I remember those days other students questioning her reality and heritage.
I find it imperative
to bring the change to the narration of India and Hinduism.
Indian culture presents many positive ideologies such as religious, harmony, instead of children who are taught non-relevant and negative ideologies and are given negative portrayal of India and Hinduism.
I fully support IQC recommendations to change the content in the world and National Geography and Discovery Channel, Discovery textbooks.
Yeah, please do the needful.
Thank you.
Respected members of SPE, next grader of Indian School District.
So here I am today to speak against publishers like McGraw Hill and HMH who portray inaccurate Indian history and Hinduism.
I request you to reject McGraw Hill and HMH programs.
Thank you.
A ferocious animosity has been unleashed against minorities in India.
The caste system is a prison without walls.
Just like my father spoke of Black Lives Matter, Dalit lives matter.
These are the words of Martin Luther King Jr.
III during an international conference the government of India invited me to attend last month.
My name is Lama Rangdrol.
I'm an African-American Buddhist Lama in the Tibetan tradition.
And yes, Buddha was born into a privileged caste, but he left to found an indigenous casteless faith system.
Therein lays the irrevocable distance difference between his religion and that I'm here to ask the SBE to join me in that compassion, as well as that of the king legacy as expressed last month.
Join me in doing the right thing.
Delay the vote and fix the text.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, members of the board.
My name is Judy Appel, and I'm a trustee on the Berkeley Unified School District's Board of Education.
And I'm speaking this afternoon in support of the IQC's recommendation and the Fair Education Act Implementation Coalition's recommendations for inclusion of LGBT materials.
It's critical for our students that their history lessons fairly represent the cultural, ethnic, religious, sexual orientation, and gender diversity of our state, and that there is a full and accurate account of these communities in our textbooks.
The teachers in my district have been waiting since the Fair Education Act for direction on what to teach and how to teach because they know that invisibility really harms our students.
That's particularly true in this political environment.
And so I will urge you to accept the recommendations of the IQC and the Fair Education Act Implementation Coalition.
Thank you very much.
My name is Harini, and I'm in seventh grade.
India has many great things, such as music, culture, dance, festivals, and food.
But why to choose the bad?
I am proud to be from a student entity, and I request SBE not to support textbooks that tries to de-grenade that.
Change these textbooks for the sake of our future.
Hi, dear panel members.
My name is Gagan Kashyap.
I'm coming all the way from San Diego.
My elder son, who is 12 years old, he always is very curious about our roots, and he and I always discuss quite often.
He and he really very feel proud of it for Hinduism and it isn't actually basically is followed by about 1.15 billion people on earth Which prescribes the eternal duties such as honesty?
They could self-restraint a compassion among others honesty and
Again, these values are keeping us very proud of our religion.
Having said that, when my son sees the Hinduism written in a textbook, he sees a very negative part of it, which really creates a big conflict in our house.
We have a strong belief on this very great panel to really consider and fix this discrepancy.
Thank you very much.
Good evening.
My name is Devi and I fully support IQC's decision to reject HMH K-6 and 6-8.
Thank you.
Hello, I'm Becca Kramer Mauter, and I'm here in my personal capacity as a Christian and a former United Methodist pastor, as well as in all capacity as a legislative coordinator of the ACLU of California, to encourage you to adopt and reject the textbooks that the Fair Education Act Implementation Coalition encourages you to adopt and to reject.
so that all students in California can benefit from learning about California's diverse, pluralistic society, and so that LGBTQ students can see role models reflected in their curriculum.
Thank you.
Members of the board, I'm Rob Darrow, Director of Research at Safe Schools Project in Santa Cruz, California.
I had the great fortune of meeting your student board member, Jayden Gray, at his high school.
He and I together visited this elective course that's being offered at his school on LGBT history.
It's one of about four or five schools in the state that offer a course like that.
The students in the course shared why they thought it was important for students to learn about LGBT and their reasons included, it's important to learn history from different perspectives, it's important that LGBT people are highlighted in history because there's a lot of important LGBT people in history, and that overall it provides greater acceptance and understanding of all people.
With your adoption of the IQC recommendations and the fair education, you will
that process forward for all students throughout the state of California.
Overall, you'll validate what those students said to me.
It's important to study history from different perspectives so you can better understand yourself.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Vaishali.
I belong to lower caste Bahujan Dalit community.
I stand here to oppose Hindu phobia by a group called S-A-H-F-A.
I belong to ancestry of Savitribai Phule, who fought for reforms of all women, Dalit and non-Dalit alike.
I don't want to feel they are nobodies, but only victims.
But I want them to know their ancestors were great contributors to Hindu culture.
I want my children to remain secure in their Hindu religious beliefs.
Some people like SAHFA think that California's history textbooks can be used to generate hate and convert kids into Hindu religion.
This is disgusting.
Fringe elements of SAHFA may try and continue to propagate hate into other places, but not in my state.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Sumedha, and I'm from the caste that some people consider it's a lower caste community.
I stand here against any kind of Hindu phobia.
Countless saints from Dalit and Bahujan Samaj community have contributed to Indian society.
For example, Satvamali composed a melodious poem and divinity is within everything, even within plants and animals.
But some people right here in this room ask to remove the lower caste sons to be removed from the framework.
Do you know who these people, they were S-A-H-F-A, the very same people who claim to stand for me and my community.
Sorry, Safa, you don't stand for me, you only stand for hate.
And thank you to IQC and SBE for including these saints in California.
Thank you.
Respected members of SBE, my name is Nambi Sankaran.
I've been living in Bay Area for 20 years.
And I have a daughter who is in the third grade.
I'm shocked to see the American textbooks still prematerial.
This results in students being bullied.
Even the teachers could bully the kids or insult them in front of everyone.
I don't want this to happen.
So we must condemn bullying at all levels, including schools.
Actually, schools are more important.
It is our duty as responsible citizens to stop bullying.
So please reject textbooks like HMH and National Geographic.
And let's stop the racial textbooks being used for bullying.
Thank you.
Honorable Board, my name is Gaurav Verma.
I'm from Fremont.
And I'm here because I'm concerned about her future as a Hindu child because I want her to grow up with a lot of self-respect about her culture and identity.
So I do welcome IQC's recommendation to reject Mifflin's, Harcourt's, K-6 and 6-2-8 texts.
But I will say that the draft textbook by McGraw-Hill for 6th grade does ignore the history-social-science framework for 2016.
Specifically, I would say that the non-authoritative translation of important texts like Bhagavad Gita by McGraw and Discovery
will have an adverse effect on the psychology and self-respect of Hindu children.
And these sacred texts, one must have acquired the knowledge in a bona fide disciplic succession under a guru.
So I do strongly move to adopt the translation from AC Bhaktivedanta Swami Prabhupada for chapter 6 and 8.
Edwin Arnold was clearly not qualified
as he was a poet and journalist.
On the other hand, I've been asked to announce that we have heard from, we believe, 283 speakers.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
As your 200th speaker, I appreciate your attention and patience.
My name is Natasha Sani.
I'm a partner with the law firm of Garcia Hernandez and Sani.
We represent school districts throughout the state.
I serve as general counsel to a number of school districts, including the Oxnard School District, Wainimi, Peralta Community College District, and a number of others.
I also served as the speaker's appointee to the California Commission on Asian Pacific Islander Affairs, and I stand here before you as a Sikh American and soon-to-be parent of a public school child.
You have received a letter from the Shergill Law Firm outlining a number of issues and mistakes that we see in the text that's been provided and asked for adoption and consideration.
We're requesting that the Instructional Quality Commission's curriculum framework that was adopted by this board on July 14, 2016, be complied with more fully, more accurately.
We know that these issues are complicated and tough and we need your continued attention to these.
History matters, accurate history matters.
Please enforce that framework and fix these issues.
We hope not to need to bring an injunction or any other further
legal action and we really appreciate your attention.
Thank you.
If you have a number up number 350 please line up in the lobby.
Hi, I know everyone here must be exhausted and we all appreciate your service.
Just to give you a heads up, you're not missing much out there.
It's raining and the line out there looks like the DMV.
I'm an emergency medicine physician.
I'm here for South Asian Histories for All.
As an emergency medicine physician, I've seen the implications of conveniently deleting facts from research.
Dr. Andrew Wakefield, for personal financial gain, erased data on the studies leading to the anti-vaxxer move in the 90s.
And now we see the implications of that among the pertussis victims, children who can't breathe.
There's the Tuskegee syphilis study, where you have African-American population that was inoculated with syphilis for research purposes.
And in Detroit, for example, where I trained, you have American public that doesn't trust the medical community.
Time and time again, we see the sequelae of alternative facts, of deletions of history.
And I please urge you to enforce the framework and fix the facts.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Sarah Jean Zochline, and I am a seventh grade teacher in the state of California.
And I just want to let you know that if this textbook is published, I will not teach it to my students.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon.
IQC, I'm sorry, introduce myself.
Lorraine Richards, I'm so anxious to be up here.
I've been waiting since nine o'clock.
Lorraine Richards, California Teachers Association.
IQC spent much time on a massive task.
Much review has been involved.
As a social studies, it has been very frustrating to implement Common Core this year.
The English department had the luxury of having a textbook and having primary sources
to implement Common Core.
And this year, the social studies teacher in my department are still using the 2006 textbook.
187 and George W. Bush as president.
Teachers continue to hunt for dated material that's appropriate online and photocopying is necessary.
The PLCs have to take a shift and look for the materials in tune and effectively use them in the classroom.
But you also need to consider equity taken into consideration and state in the California Education Code.
Thank you.
Hey everyone, my name's Tara.
I'm a queer transgender Hindu born into an upper caste family.
I'm here with the South Asian Histories for All Coalition.
I believe it's incredibly important that folks like me learn the truth about caste and its root culture.
We can't end caste apartheid if we can't talk about it.
Learning basic historically accurate facts isn't an attack on Hinduism, just like learning about homophobia isn't an attack on straight people.
It's a form of educational malpractice when Hindu nationalists flatten our communities or dumb us down to a single narrative.
And fourth, thank you.
Good afternoon.
As-salamu alaykum.
Peace be upon you.
My name is Farah Mahasri.
I'm a Muslim American.
My parents are from the South Asian country of Pakistan.
I'm here today to ask you to enforce your framework and to fix the facts and some of the proposals.
Today, 53% of students, Muslim students in the great state of California, report being bullied in school.
36% of Muslim girls who wear hijabs or head coverings report that their hijabs have been forcefully removed from their heads.
That is a physical assault.
When we allow Isiah into our textbook, it institutionalizes fear and hatred and bigotry against Muslims.
And this has long-lasting effects.
As educators, we know that students who are traumatized are incapable of learning.
They are stuck in fight-or-flight response, and they cannot retain long-term memory.
I know that this is a fact from personal experience.
As a 10-year-old, my teacher, my teacher called me a terrorist in front of our entire classroom.
So thank you, and I ask you to enforce your framework.
Hello, I'm Kamal.
I'm a Fremont resident.
I support Professor Jeffrey Long's and Hindupedia's recommendation to edit some of the text.
I feel every religion should be
represented correctly and it will only you know through an authority i support chapter six and chapter eight of ac bhakti vedanta uh bhagavad gita's text to be included in the megahill text
books current text is not accurately representing Hinduism.
Thanks.
Hello, my name is Abhinav Shukla and I'm a Hindi poet and I really appreciate all the effort you have been putting in.
I support IQC and doctor's feedback that we have been talking about.
I just want to tell you that I'm father of two kids, and I want them to be the wonderful citizen of the future of America.
And I want them to feel from inside, not anything that puts them
I am a parent of a 10th grader and a 4th grader studying in Balsam Cordova School District.
California state guidelines for India, Hinduism and Jainism be ignored.
only if they incorporate the content suggested by Professor Geoffrey Long and other 38 academics.
And if we don't reject these draft books, those are in question.
Eventually, they will increase in bullying incidents against our students.
will say, look at California, what have you done?
And eventually other states who are adopting California history books, you know, they may stop, you know, adopting California history books.
I appeal again, please stop material disrespecting and misrepresenting Hindus and Jain people in the California textbooks.
California is at the top of my economy list in the world, and please maintain the same standards while representing Hinduism and Jainism.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon.
I'm a parent of a first-generation born who's going to put his roots here in California and the United States.
Thank you for your hard work, for listening to all of us.
California law and the standards standard of evaluation says the criteria is to instill in each child a sense of pride in his or her heritage.
Develop a feeling of self worth related to equality of opportunity.
Eradicate the roots of prejudice and thereby encourage the optimal individual development.
All of these are violated by textbooks by HMK and others.
They also prohibit any description, depiction, label, or rejoinder that tend to demean, stereotype, or patronize minority groups.
The portrayal of Hindu religion does exactly that.
Malcolm X said, if you hate your roots, then you cannot like any other part of your trip.
This is exactly what the textbooks do.
Thank you so much, and I hope you do hear us out and make a good decision.
Thank you.
That's it.
Hello, my name is Eric Harris.
I'm with the California NAACP.
I'm here because an organization, NAACP, as a racial minority, we understand the challenges that are faced when it comes to our story being told properly.
We understand, as an organization that has been around since 1909, that it is very, very important to have textbooks and have history written the way that it's supposed to be written.
We started, like I said, in 1909, and we've been an organization for generations representing different people of color.
And we stand up strong for the people of Indian descent when it comes to these textbooks, saying that they should be done properly, redone, and that the current textbooks are not in the proper form.
the California NAACP stands against the current textbooks in their current form.
Thank you.
Namaste.
My name is Govinda.
I am Tracy, California.
These are the opening marks in a language called Sanskrit, the most ancient language from India.
Anything to know about India, you need to know Sanskrit, whether it is the culture, whether the Vedas.
Bhagavad Gita they're talking about, all the contributions that ancient in technology, science, mathematics, and everything, they're all in Sanskrit.
Sanskrit is alive today.
And in fact, here in Bay Area, hundreds of people speak Sanskrit at home.
But many of the textbooks that are being prepared, they do not say anything about Sanskrit.
They talk about Sanskrit, but in a way that is no longer spoken by people.
I spoke.
I'm alive.
So Sanskrit is also alive.
In fact, my son is here.
He speaks Sanskrit.
We speak Sanskrit at home.
So thousands of people speak Sanskrit at home.
Not only that, the textbook that we also support all the changes that are being done.
Professor, thank you.
Hi, esteemed board members.
My name is Sirisha and I'm from Folsom, California.
I thank and fully support the decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMH.
These programs affect our kids very negatively by portraying them and their country in a very negative light.
Even after the huge number of revisions and rewrites submitted at the last minute, not all problems are being addressed equitably.
HMH had to submit 4,600 edicts collectively for their program, that too just four days ahead of IQC's deadlines.
Even with that, they have huge errors in their books.
For example, just the HMH 628 program has more than 160 revisions.
Since they are not permitted as per California Code Regulation, Section 9524A5.
Even this has several errors and we don't have time to go through all of them.
Just a cursory review shows a lot of problems for them.
So please reject HMH books.
Thank you.
Good evening board members.
Thank you for listening to us.
My name is Sarjanya Palleti.
I live in San Jose and my two kids go to Evergreen School District.
As a first generation Hindu American parent it has become a challenge for me to make my kids unlearn and undo what is taught in the schools and school textbooks which is very sad.
Especially with respect to my culture and religion.
I'm appalled to see Hindu Hinduphobic and anti-Hindu group.
Against Hindus and contempt towards anything Hindu.
It is imperative that you reject untruthful, biased, and hateful material against Hindus and present Hinduism and Indian civilization the same way and with same standards and with all fairness that you present the other religions.
Now, onus is on Brexit, which is long overdue.
Thank you very much.
I am on behalf of all these eight kids.
So we support the IQC recommendation.
We support Jeffrey Long's letter.
And we oppose Hinduphobic groups like SAFA.
So thank you.
We just wanted to come as a group.
Thanks.
respected members of State Board of Education, a big Namaste and Om to all.
I'm Chakravarti Sulwa from Milpitas, California, representing Virat Hindustan Sangam, California chapter.
Before coming here, monetization of Hindus and Indians.
But I really felt bad after listening to a lady just before, who mentioned that a guy was beaten up for growing mustache.
But I think she probably forgot that a Sikh
with a beard, mustache, and turban for a decade.
Senator board members, lots of fake information is being projected by different groups.
So I humbly request you to all please consider feedback given by Hindus, not Hinduators.
Thank you so much.
It is a well-known fact that bias and ignorance stems from miseducation.
A simple solution to this ignorance is to fix the textbooks that millions of kids in California read, but not everyone agrees with the solution.
The people of SAFA has interrupted the process at the last minute and are now bold to make changes and stop the process.
One of the lady speakers representing SAFA came up to me while I was in line and started recording me.
When I asked her why she was recording, she harassingly asked, do you believe hatred against Dallas is funny?
No.
Discrimination against anyone is never funny.
This is coming from someone who has been discriminated and abused for my religion and my belief.
No matter who you are, you deserve the same amount of respect you give to others.
I request for you to accept the revisions admitted by the IQC.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, respected member of SBE.
My name is Basavaraj.
I'm a resident of Pleasanton.
I have two kids going to Clinton University.
I'm here to support IQC's decision about rejecting HMH K-6 and 6-8.
And also I support Jeffrey Long's letter.
And thank you very much for listening and your hard work.
I appreciate your time.
Have a good day.
respected members, I am Nilesh Malpedi.
First of all, I really appreciate your patience listening all of us.
Without taking any additional time, I thank you, fully support the decision of IQC rejecting the and then I support by Jeffrey Long and 38 other academicians.
Thank you.
Dear board members, how would you react if New York is shown in books with the pictures of homeless people at ghettos instead of Statue of Liberty?
India and Indian civilization has offered many things, such as yoga, mathematics, and the democracy.
So why show India in poor light by showing slums and monkeys?
My name is Ramji Sethuraman, father of two kids who are studying in San Mateo School District.
I would like to register my disappointment in front of the members of the State Board regarding the misrepresentation of India and Hinduism in the HMH K-6 and HMH 6-8 programs.
I fully support the decision of IQC to reject these two programs of HMH.
I stand here with the support of 11 Assembly members, 3 Congressmen, 3 Senators, Lieutenant Governor Gavin Newsom, and numerous Hindu Jainists.
Stop the hatred against Hindus.
Stop demonization of Hindus.
I trust the board will hear our plea and reject HMS2 programs as recommended by IQC.
Thank you.
Namaste, respected members of State Board of Education.
originally a Kashmiri Pandit refugee from India.
I missed my birthday today to make myself heard.
My elder daughter's social science studies classroom experience was very painful for us and has left very bad memories for our family.
I have been hoping for better books for my younger daughter.
I fully support the Recommended QC and digital textbooks of HMH, but I would like you to do more to fix the problems.
McGraw-Hill also has a lot of prejudiced and racist content.
I also demand that all the recommendations of the academic coalition by Professor Geoffrey Long and 38 other top academics be accepted.
If the person has suggested correction, please reject McGraw-Hill as well.
Thank you and Dhanyavad.
Hello everyone namaste my name is Veda Balapalli and I'm a 6th grader at Madea Creek Middle School in Oak Park California.
6th grade was the first time I was taught my culture in school.
I was very excited however I'm so shocked by the way how my culture is described.
It is not fair that the textbook is creating the negative impression upon us.
After reading the chapter, I clearly feel that not only will my classmates form wrong impressions on Hindu culture, but I also feel that my fellow Hindus may be bullied for the same reason.
Surprisingly, the textbooks do not cover the many positive aspects of my culture, such as dance, music, culture, festivals, traditions, philosophy, et cetera.
I understand, as for my dad, that IQC did an excellent job in framework.
I sincerely request you to make sure that the framework standards.
Good textbooks encourage student interaction and stop bullying.
By following the framework standards you will be promoting that for my future, my siblings future and other children's future as well.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Jaddeep Singh.
I've appeared before at least a couple of times in my capacity as a Sikh-American historian.
I'm someone who's very deeply invested.
I held one of the four Sikh studies chairs in the state of California about five, six years ago.
So that's part of my credentials.
I appeared before you before here because Sikh-American history was being distorted and erased.
And I paid no respect.
Unfortunately, there are still some problems in terms of theology, of Sikh Americans being misrepresented, Islamophobic histories, as well as misrepresentations of caste.
Now, I'm someone who's very deeply invested in California's education.
Not only did I go to high school here, but I earned three degrees from here.
I've taught in all three levels of higher education.
Now the problem we have in this country, the reason we have Nazis marching in Charlottesville is because the lack of courage we had in telling the truth about who we are.
The same problem is occurring right here.
Yes, our history with caste is very ugly, but that doesn't mean we should erase it.
So please, listen to the historians, South Asian American Histories for All, listen to the scholars.
I'm a scholar and I know that I'm not qualified to make these adjudications.
Please listen to the scholars that are.
Thank you.
Namaste, respected SBE members.
I am Kiran.
I'm a parent of a seventh grader son and a first grader in Cupertino, California.
Quickly, my major concerns are the reflection of Hinduism.
My son and myself have been reviewing the drafts as well and I involved him for the sake of understanding.
So my experience comes right out of what I saw my son said.
He did feel that Hinduism has been negatively reflected.
He doesn't feel that it would reflect his character or what he thinks about others regarding caste or any many other aspects.
So my request to you is, please continue to reject HMH.
I support the IQC decision to reject HMH.
And at the same time, please reject me.
Please consider the changes for Nat Geo and also consider Jeffrey Long's letter.
So the biggest concern is the credibility of the textbooks so that the kids start respecting the textbooks.
Thank you.
Good afternoon and namaste.
I know you have something to learn for the future generations to come.
So I hope and I urge you to make a decision based on unity and not divinity.
So let's not divide, let's unite.
And these are the children who will be going and becoming future presidents and senators.
They have to be proud of who they are.
The country and its social and economical situations are different than a religion.
Religion is practiced by many people all over the world.
I hope and I'm sure that we'll make the right decision that we can be proud of 10 years from now or maybe 100 years from now.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, my name is Navdeep and I've taken today off and drove all the way from San Diego to share my concerns about negative portrayal of Hinduism and India in HMH McGraw-Hill and Discovery books.
I was born and raised in India and I have experienced beautiful aspects of Hinduism like there is a world as one family.
Also respect for women, inherent secularism and love for environment.
I have many friends whose children were bullied in school because of negative portrayal of Hinduism.
This is not just against California Department of Education's guidelines but also against
Please reject HMH as recommended by IQC.
And also, I fully support edits submitted by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other academics.
Thank you very much.
Namaste.
Good afternoon, everyone.
I am the fourth grader and one son coming from Los Angeles.
I'm coming from a Hindu background.
We respect, we treat women as goddesses.
We have goddesses, Lakshmi.
We have goddesses, Saraswati.
We have goddesses, you know, for education.
We consider men, consider teachers of God.
We see everywhere God.
You know, we wanted to include everyone.
So I would request we should not promote any negativism or any, you know, making any other religion or anything bad.
We are sending our support and we have to have that inclusive attitude.
We should not separate anyone.
So I really appreciate your patience, you know, having you have that type of intention, you're patiently listening.
I really appreciate your patience.
I'm thankful to you.
Strongly support the introduction of the hedge fund by IQC and request you to confirm.
Thank you very much.
Dhanyavaad.
Hello, everybody.
Thanks for all your patience.
I'm coming from Fremont School District.
And of course, the first generation daughters in America.
And I'm also, as a parent, deeply concerned the way I read her chapter on Hinduism.
And it start with first paragraph, which is full of negativity.
about casteism.
I'm not surprised.
I mean, if you want to focus, you should focus on positive things about any religion, any country.
And today, millions of people around the world, and in America as well, following the yoga.
Because everybody's looking for peace.
And within themselves, also, you know what's happening around the world.
And this yoga came from India.
And you are not projecting that as a positive thing in the book.
That should be our clients.
If you love American kids, America, and our next generation, you should focus on positive thing.
So I support HMS books.
Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
Hello.
Hello, my name is Shyam Paleti.
I'm from San Jose.
Recently, a news article from LA Times caught my attention that one of the princes of South Korea was arrested for corruption charges.
He was the donor to the tune of $20 million to the Harvard and George Washington universities.
You see, such corruption happens to be donating to the universities and academic
institutions so that they can present their religion.
Such Islamic or evangelical missionaries, marxist groups, are big donors to present their angelic view of that one.
That is how the textbooks are presented, whereas when it comes to Hindus, Hindus are orphans because they cannot provide money to the sahibs and all that stuff.
But also, Hindus have been victims for millennia.
And also, a lot of them have been genocided, including the person, the Kashmir Bandits, who spoke a few minutes ago, was a victim.
So I urge you to reject all kinds of textbooks that present Hindus and Hinduism in a negative way, as opposed to fairness to the Hindus.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, dear members of the board and all of you present here.
I just want to say each and every civilization across the world is having its pros and cons, but why all the cons are there in the books of the Indian culture.
So I think truth is not there.
Truth should be revealed when we are presenting both the aspects of good and bad.
So truth is not about telling the bad stories about the Indian culture and the civilization.
Thank you so much.
I think you'll do the justice.
Thank you.
My name is Nidhi.
I'm a 10th grader from Mountain House High School.
Imagine being a 6th grader and opening up these textbooks to find out everything you've been taught about your culture society and religion is being misrepresented.
This is just not my case but the cases of thousands of 6th graders all over California right now.
Now, I've always looked for knowledge, and knowledge is equivalent to the worth of God.
If this is true, do I follow something so high in worth, or do I follow what society has always taught me?
Keep these questions in mind while making a decision.
Thank you.
Respected members, my name is Himanshu Shukla, and I just want to give you a kind notice that there are a few members of SHAFA who are coming and speaking again and again.
So we need to be mindful of the fact that there are a lot of people waiting outside.
So at the end, I just want to say, please reject HMH as recommended by IQC.
I fully support edits submitted by Professor Jeffrey.
Thank you so much.
Hello, respected board members.
I'm Saroj Satpatee from Pleasanton.
You are the forward thinkers and trendsetters for California.
I have a very simple question.
My 13-year-old saw this textbook, come back to me, say, I read about Greek civilization versus Roman civilization.
Am I this?
I start, no, but I stop my younger one, come up, stop me there.
I trust my brother.
And it is written in the book, my brother said it.
Please, I have the simple question to everybody.
Please tell me, I will go back and what I will answer to my six-year-old so that the fact will be reflected in his mind.
That's all I will answer.
Good afternoon all.
Thanks for providing me an opportunity to come and speak here.
I am Asha.
From the ongoing proceedings, I can figure out the real concerns of hundreds of parents like me.
On the other hand, I am pleased to see a bunch of people from SAFA equating India to just a caste problem.
Isn't there anything worthy for which India has to be remembered and revered?
be it the field of math, astronomy, medicine, philosophy, dance, music, anything at all, I request the SP to do justice.
The Prime Minister of India is a Dalit.
I hope it conveys to you a lot.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Pranav.
I'm a coordinator with Hindu Education Foundation.
We have actively worked with the IQC throughout the process, the framework process, and even the textbook recommendation process.
We participated throughout the process.
But what I've noticed today is that there's a group called South Asian Histories for All, which has suddenly appeared out of nowhere, and they're trying
kind of portray that, hey, you guys are doing something really wrong.
Participate from the beginning.
So where were they when, you know, all the other processes were happening?
You can't just come and, you know, sabotage something which has been going on for a long time.
We have participated in the process.
Also, some of the recommendations that they're giving, for example, removal of Saraswati.
If they're really, then you'll violate the framework.
So are they actually asking the textbooks to violate the framework?
So I don't understand why they're doing this.
I fully support the recommendations of the IQC.
And thank you for allowing me to speak.
respected board members.
So I just want to highlight a few points from India, because a few friends said something negative.
So I just want to tell you we feel proud that I'm a Hindu majority country.
And my current president is a Dalit.
His name is Ramnath Gond.
The person who written the Constitution of India is a Dalit.
We have a Sikh president.
Sikh Dalit is also Prime Minister Manmohan Singh.
And the past one of the most religious book, Ramayana, is written by Balmiki.
So you see Valmiki is a Dalit and the Vedas are written by again a Dalit with Vyasaji.
So this is how you can come to know that what Dalits are living very happily.
This is what Hinduism is known or the Hindu country India is known for all the religions and if you look the population of other
religion, other groups are keep on increasing.
In fact, we are in majority.
This is not happening everywhere in the world.
So this this is how you can come to know how peaceful we are and how respectful we are to the other.
Same respect from other religion and other countries.
True.
Thank you.
Good afternoon members.
I'm currently in 6th grade attending Lawson Middle School in Sunnyvale.
This year my class will study about different religions and ancient cultures around the world as part of a history and social science.
Social science.
We have not started reading about.
My textbook I see several.
People.
I see several bad pictures in those chapters.
For example a picture of people staying in slums and cows roaming around amongst garbage.
I'm already worried how my non-Indian character will be teased and made fun of.
In my school we talk about showing respect and caring for each other.
Why are such things which go opposite in the opposite direction and encourage negative behavior put in the textbook.
My humble request to you is to make sure that none of the new textbooks that come out next year have these problems.
Thank you.
Hi, my name, good afternoon, respected board members.
Hi, I'm in sixth grade and I study in Lawson Middle School in Cupertino.
I came to know that existing history and social science textbooks that I will be studying from in middle school have stuff that shows Hindus and Indians in,
And what's more, nothing much is likely to be improved in the new textbooks.
In the new textbooks which are coming out next year.
I'm really concerned about this.
Just as I want to learn more about other cultures and religions, I want my friends and my classmates to know more mine.
Things like values that are important to my family, the festivals we celebrate.
Time.
And I want to feel proud of my culture to be able to talk about it.
Please make sure that the stuff that goes into new textbooks will help that.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
respected members of the State Board of Education.
Ten years back, I think last time when we did the review, I was here asking to change or portray Hinduism in a positive manner and still that is not being done.
And this is a right chance, hope I don't need to come next time here asking for this correction.
And second thing, I saw that some of the groups are portraying that the kids and parents are here lobbied by somebody.
They want to just misrepresent India, South Asia, all these kind of things.
I feel very bad.
These kids are coming after taking off from class.
They want to make sure that their belief or the system what they believe and practice at home is represented properly.
I request that the recommendation by Jeffrey Long be accepted to address all the problems in the book so that I don't need to come next after 10 years.
Thank you.
And sorry for keep you guys waiting and standing all the way through this process.
Namaste.
My name is Arjun, and I am in second grade in Sedgwick Elementary School.
I would like to explain the Bhagavad Gita and Ramayana translated by non-Hindus.
There are no Hindu translators.
Please have McGraw-Hill use A. C. Swami Prabhupada's translation of the Bhagavad Gita.
Please see the letter from Hindupedia.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Good afternoon, respected members of the State Board of Education.
My name is Srinivas Vinayakotta.
I am the concerned father of two girls.
This is my third time.
In the last two years, I came to Sacramento and expressed my views.
In these two years, IQC made good progress.
I thank them for rejecting two girls at the same time.
I am utterly shocked with the National Geographic, which has completely ignored the new framework, for example, skipping our core Hindu teachings, rituals, and tries to show Hindus as a primitive entity.
This violates the California law, as well as the criteria for instructional material as mandated by the CDE.
The textbook should be adopted only if all these changes are reflected, failing which the textbook not be adopted for teaching in California public schools.
I demand that all the recommendations of academic coalition by Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other top academics be adopted.
Good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
and the young board member.
I really appreciate your time and effort that you have put in in listening to us today.
I'm going to say one thing.
When I was in school, I teach my children, one of whom is in the eighth grade, one of whom is in college.
Matru devo bhava.
Mother is my first God.
Pitru devo bhava.
Father is my second God.
Acharya devo bhava.
Teacher is my third God.
And then Atithi devo bhava is my fourth God.
I want to emphasize on the third slogan, which says, teacher is my God.
We teach our children what your teacher tells you is what is going to form you for not today, but for the rest of your life.
Would you want it to person?
I tell my son.
If he complains about a teacher, you need to resolve, because the teacher will tell you what is good for you.
Am I going to tell my son what the book represents?
Because the teacher is given a book to teach from.
That it is right when it is wrong.
Would you want the children, for the rest of the kids that are here, their parents, to feel that?
Think about the phrase that says, teacher is a God, that we teach our children.
Thank you.
Respected board members, good afternoon.
My name is Gaurav Patwardhan.
I'm from Lamersville Unified School District, where my son is currently enrolled.
I'm also here representing BJP, an advocacy group focused on ensuring the correct representation of India and Hinduism in the US.
We are deeply concerned about the state of the draft textbooks when it comes to how India and Hinduism are covered.
Inclusion of texts like the Bhagavad Gita by translators, like done with McGraw-Hill and Discovery is adverse reflection on Hinduism.
The Bhagavad Gita translation on page 280 should be replaced by the Bhagavad Gita itself, which is the most widely published Bhagavad Gita in the world and has translated in 50 languages.
The Ramayana on page 281 should be replaced by an authorized translation like the one published by Gita Press.
I also endorse the recommendations done by Professor Long and Hindupedia.
Thank you.
Namaste all.
I'm a mother of a little daughter who is going to be schooled and I don't want my kid and any other kid to read negative about my religion.
So it's my humble request to uphold the law and see to it that no derogative content is taught in our school.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, President Kirsten, board members.
Thank you for your indulgence.
My name is Alice Kessler.
I'm here with California, the largest statewide organization representing lesbian, gay, bisexual, transgender, and queer people in California and nationwide.
And I'm here today as a member of the Fair Education Act Implementation Coalition to support the Instructional Quality Commission's recommendation, which includes rejecting
And approving the 10 other programs with the edits submitted by Studies Weekly, McGraw-Hill, and National Geographic would just say that Equality California was a sponsor of the Fair Implementation Act with Senator Leno and legislation that came before that by Senator Sheila Kuehl.
You are brave and you fill so many Californians and young people in particular with hope that they will finally see themselves reflected in our textbooks.
So we would applaud the IQC on their work in getting to this moment and would urge your support.
Thank you.
I'm with the California Legislative LGBT Caucus.
We urge you to ensure that the historical contributions of lesbian, gay, bisexual, and transgender people are accurately and fairly portrayed in all instructional materials being considered for adoption in California.
Students need to feel safe and self-confident and physically in order to learn and thrive in school.
They are denied a safe school environment when they are exposed to negative stereotypes in classroom materials and school-sponsored activities.
Student studies have shown that including the contributions of LGBT people in instructional materials is linked to greater student safety and lower rates of bullying.
Your decision on these programs will ensure that only the materials adopted for use in California K-8 classrooms align with both the HSS framework and the social content standards and reflect the requirement under the Fair Education Act to include LGBT people in history and social science instructional materials.
Thank you for your time.
Good afternoon, board members.
I am Dr. Kripa Rao, a scientist, a mom, and a person from the so-called lower castes.
I have been working with the SBE and IQC very respectfully for the last four years in order to resolve our concerns on the textbook issue.
today to protest some of the allegations that were leveled on us Hindu-Americans by the South Asian History for All group, where they accuse us of assault this morning.
We came here by 6 AM, and we are peacefully waiting for our turn to speak.
Members of SAFA can start the altercation with us.
Families with small kids like ours are not mobs.
Please, SAFA, be respectful.
Also, when a representative of Sahafa had an epileptic seizure this morning, all of us went to help us with no regards to what caste such helpfulness is a part of the Indian culture.
Sahafa also don't want sages like Valmiki and Vyasa to be included in the textbooks, even though these sages belong to the lower castes like me, and they have major contributions in the field of Ramayana and Mahabharata.
Thank you.
respected members of State Board of Education.
I'm a father of an undergrad.
So my son was ridiculed and bullied in middle school as well as high school because of the disparaging content about Hinduism in the textbooks.
So it corroded his self-confidence culture.
He had grade suffered and we could easily notice behavioral problem.
Resultant emotional scars aren't fully cured even after all these years.
I hope even my enemy doesn't suffer what we suffered because of the disparaging content in that Hinduism and India has so much to offer to humanity.
Ancient Hindu scriptures are treasure trove of knowledge
and wisdom, which is pertinent even in this age.
Beetle's work was influenced and inspired by spiritual experience in India.
Civil rights movement has its origin in India.
Yoga has changed this world for a better place.
By degrading Hinduism and textbooks, future policymakers of USA are deprived of a chance to curiosity and interest in Hinduism.
Thanks.
respectable board member for this opportunity to speak this afternoon.
Ever since a nationalistic Prime Minister started leading the country, there are fringe groups who have become very intolerant of the majority belief.
And these fringe groups basically try to divide the people on the caste lines.
The Prime Minister himself is from a lower caste, the President of India, and we had
from a minority Sikh community.
He had a long beard and a moustache and there was a female quoting like a guy was killed because of growing moustache and beard, which is like not true at all.
So please consider the opinion of millions of Hindus and disregard the rhetoric by these fringe groups like Safa, who a guy from a backward class becomes a prime minister and Hindus are standing up today and voice out their concerns in case there is any attack on their religion.
So please consider the opinion of all the majority sections of the Hindus and take the rightful decision and don't let kids get bullied in schools.
It's in your hands now.
Thank you.
Hi there.
My name is Tirthankar Bhaumik.
I'm a parent of two kids in Fremont.
So I'm really concerned about the representation of Hinduism.
And thank you IQC for rejecting my textbook.
So I would like to endorse the changes which have been recommended by Hindupedia and Professor Long.
just wanted to say that America itself was discovered because of India, because Columbus wanted to find a trade route to India.
So please remember this and represent us.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Namaste my name is Sanjeevani Dej.
I am.
I do not want to be bullied when I go on 6th grade.
Hinduism is one of the oldest and all accepting religion where we have a lot of colorful festivals which we celebrate victory of good over evil.
However I heard nothing about this taught in schools.
I was is asking for dignity.
Please reject biased books as they are illegal.
Thank you.
From us the respected board members my name is Amrita Joshi I go to Rose Elementary School in Lopez.
Hinduism believes in divinity.
As it gives so much without complaint.
But looking at this picture.
that in the textbook it's shown eating trash.
Everyone knows that cows don't eat trash.
Why are you allowing such books to be taught in schools.
Content is bad and illegal.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Sridhar Jalapuram, and I'm from the Cupertino School District.
Both my kids go to the district.
I'm deeply concerned about the state of the draft textbooks when it comes to... I'm relieved to hear that the IQC has requested that Houghton Mifflin, Harcourt's K-6, and the 6-8 text be rejected.
In addition I request that the draft textbook from National Geographic ignores grade 6 ignores the history socials framework I endorse the recommendations from To recommend that our accredited sages or translations like that of AC Bhaktivedanta Swami Srila Prabhupada the Bhagavad-gita be added to the textbook the point I'm making it because is the
Texts like bhagavad-gita are translated by people from outside People are like poets and journalists who don't understand the crux of the bhagavad-gita, and they can add their own Ideas into that so we would like a genuine person to be doing it and so that's my request.
Thank you very much
My name is Shankar Das Shivagana.
I am a resident of Sunnyvale.
Thank you for giving me a chance to speak my part.
I know you've had a long day.
Okay, so I support the recommendations of IQC to reject the textbooks.
I also support the media in correcting some of the content in the textbooks.
As an American Hindu, I find the views of SAFA and groups like them to be non-representative of my views and the views of my friends and family.
Now on the topic of translations, in any academic field you sort of want the best of the best, and the tradition of Sanskrit scholarship in India goes back thousands of years, and in fact a lot of Western
A grammatical scholarship is based on the works of Patini, and I recommend that you do adopt the texts of Bhaktivinoda Swami Prabhupada.
Okay, thank you.
Good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
My name is Sridhar Raju.
I come from the Pleasanton Unified School District.
Two of my boys went to Pleasanton Unified School District.
The older one is in high school now.
One day, what happened was that my son came home and said, Dad, there is an essay I have to write on Hinduism.
And he says, Dad, I don't want to write about Brahmins because they actually did a lot of bad things.
And that's the time when I realized that there's something wrong with the textbooks.
And I went to see the content which is not representative.
So I explained to him about the kindness and the mercy and the honesty that the values that encompass the Brahmin culture.
And he wrote an essay based on that.
He got an A plus on that report.
So he came back and said, Dad, I'm proud that you really taught me.
Now is my chance to tell you that I'm really happy that your ICQ has rejected the changes, so I support Dr. Long's recommendation and Hindupedia.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
My name is Suresh and I come from the city of Saratoga and I'm here to express my concern about the textbooks that I taught teaching about Hinduism in in classes six to eight, which is not the right understanding of Hinduism to know things to understand the truth and the truth which has been there.
It's not right.
I urge to just take the
content from the right scriptures, which is a Bhagavad Gita written by A.C.
Bhaktivedanta Swami available in many languages to be the right representation of Hinduism.
Dear lovely board members, I am a father of two, and because of the problems that we talked about with so many of my friends over here, I actually took the decision that I will not send my kids to school and homeschool them.
I am actually studying with my kid as he studies.
I am going through the challenges that he does so that he can escape some of these things.
I don't want him to feel disgruntled and feel frustrated with how things are represented here.
I do support IQC.
I am against the way SIFS is representing things.
I want India and Hinduism to be represented.
saying can you actually spread the mission of love so that people don't segregate societies and people in religions and things like that and just open up their heart that's what India is that's what all humanity is all about can we do that please to the books it's humble request thank you
Respected members of State Board of Education, my name is Namrata Srivastava and I am a resident of El Dorado Hills, California.
I stand here to oppose hatred against Hindus and Indians.
I fully support the decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMH.
while some other textbook programs are good, racist, hinduphobic, and the worst in quality.
They have numerous violations of category 1 of adoption guidelines, especially category 1.10, which prohibits adverse reflection based on religion and ethnicity.
They also violate the California law, which prohibits religious discriminations.
For example,
It inaccurately shows Buddhism and Sikhism as an improvement over Hinduism, which is a clear adverse reflection and violates Category 1.0 of adoption guidelines.
Hence, I truly request you to reject HMHS2 programs as recommended by IQC.
Thank you for listening.
Hello, my name is Avinash, and I'm from Fremont.
I stand here to oppose hatred against Hinduism and Indians.
I fully support the decision of IQC to reject the two programs of HMH programs that are blatantly racist, Hinduphobic, and worst in content.
They have numerous violations of Category 1 adoption guidelines, especially Category 1.10.
And hence, I ask to reject HMH2 program as recommended by IQC.
Thank you so much.
I am in Parkmont Elementary for the Fremont Unified School District.
My school uses the McGraw-Hill text and I'm starting Ancient India and Hinduism next week in class.
I went through the materials in advance and felt from the very beginning
The text made me feel discriminated against.
It starts with something I've never discussed at home.
In fact, caste doesn't impact any aspect in my life.
Further on, I saw that the translators for excerpts from other religious texts were from that faith, but for the Bhagavad Gita and Ramayana, that is not the case.
They are using Christian translators for
I support.
Any speakers or any individuals who have signed up to speak, up through numbers 400, please sign up if you're not already in line.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Ashwin Mathew.
I'm with South Asian Histories for All.
I'm a lecturer at the University of California, Berkeley.
I would like you to consider the people who aren't in this room today.
We all have been absent from some of the hearings in the last couple of months because we have been responding to hate crimes within our own communities in this current political climate.
As you may know, that's not restricted just to the US.
Of course, this is also happening back home in India.
So as you deliberate on these textbooks and what they mean, please connect to the Muslims, the Sikhs, the progressive Hindus, the people who are of working class who are unable to make it to these hearings, whether responding to issues of violence in their own communities or because they simply have to work and cannot make it here today.
And I ask you to remember their voices, even as you hear the mass of other voices before you today.
Good afternoon.
You know, when we are talking about religion and culture, you know, we know every religion has lots of words of wisdom to share with humanity.
And our textbooks are, you know, for the future generation to train them in the right principles.
So I know that.
The content of our textbooks reflect the positives in each and every religion, including Hinduism, and not cite selected examples which might show any religion, you know, in the bad light.
So with that, I would like to quote or I would like to cite
that the most authorized version of our religion is by the scholar named A.C.
Bhaktivedanta Srila Prabhupada.
And he has shown to the world by example what real scriptures of the Vedic tradition is, which is called Hinduism now.
And I would like you to really ponder over this issue and not go by popular journalism or our so-called Sanskrit scholar, but really don't understand the religion as well.
Thank you.
Hi, respected members of the board.
I bring two good things.
One, it's going to be over real soon.
Not many people outside.
And you're not missing the California weather.
I want to reiterate the coalition of support that has been here from APAP, NCAAP, LGBT, California Hispanic Chamber of Commerce, Anti-Defamation League, and a dozen other organizations with support the rejection of these textbooks.
17 elected officials from the California... 2,000 people have spoken in the last few years, 40,000 signed petitions, about more than 10,000 emails sent and 8,000 physical letters sent, all in support of accurate and equitable textbooks.
All we ask is to reject the... the approval of National Geographic's final submission.
Thank you so much.
There are a few people behind me who are trying to not speak, but just support.
Thank you.
We support.
I support.
Support.
Hello.
My name Raj Kumar.
I am from Rewalanda, Srivastava, California.
I suggest that India still have a caste system and vast caste system.
Mostly Dalit people are being killed by the Hindus and they are name of the cow.
People are being killed by like animals.
No, no one take action.
No, any legal action have taken.
Even Babasaheb Dr. Ambedkar burned Manusmriti Hindu grants.
That's why I suggest to include Dr. B R Ambedkar books in syllabus.
are based on casteism, no one take action.
Whoever killed Dallas, I suggest delay the vote of approval, fix mistake.
Thank you.
State Board of Education.
I am Yogesh Shikde from Sunnyvale, California.
Last year, when the framework was revised, many positive contributions to Hinduism and ancient India sections were added.
National Geographic has completely ignored 20 major items from Hindu history, thereby completely erasing our history.
Contribution of Hindu lower caste sages like Vyasa, Valmiki and description of our sacred texts, the Vedas.
This is a clear violation of Category 1.2 and 1.12 of the HSS Adoption Guidelines.
This is clear discrimination against a culture causing huge number of violations of Category 1.2 and 1.16 corrections in a letter on November 6th.
We ask the SBE to accept the corrections that National Geographic has suggested so that it brings accuracy to the textbooks.
I urge you to adopt the textbooks only if the corrections that they have suggested are taken.
My friends here are here to support.
Thank you.
respected members of State Board of Education.
I'm Vasudha from Folsom, California.
McGraw-Hill Textbooks has, for example, actually inaccurately said that Ashoka became Buddhist after the war.
But in fact, he embraced Buddhism three years before the actual war.
IQC made correction in one place in last hearing after it was pointed out.
But in two places, the error still exists.
These small elements go a long way in minimizing Hindus.
So it is important to rectify them.
There are many such inaccuracies in the macro health textbooks.
I support the recommendations of Professor Jeffrey Long and 38 other academicians.
I request you to take the academic group's recommendation to address all of them.
I also request you to reject the hate against Hindus.
Thank you.
I support it.
I support.
Respected members of SBE.
On Monday, a last-minute letter was submitted to you by HMH regarding their 6-8 program that was rejected by IQC.
They have made several claims in the letter.
We would like to show how the claims are based on their subjective analysis and not the criteria as a code of regulations.
This is in front of you.
The appendix has the tables that has the data.
Here are the broad points.
One, HMH in their letter acknowledge the higher than normal volume of correction, but classify the majority of errors incorrectly as errata.
We have analyzed their changes utilizing the definition of 9510H, 9510R.
Our analysis finds their claims are not only inaccurate, but they are misleading.
We have provided grade-wise data with severity of changes that clarifies much higher volume of changes.
In our analysis, we found that 26% or 946 of changes that they submitted are very significant changes.
If we consider edits of medium severity also, the edits are considerably significant.
causing changes in the narrative.
Even with such major rewrites, it fails to solve the underlying issue of adverse reflection as defined in Category 1.10 of HSS Adoption Guidelines.
Even the changes that were submitted were incomplete, where the edits talk of replacements but don't tell full details.
No publisher content can be allowed based on a promise of change when the content itself is not known.
in the continuation of the previous speech of the Hinduism and Christianity section failed to even address the violation of Category 1.
HMH drafts are blankly racist, stereotypical and show Hinduism as inferior to other religions.
Hence, we ask you to recommend the rejection of HMH 6.2 as recommended by the National Quality Commission.
Thank you.
Namaste, respected members of the State Board of Education.
I'm Shipra Varshney from Santa Clara.
I'm here seeking Dr. Jaya's advice and team recommendations.
And I'm also here to oppose any kind of alarmist and anarchism by Hinduphobic group such as SAFA.
Thank you.
Please support.
I'm a member of SBE.
I'm from Sunnyvale, and I'm a mother of two.
On Monday, an anonymous letter was submitted to you by a group named South Asian Histories for All, SAFA.
The letter claims that the HSS framework is not being followed.
Based on this contentious.
Here we present an analysis of their demand in the letter.
The analysis is in front of you.
Firstly, in 32 of 43 revisions proposed by SAFA, the publisher's original text already comply.
to framework, but SAFA appears to be seeking deletions or alterations to this.
They are hence forcing the publisher drafts into noncompliance of framework and adoption guidelines, especially category 1.2 and 1.12.
Thank you.
If you are planning on addressing the board on this item and have numbers anywhere between 1 and 500 and 550, please line up.
Ms.
Feister?
We believe that we've had 394 speakers.
Thank you.
You may go ahead.
Thank you so much for being here.
Thank you.
Respected members of State Board of Education, my name is Patton from UBerdeen.
As a continuation from whatever the previous speaker has said, many of SAFA's suggestions are blatantly anti-Hindu and adversely reflect on Hinduism, leading to violation of Category 1.10 of the HSS Adoption Criteria and California's Education Codes.
Thirdly, SAFA is a history neglect.
But it is ironic that most of their edits in the fact call for deletion of content.
Safa blatantly even suggests the removal of a section on Hinduism in one of their drafts.
Lastly, nowhere in their letter do we see any suggestion to add the cultural or religious contribution of so-called lower castes.
Because of the efforts of HHF, histories of Hindu sages and saints from so-called lower castes were added in the framework.
Thank you.
I support.
We support.
As a continuation to the previous speaker, we thank you for your hard work in developing the curriculum framework and enforcing the social content standards.
As standards and evaluation criteria and CLR demands, each child should feel the pride in his or her heritage and develop a sense of self-quality of opportunity.
They also forbid negative stereotyping.
The bigoted and highly biased Hinduphobic edits of SAFA are directly contradictory to the law.
We have made a point-by-point analysis of SAFA's letter.
It clearly shows that the asks and the alarmism of SAFA are based on very... We also commend you for not getting alarmed by the letter and staying on course with the SBA agenda.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
Hi, my name is Mehul Bastavala.
I'm from Art of Living.
So the main points I wanted to mention was to fix the dates of ancient India and Ramayana.
So the Saraswati River dried around 2500 BC.
I've sent these letters out.
You can refer half an hour back.
And so it is around 3,000-4,000 BC is the Indus Valley Civilization, which is man-made.
There are NASA photographs that shows that it's nine feet below.
So with 0.3 millimeters, 0.4 of rise every year, it is 7,000 years old.
So I would like you to fix the dates.
Whenever like people mention about Vedas, they say like it's a thousand years BC.
No, it's not to fit that audience.
And Ramayans go all the way to 5000 BC.
That was one.
And then the other thing was include some quotes from Western authors and scientists about India so that people understand the true value and contribution and the democratic system that they had.
And also explain what yoga is.
Just give it to our staff thank you.
Next please come forward.
Dear members of the State Board of Education my name is Anshuman and I am an eighth grader at John F. Kennedy Middle School in Cupertino.
As an American student I should not be labeled on the basis of what we believe in at the
The analogy would be like seeing white Americans solely as perpetrators of slavery.
My concern is about the wrong portrayal of Hinduism in textbooks by using denigrating pictures of trash and pigs.
The discovery textbook shows the slums and asks the students to identify.
that Hinduism is only about caste.
I request you to remove these wrong pictures about Hinduism and show the positive contributions that Hinduism has done to the world.
Thank you.
I support.
Respected board members, my name is Satyaj Choudhury.
I'm serving as the president of the Overseas Volunteers for a Better India.
and we represent over 100,000 Indian-American families across all faiths in the US.
There's a whole bunch of crazy stuff that has been written about India and Hinduism in the textbooks.
Let me just quote one of them from Einstein, what he felt about India and its heritage.
So what he said was, we are deeply indebted to the Indians.
They have shown us how to measure and count.
If we had not known their invention of zero and the facility it affords in counting, we wouldn't have made any invention, Einstein had to say about India.
Another one by Oppenheimer.
Access to the Vedas is the greatest privilege this century may claim over all previous centuries.
My request is that there is so much richness that these great thinkers have seen in India.
And I request that we please include these in the California textbooks and edit.
So please include them.
Thanks.
Hello, my name is Lamitard here, and I'm currently in 10th grade.
When I was in 6th grade, we were learning about ancient India and the textbook we used.
I was very shocked to see this discriminatory example in the textbook.
When we went out for lunch, a few of my classmates asked me taunting questions about whether this was normal in India, and if all Indians lived in such dirty conditions.
This comment really hurt me, and I did not want my classmates to think of my culture in such a bad way.
A recent survey on bullying conducted among history said that about one
More respondents have been bullied within the past year with about a third saying those bully who bullied them Are we're making fun of Hindu traditions?
I am afraid this number will keep growing if false and biased information about Hinduism continues to be part of the textbooks I strongly urge you to continue to reject hardcore As recommended by IQC as they have the same problems as before.
Thank you.
I support I support
I would like to applaud IQC for rejecting the Harcourt programs and thank the department for having me here.
However, I am appalled at the racist content portrayed by McGraw-Hill, Discovery, in addition to HMH.
This content is not only deliberately misrepresentative of Hinduism, but goes directly against California state law, namely Educator 160040.
Also, the bullying report released by HAF highlighted, quote, one out of every three respondents said they had been bullied for religious belief, half indicated social isolation.
As a student, it is unacceptable to allow this sort of discrimination and bullying to occur at the expense of Hindu-American children.
While also disseminating, once again, to reject both HMH programs, McGraw-Hill, and Discovery for their blatantly racist information on Hinduism.
Thank you.
I support.
Respected board members, thank you for giving us an opportunity to come and speak in front of you, showing our concern.
I just want to let you know that it is strange that fringe Hinduphobic group, South Asian Histories for All, SAFA, is asking to
content in the section on Hinduism and ancient India in all textbooks is about caste.
No other section discusses social structure of its civilization in such a detail.
It sounds hollow when they say caste is being erased.
No one is trying to erase it.
Such a way as to perpetuate hatred against Hindus.
They are trying to add a Hinduphobic view of caste into the textbooks.
We are not saying cash should not be discussed, but it should be neutral.
Thanks for giving me the opportunity again.
Thank you.
I support this.
Thank you all for coming.
I appreciate your comments.
Next person come forward, please.
Thank you so much.
Respected members of the state board of education, I stand in front of you to speak against the support of Asians, LGBTQ community, and numerous Hindu, Jain, and interfaith groups, academics, educators, as well as the thousands of Hindus and Indians across California.
It is sad that the textbook have become a battleground.
It is a tool to spread the political views of few people.
It cannot be the place for such shrillness.
We want our children to become respecting each other and not start to hate each other right from their school days.
I stand here to support Geoffrey Leung and 38 other academicians.
I request that the recommendations by them be accepted in all forms to solve this problem.
Thank you.
If there are any remaining speakers for item number 18, now would be the time to line up.
This is the last call for any speakers for item number 18.
Go ahead.
In the history of the State Board of Education.
I didn't know I was going for a record.
So, good afternoon.
Is it still not up?
It's on the computer.
Okay.
You can start without the motion.
Go ahead.
So I thought that I would go ahead and since it was since this morning and it's now the afternoon that I would remind the board of what we talked about this morning regarding the process that the Instructional Quality Commission conducted in order to make their recommendations to you here at the state board meeting today.
A little bit further than that, when the reviewers were conducting their independent deliberations, we were then collecting all of the public comment as the independent reviewers were conducting their review.
We collected those in a Box.com account and dispersed them to each individual panel.
deliberations.
At the week-long deliberations, the panels also received public comment twice a day during that process, went through their deliberations, came to a consensus, and developed their report of findings.
The report of findings was posted on the CDE website and forwarded to the Instructional Quality Commission.
and put together another Box.com account so that all public comment was there, available for everybody to see, forward that to the commissioners.
On August 17th, we had a public hearing where we heard from over almost a hundred public speakers.
Again, we collected public...
Comment and during August 17th all the way to September 27th.
We continue to Collect public comment and provide that to the commissioners so that they were fully prepared on the September 26 27th IQC meeting at the IQC meeting on September 27th the subject
the public comment that they had heard from all of that, the deliberations, the public hearing, and what has been collected between the public hearing and the IQC meeting.
They also looked at the report of findings from each of the panels, and publishers submitted comments as well.
They took all of these pieces in consideration, so it was a unit of public comment.
comment and the report of findings to determine which edits and corrections would best help the instructional materials align with the content standards and align with the framework along with the evaluation criteria adopted by the State Board of Education.
So they would consider all of this data as you would say
to the state board that you can see in the advisory report.
So I just want to remember, remind everybody of our full process that the IQC conducted in order to make their recommendation to you today.
Do you have any questions?
Are there board member questions?
Go ahead.
I would, I think maybe our leader, Rocker, ought to lead off on these questions.
Thank you.
I wanted to ask just a few questions.
I was taking some notes during the public comment.
In public testimony and then in the written correspondence, there were repeated references to McGraw-Hill, grades six through eight, and National Geographic that require corrections.
And if you'd address the rationale for proposing these materials for adoption and clarify the process for ensuring that the necessary edits and corrections will be made.
Yeah, for the audience, let me just say we have two board liaisons who work with this and oversee all the technical changes.
So we do this for various areas that we work in and the board member Sandoval, board member Rucker have our liaisons to
get into every detail during the entire process.
That's why I asked these two to begin our questioning.
Go ahead.
So, with McGraw-Hill and National Geographic, each of the panels, again, conducted their thorough review, and this is alignment to the content standards and to the framework and the evaluation criteria.
The IQC, that needs to determine some corrections along with the public comment, and so the public comment that we heard about was also considered during the IQC's recommendations, and some of you can find even incorporated into the advisory report of the Instructional Quality Commission.
So those programs and the IQC that's determined if they met the standards and the content of the framework, they found that they did along with the edits and corrections, and that was a part of their recommendation.
And then the process part is that we have the 60-day timeline for all of that, for the publishers to submit their edits and corrections.
It's important to state that the documents we're seeing today for the adoption only contain what are the recommended edits and corrections.
We actually don't see the actual edits and corrections in the content of the drafts that are up to this point.
Drafts that you see online from a link to our website are only the draft versions that the reviewers initially saw.
None of the edits and corrections that are in the advisory report are reflected in the instructional materials posted.
You will not see those final versions until after the edits and corrections have been verified.
So that's preparing for February.
actually start their own review for making adoption decisions.
The content will have been edited and corrected in the published versions that will be available for purchase.
Yes.
Board Member Sandoval.
And just one more clarifying question.
We also heard repeated references to Bethulong and if you could tell us how those were considered?
Absolutely, I have actually examples of four, I just picked several examples that came from the Jeffrey Long document of 925 that were incorporated into, specifically I just chose McGraw Hill, and we have several of them that have been incorporated.
Phrase is to be replaced with the following historians have found many clay seals stamps statues and figurines in Harappa some of these show features that are all present in Hinduism today such as male and female figures and made meditative pose that resemble different deities as well small clay figures in traditional greeting poses Every long document and incorporated into the IQ sees edits and recommendations in their advisory report.
That's just one example.
I
Yeah, there were other examples.
Yes, I have several other examples.
We're not going to go over them all today, but we did use that document for some of revisions.
Yes.
Other comments by the liaison?
important to say, as it's been noted, this is an adoption that has gotten a lot of attention from many communities and from many, many stakeholder groups over the long course of the development, both from the framework to the actual training of the reviewers to where we come to today.
It's really important to recognize the hard work of all the reviewers, all of the content, folks who did the study of these documents and these books, of the publishers who are being recommended today, who paid attention to and heard the concerns that were raised from many communities.
It's also important to recognize
that while this adoption is different because it's a personal history and it's not just somebody else's history, it's her story, it's his story, it's our story, this does not resolve the conflicts that many people feel are in history.
That's not the purpose of our adoption is to settle all family disputes.
That's not the purpose of having this, of having a, creating a curriculum.
The purpose of creating the curriculum is to do what we saw modeled here, to have a dialogue, to have disagreements, to let people talk about what the issues are, why those are issues, and why they are so very personal.
All throughout this conversation, both Nikki and I contributed to that conversation.
We talked about how our own personal histories, our own personal dissatisfactions were with what was written in the framework and what was identified textbooks that were provided.
So we shared our concerns as well.
But it wasn't to share our concerns saying that we were the ones who knew or that we were the ones who truly understood.
It was to make sure that we gave to the committee the charge to be responsible, to be deliberate, to be thoughtful, and not only have the criteria,
and how they understood and identified who the experts were and why that expert contribution was very important to framing and to filling in the content and our true understanding about what it is that California wants the curriculum to provide and that California wants our students to get to read.
So I want to make sure, again, we reiterate our thanks to all those who submitted letters, to all those who traveled many, many hours, many, many times to come here to give their one minute of testimony.
While you may feel frustrated by that one minute of testimony, the publishers heard what you said.
and the decisions that we're tasked to make today are informed by those many hours of single minutes of communication, of passion, of conversation, and testimony.
I also want to make sure we recognize the hard work of the staff to make sure... was thoroughly done, was completely offered, and
completely managed so that everyone had the appropriate opportunity to participate and did not feel ostracized or kept out or not allowed to participate.
Wrangling a whole lot of folks to make sure that they could come here and be able to participate, included and felt heard, happened because we have a commitment of staff who believe in the process that we've put together to make this adoption happen.
But more importantly, I'm very proud of the work that our writers have done in putting the framework together and in crafting the criteria.
We will not resolve today by any action we take.
But that's the good news, because it is a conversation, and it is a question, it is a debate that we should continue to live with.
I want to remind you, because I heard a lot of comparisons in this debate about Martin Luther King.
Martin Luther King was not the owner in our community
leader that many people will quote.
But more importantly, for all of those folks who have very strong beliefs and who have very strong convictions about what this curriculum is supposed to give to us, we think we've modeled the way this curriculum should be used and the way this curriculum can be developed that we started with over two years ago.
So I want to thank all the stakeholders and all of the folks who were involved in this process up to this point.
Board Member Sandoval, do you have any other comments?
Yeah, just that I've witnessed the process from the framework revision and adoption all the way and I feel that the CDE and the SB staff, the reviewers, the thousands of members of the public have really made a profound and positive difference in the educational materials that will be available to all of our students in California.
Stakeholders, thank you for using your
strong.
Your agile minds just to follow the process.
It's so complicated and involves so many people.
And just for having the will to ensure that we're fulfilling our responsibility to all of the students in California to provide educational.
And this really will serve to build key understandings that our young people need to advance academically on to college and career.
But we'll also go a long way to improving school climate nurture relationships between people from different backgrounds and beliefs and foster a stronger sense of.
to make a motion if there are no other... Well, we have a chance now for more board member comments and observations.
Board member Strauss.
So, first, I just want to thank all the public who has been part of this process all the way through and for your voices and for the research that you've shared.
And I think...
principal parent and a now grandparent, that we want the best fair education for all of our students, and we don't want bullying for any of our students.
And we share that for you.
We are working very hard to create fair and well-developed materials.
to invest in the teachers and the leaders who will do the work at the schools.
And I think our legislature and a member record reported our last board meeting that they've invested and given us some money to help develop even more materials.
But we have a commitment that teachers will get the training they need to understand what districts will understand.
This is this process is not over at all And I think um, I just want to then personally thank member sandoval and member rucker for staying through the whole process All the hearings all the edits everything.
Um, I think all of us so appreciate the diligence that you all have shared in this process um, and then I um
I think you said it was 10,000 pages of comments and have tracked them all, have helped the members of the framework committee and the IQC go through the process.
I don't think people realize always what it takes to help support this process.
We just so much appreciate what the staff's role has been and it's been extensive So I just wanted to share thank that and then also let the parents know that we really hear what you're saying And we want every classroom in California to do a really good job of giving a broad and fair educational Thank you
I wanted to say that this framework has a major overhaul, in part led by the California Supreme Court, concerning our civic culture and civic participation.
It really, I think, will be noted nationally for
people in civic participation and we certainly had a lot of people today.
So this is in some ways a classic example of American civic culture and participation and the chance to be heard.
So the framework has it and we had some action today.
Other board comments?
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Yes, I also want to thank all the public, the parents, and in particular the students that came to exercise their voice and civic and engage in civic engagement.
This is your history.
This is, so thank you for coming.
You know, I think that as a parent of two young children, I also want to see my Mexican-American kids reflected value through our materials and our curriculum and our history.
I want them to learn from others and I want others to learn from them.
And I think it's important and I think we've all been very mindful.
We want to be mindful of honoring, valuing, and portraying our religions and histories and ethnic backgrounds in the most accurate way.
And I think that this process definitely seems like that is what we did.
We make sure to hear by the framework.
Today, we know that this is a sensitive topic because it's a personal topic.
History is personal.
But rest assured that many of us are very dedicated to making sure that our students, our histories are properly reflected.
And so with that, I want to make sure that I don't let a comment go by.
The fact that my ancestors were already here, as well as board member Sandoval's ancestors.
So let's correct history and make sure that our kids know that.
Thank you.
And while we're correcting history, we already know Lincoln did not free the slaves.
Board member Valdez.
Thank you.
All of the teachers who did the arduous work of taking it back to their homes, schools, or their tables and putting out all those materials.
Years ago, I was on the IMAP Committee on Instructional Materials Adoption Panel.
So I understand the vetting and the initial training and then the going through the adjudication and all of that.
So it is a process that has to work today.
I think we did make history today.
And once all of these or whatever programs are approved, districts will have choice.
And one of the speakers talked about, they're still talking about a precedent two terms ago.
And so we need to have these materials.
And I think that they're going to be very exciting.
And a good framework was the foundation for the publishers to create these materials.
So I thank you for your work and congratulations.
Okay.
I think we're ready for a motion.
I move approval of the CDE's recommendation, one, to adopt the 10 instructions recommended by the Instructional Materials Commission, two, direct CDE staff in conjunction with members of the IQC and or content review experts as needed to evaluate whether publishers have made the IQC recommended edits and corrections, social content citations, and Publisher errata specified in the Instructional Materials Report to be adopted instructional materials.
In the case of inconsistencies between the IQC-recommended publisher errata and the IQC-recommended edits and corrections and social content citations specified in the advisory report, the IQC-recommended edits and corrections should take precedence over the publisher errata.
And third, pursuant to Education Code Section 60200E, specifically find, based on the Instructional Quality Commission Advisory Report, that fewer than five programs met the criteria for adoption in kindergarten through fifth grade.
We'll second that motion and I want to make a note that the panels there were 12 panels 10 of the 12 panels of programs are being recommended the two that were not Recommended the IQC strongly agrees that they should not be recommended and by taking this To recommend those two programs as well All right any further discussion from the board I
I'm pretty sure it's your hands.
Carries unanimously.
Thank you.
We're now on to the item for SBE priorities and we're alphabetical rather than by your identification sign.
Member Burr, you are at the beginning of the alphabet.
My reports are finished.
I did the screening committee and you heard a lot of information about the collaborative.
Yes, our next collaborative is the first Thursday of December here in the department.
Next is board member Holliday.
Go ahead.
Sorry, you caught me too quickly there.
First of all, it's kind of ironic that the longest meeting we've had in years had no charter items whatsoever as part of it.
But I think that's going to change for the next meeting or so, from what I hear.
In terms of the Environmental Literacy Steering Committee, the committee will meet in this room again and celebrate the end of the second year of the existence of the committee.
And it will also announce that the committee is working with, I think it's like,
both Southern California as well as Northern California to create model plans for how environmental literacy can be infused in the LCAP process and therefore get into the classrooms and be a significant part of the entire curriculum.
So the Environmental Literacy Steering Committee is hard at work making progress at the district level and I'll be updating you more in the months to come Good board member gray You're next on the
Yeah.
Somebody did this wrong.
Well, I'd still be happy to talk about two things.
One about what I did over this past week.
And also, I wanted to make a comment earlier, and I was kind of nervous.
So maybe I'll make that.
The SAVE conference, which was great.
It was great to see student voice, student civic engagement.
That's something that's just great to see.
And it's great to see just
the wonderful ideas that students have and are willing to offer when, you know, given the platform, as you guys I'm sure could tell you, I also got the opportunity to meet the candidates for the next year SBM position, which is a little weird because I just began the position, but you know, the kids are great, and I'm really excited for next year, I guess, even though my term just began.
With that being said,
the adoption of the new curriculum.
As like a history nerd, history is my favorite subject, I've definitely also, you know, felt the pain and the disappointment of not always having my culture and my identity, I guess, accurately represented in the textbooks I read.
And even for the process, I can say that I'm proud that I'm here today as we're adopting this.
So I guess that's a little update.
Yeah.
Great.
OK, I am next on the list.
I attended a two-day conference sponsored by PACE on continuity.
It was a by invitation group of, I don't know, 60 or so people, and really got into trying to grapple with it and apply it.
And I learned a lot.
So it was a very interesting exercise and worth my time.
So you heard from board member Burr regarding the screening committee.
For me, the only update is on the health education framework.
The committee will be meeting November 29th and the 30th.
And this is the fifth meeting, with our last one being in January, and those are open to the public.
Which is now being integrated into the framework.
And at this point, the Health Education Framework Committee is working to go through all the chapters and submit to the Instructional Quality Commission after the January meeting.
So please stay involved.
Thank you.
Board Member Rucker.
representative on the Interstate Compact on Educational Opportunity for Military Children.
This is the State Council General Business Meeting.
California, by an act of the legislature, created this compact to deal with issues of children who are military dependents who are
are stationed at multiple military installations throughout the state of California.
And so we deal with their transfer in or attendance issues.
The compact meets four times a year and this was our second meeting for this schedule.
Third meeting, I'm sorry, for this conversation.
what to do with the federal requirements that was added with the Every Student Succeeds Act to have an identifier for students who are military dependents added to our state student data system.
That is a conversation that is still ongoing and work is moving forward.
I'm working with board member sound of all concerning the history social science Adoption and the front development of the curriculum and the framework having done the adoption today I'm looking forward to working with Stephanie and her unit on the next steps which include finishing up the adoption and doing the public
I'll be a fly on the wall listening to some very creative people who are discussing activities and ideas for those workshops.
But I do and I'm looking forward to seeing the rollouts happen and to seeing the other work that will be done to support the implementation of the frameworks.
And that's all I'll do.
First, California State Summer School for the Arts.
On Monday, Pixar Animation Studios hosted a benefit screening of their new feature, Coco.
And the California State Summer School for the Arts alum, Adrin Molina, was the screenwriter and supported the school.
is going to help ensure that all admitted students are able to attend this extraordinary pre-professional program, regardless of ability to pay.
So it's wonderful to have that partnership.
And then related to visual and performing arts, on September 27, I mentioned Accepted 2018.
Performing arts standards draft guidelines for advisors and advisors will convene early next year to work on the revision of California's visual and performing arts standards Which will be aligned to the national arts standards the Advisory Commission on special education met on October 11th and 12th and
We got a summary of the work related to the preliminary education specialist credential, and that continues to be a work in progress.
And commissioners offered feedback on the possible models for a changed special education credential structure.
And the theme is that both general education teachers and special education teachers must be prepared to differentiate instruction and read and implement an IEP, an Individualized Education Program.
And the commissioners also reviewed statewide assessment results.
In math or English language arts, there was an incremental increase.
And commissioners reviewed the designated supports and accommodations, learned about the CAST field test.
Of particular interest is the Cognitive Lab, which is a study to determine how visually accessible versions of technology are against item types.
And then LPAC Cognitive Labs will evaluate accessibility of items for blind or deaf student populations.
Then just a final note from the Advisory Commission on special education the commissioners have a great interest in the health framework discussions In all grade levels, so I just wanted to bring that Forward just to always I'm sure I know you have that in mind too, but I just wanted to make that that point Thank you.
Hey board member Strauss.
I
So I just wanted to talk about a CTC event.
And they did quite a bit of talk.
They're using a dashboard like we're trying to, we're developing our dashboard.
And they're looking at lots of data around teachers and how long they stay and their passing scores.
And they actually did a whole standard setting on their new science test, which is aligned to the Next Generation Science Test.
And it's something to talk about.
are saying they revised their cut scores.
So it's just alignment to the similar kind of new test and trying to get it aligned.
They are having problems with people passing the physics test.
So as we look at science implementation, we'll probably have to think about that.
Also, there was quite a bit of discussion about a child development permit with a lot of concerns.
education teacher field, they're experiencing a huge shortage in preschool teachers as well, and kind of looking to make the coursework more rigorous and structure it, but also worried about getting people into the field teaching preschool before they come to us.
As far as last week,
It's their second one they've done.
It was wonderful.
It had 300 or 400 people there.
They had wonderful sessions, both by people who worked on the framework, some of our CDE staff on ethnic studies.
Tom Adams and I were there.
It was a wonderful, wonderful energetic, but we have lots of work to do, we know, in rolling out history.
Those are about 100 people from around the regions of California that are building capacity in math and science so that they can go back to their regions and help do professional development.
They're having a separate meeting now to make sure that all the regions of California where people have lots of work to do, as you know, with our math scores and the needing to build capacity for teachers, and we will as we continue to move forward in science.
On Monday, I was on accountability.
I was in Santa Cruz meeting with the counselors.
And I just wanted to highlight one piece.
Santa Cruz did their first summit for... Riverside County.
But as we've been talking about multi-tiered systems of student support and instruction, they're talking about multi-tiered systems of student support for counselors.
And so that concept of what we do for all kids, what we do for some, and what we do for a few, I think we'll carry through in our theme.
I wanted to highlight that.
And then...
in Santa Barbara Unified.
That's a larger unified district.
We also have a state steering committee on standards implementation.
That's a small group, CDE, state board, and CESSA, the county office, taking a look at what we need to do.
And we also, in addition, are looking at a line of how to communicate.
quite a bit about the social-emotional learning.
You're going to hear more about that.
We have a committee working on that as well.
And the last thing, talking about civic engagement.
Last Friday, PACCRES met.
That's the group that works authentic assessment for college, career, and civic readiness.
And they're spending a lot of time looking at civic practices.
Authentic engagement.
I think we'll hear a lot more about that as we do continue to roll out in the history framework But there's a think group that's working with state board and CDE and county people thinking about this along with some researchers So that ends my report.
Thank you board member Sun
committee is still new.
We're not even a year old yet.
And so thus far in the last four meetings, we've explored various topics like data across systems and opportunities for data sharing, successful career training programs across the state, and various agencies supporting career guidance programs.
is that all of these disparate entities, programs that have launched over the past decade or so to address preparation of students for careers is starting to form partnerships, some regionally, some at the state level.
So we're seeing a lot more collaboration among
The bad news is that we still have a long ways to go.
So the systems still do not speak to each other.
The data systems don't speak to each other.
We're using different vocabulary.
There's a lack of knowledge about other institutions.
So we've discovered that and we've
Support for instance the CCI and I'm not sure that we've got those aligned either So there's still a lot more work for us to do We've been on a reconnaissance mission over our last four meetings and we are looking moving now towards some policy meeting Board member Valdez
Okay, I'll bring it home.
I have represented the board at a joint meeting, and I think it's the third time in 20 years that they all came together.
So it was the executive director of the California Teaching Commission.
University California and Cal State Universities as well as private colleges come together and a big topic that day had to be with a special ed Certification and and really was about recruitment and what's happening.
How does our accountability system impact the candidates that are coming into?
the workforce and get more quality teachers in place.
So that was exciting and it was a great opportunity and just nice to see that they're all together and talking and it really looks at that continued articulation and the vertical articulation, if you will, is happening.
The first one that they've ever had and so that was a good opportunity to really meet and talk about the needs of special ed I have a special ed background and I think that's something that is Lots to happen and especially with the Teaching Commission and looking at credentialing for teachers.
So those are the two things I was involved in Public comment General public comment is there anybody for that on items not on our agenda
We are checking.
Any members for public comment, please step to the podium.
We just called... While we're waiting for that, could I make one statement?
These are for items that are not on our regular agenda.
Were you... I hope we were clear on that.
If you're speaking on an item that was on our agenda, then your chance is gone.
Okay.
worldwide and the thing is you know in India many languages are taught when you're small when your brains are developing not when you reach the high school so if you have languages then what happens is when speaking Sanskrit it's like brain waves you know you can study other things better for kids and adults
So by just teaching English, you lost the age from 10 to 15 years when they reach high school, when the brains are developing.
So I would suggest that in your language forum, you look at, you know, promoting, teaching, teaching Sanskrit and all that.
So the whole thing about Vedic mathematics and Sanskrit, you know, think about it, you know, it's like leapfrogging your consciousness, I feel.
Thank you.
Okay, that concludes the public comment.
We have no signups for public comment.
Okay, thank you.
All right, the board is adjourned.